EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT COMMITTEE
WILL COME TO ORDER- THE THINK
THE MICROPHONE WAS OFF HALFWAY
THROUGH THIS OF ME SAY THAT
AGAIN THE SENATE REPUBLICAN
POINT INRETIREMENT COMMITTEE
WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD
AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO THE CO
IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING A FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS THE
SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC NEEDS. TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE- IN THE- STREET BUILDING I
ASK ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
TO BE PRESENT IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED PLEASE SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM- IN BEGINNER
HEARING LET ME NOTE THAT I'M
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE HAVE TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO. ARE HELD
UP IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE
CURRENTLY THEY'LL BE HERE
SHORTLYDUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEAN PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS
MAY INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIR.ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME THEIR
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES- THIS IS A IMPORTANT IN
WE WILL ENFORCE OUR INCLUDING ON
THE TELECONFERENCE ON. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW YOU SEE THE
SIGNS ON THE TEACHERS FOR
DISTANCING AND WILL BE USING
THAT TOLD COVER SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WE WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN. NO ONE ELSE IS NOW.
TODAY'S PARKED NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX
THREE. AGAIN 877-226-8163 THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN SIX TWO.
TWO FOUR SIX TWO. SEVEN SIX TWO
TWO FOUR SIX TWO IS THE ACCESS
CODE. FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECOM SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER. TO THE SENATE
WHERE THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WHEN WE MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. PRESSES
ONLY ONE TIME AND WE'RE
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
SIGN YOU ALIGN THE SINCE THIS
CAN SOMETIMES BE A SHORT WAIT.
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT. IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE ON MUTED AND YOU ARE
NOW READY TO DISCUSS THE
COMMITTEE. ADDRESSED COMMITTEES
SKEWS ME PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK
YOU MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU
WERE WATCHING. THE HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE SOME MUTE YOUR DEVICE
AND THEN GIVE TESTIMONY ON THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE- MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY. IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE SERVICE OR HAVE
THEIR CONNECTIONS. MUTED WE HAVE
TWELVE BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
BEFORE YOUR PRESENTATION ON THE
BILLS- LET'S ESTABLISH- QUORUM
IF WEEKEND A CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. COURTESY HERE
COURTESY HERE A TROUBLED THE
DESKTOP HERE THE REST SO HERE
LAYARD HERE LAYERED HERE NEWMAN. ALL RIGHT A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED THANK YOU FOR THAT-
WE ARE GOING TO PASS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AT THIS MOMENT
AND- WAIT UNTIL- ABSENT MEMBERS
ARE HERE AN ATTEMPT TO TAKE THAT
UP ALL AT ONE TIME- SO UP FIRST
IS A BILL THAT I WILL PRESENT.
IN I'M GONNA HAND THINGS OVER TO
SENATOR DRAWS- OUR OF OUR VICE
CHAIR- IT. IS ONE OF THE MEMBERS
WHOSE TEMPORARILY ABSENT
OTHERWISE SHE WOULD ORDINARILY
TAKE OVER THE GAVEL IN THE
REASON SOMEBODY'S TAKING OVER
THE COWBOYS BECAUSE SENATE RULES
PROHIBIT ME FROM SHARING AND
PRESENTING THE BILL AT THE SAME
TIME SO- SENATOR ALSO- A- YOU
OVER THE GAVEL. CLOSER E. I
THINK THE AND- LOOKS LIKE A VERY
THE WHOLE THING. OKAY OF- I NEED
THE GAVEL TO CALL CENTER LAYERED
OUT OF ORDER WHEN HE- HE MISSED
WHEN HE MISBEHAVES. USING THAT-
YEAH. OKAY THE NEW KRITISIERT
MAKE YOUR PRESENTATION ON S. B.
EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
SENATOR DRAWS SO HARD ACTING
CHAIR IN COLLEAGUES I'M PLEASED
TO PRESENT SB EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA RETIRED TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA ADMINISTRATORS. DELTA
KAPPA GAMMA CALIFORNIA IN THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WITH SUPPORT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
AFL-CIO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM IN
MORE. SB EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT WILL
ENSURE EQUITY INSTABILITY FOR
CALIFORNIA'S OLDEST RETIRED
TEACHERS. AND EDUCATORS IN
GENERAL TEACHERS THE CALIFORNIA
STATE TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM
WHO RETIRE BEFORE NINETEEN
NINETY NINE RECEIVED
COMPARATIVELY LESS BENEFITS THAN
THEIR PEERS WHO RETIRED IN THE
EARLY TWO THOUSANDS OR
THEREAFTER. COMPOUNDING THIS
THESE RETIREES OVERWHELMINGLY
WOMEN OVERWHELMINGLY WOMEN HAVE
BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
BY TREMENDOUS FINANCIAL
HARDSHIPS INCLUDING INFLATION
EROSION WHICH WERE SEEN ONCE
AGAIN TODAY INCREASE HEALTHCARE
EXPENSES AND WIDENING HOLES IN
MEDICARE COVERAGE. WELL THESE
RETIREES ARE STRUGGLING TO KEEP
PACE WITH RISING INFLATION IN
CALIFORNIA'S COMPLEX ECONOMY THE
SUPPLEMENTAL BENEFIT MAINTENANCE
ACCOUNT A SPECIAL ACCOUNT AND
CAL STIRS THE PROTECTORATE
TYRESE FROM INFLATION HOLDS A
PROJECT WILL PROJECTED ACCESS OF
ELEVEN POINT NINE BILLION IN
FUNDS. SB EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT
WOULD ACTIVELY DISTRIBUTE EXCESS
FUNDS WITHIN COASTER
SUPPLEMENTAL BENEFIT ME IN THIS
ACCOUNT TO CALIFORNIA'S OLDEST
RETIRED TEACHERS THOSE WHO ARE
MOST IN NEED. OUR EDUCATORS.
THOSE WHO GAVE THEIR LIVES TO
DEVELOPING OR NEXT GENERATION
AND QUIPPING STUDENTS WITH THE
SKILLS THEY NEED TO SUCCEED.
DESERVE RESPECT AND SECURITY IN
THE RETIREMENT AND THEY DESERVE
TO BE TREATED FAIRLY. SB EIGHT
SIXTY WILL NOT ONLY CREE EQUITY
AMONG RETIREES ALSO DRAW NEW
TEACHERS TO THE WORK FORCE AT A
TIME WHEN THEY'RE SO DESPERATELY
NEEDED IN OUR CLASSROOMS. LASTLY
I'D LIKE TO KNOW THAT THE
CURRENT BILL DOES NOT REFLECT
RECENT CO AUTHORS WE WILL MEN
THESE NEW WITH THESE NEW CO
AUTHORS AND WE'RE PROUD TO HAVE
THEIR SUPPORT- THAT WOULD
INCLUDE. A COMMITTEE MEMBER
SENATOR NEWMAN IN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOLEY BUT I TO KNOWLEDGE
THEM AND THANK ALL OF OUR CO
AUTHORS ON THIS BILL WITH ME
TODAY IS PACKED BOY. THE
CALIFORNIA RETIRED TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION A MEMBER- TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. OF ALONG WITH ED
FOLEY A RETIRED TEACHER AND
MEMBER THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION CTA THE NATIONAL
EDUCATION ASSOCIATION. TO ALSO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL
. OKAY SO. THANK YOU SENATOR WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO. PAT BOYD.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATOR CORTESE AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS PAT BOYD I'M
A RETIRED TEACHER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RETIRED TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION. I RETIRED FROM THE
REAL LINDA SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
NINETEEN NINETY ONE. ENJOYING
THE CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SYSTEM AFTER A TOTAL
OF THIRTY EIGHT YEARS OF WORKING
WITH CHILDREN IN KINDERGARTEN
AND FIRST GRADE. SPENDING TIME
WORKING WITH THE YOUNGEST
LEARNERS WAS SO FULFILLING AND
GAVE ME A SENSE OF PURPOSE I
LOVED EVERY MINUTE. AS A RETIREE
I ENJOY WORKING WITH OTHER
RETIREES AND VOLUNTEERING IN MY
COMMUNITY THROUGH KELLER TA. AS
I GROW OLDER I'VE SEEN
CALIFORNIA CHANGE MY COMMUNITY
IS CHANGING THE STATUS CHANGING
THE WORLD IS CHANGING THESE
CHANGES HAVE IMPACTED THE
FUTURE. THAT I HAVE PLANNED FOR
. CHECK YOUR EARLY THE IMPACT MY
RETIREMENT ALLOWANCE WILL
PROVIDE ME BOTH NOW AND IN THE
UNCERTAIN FUTURE. AS A RETIRED
TEACHER I CERTAINLY DIDN'T ENTER
THIS PROFESSION TO BECOME
WEALTHY. BUT THE FACT THAT I
HAVE A LITTLE CERTAINTY OF
PURCHASING POWER. THROUGH THE
CAL STIRS SUPPLEMENTAL BENEFIT
MAINTENANCE ACCOUNT GIVES ME A
SENSE OF SECURITY THAT I WILL BE
PROTECTED FROM INFLATION WHICH
IS TAKING MORE AND MORE OF MY
INCOME. SB EIGHT SIX EIGHT WILL
PROVIDE RETIREES LIKE ME. WITH A
LITTLE RETIREMENT SECURITY BY
INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF
PURCHASING POWER THAT WE RECEIVE
BASED ON WHEN WE RETIRE. FOR THE
OLDEST OF US. 80% OF WHOM ARE
WOMEN. WE COULD RECEIVE UP
21100% PURCHASING POWER WHICH
COULD MEAN WE WON'T HAVE TO
STRUGGLE AS MUCH TO DECIDE
WHETHER WE'RE GOING TO SPEND OUR
INCOME ON MEDICATION RENT OR
OTHER ESSENTIALS. JUST THIS YEAR
MY MEDICARE COSTS WENT UP BY
FOURTEEN POINT 9% HOW AM I ON A
FIXED INCOME COUPLED WITH HAVING
MY HARD EARNED SOCIAL SECURITY
BENEFITS ELIMINATED. BY THE
SOCIAL SECURITY OFFSETS SUPPOSED
TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD THESE COSTS
. S. B. EIGHT SIX EIGHT WELL
HELP RETIREES LIKE ME HAVE A
LITTLE MORE PEACE OF MIND AND
MORE FINANCIAL INDEPENDENCE SO
THAT WE WON'T HAVE TO RELY ON
OUR FAMILIES TO GET BY. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA RETIRED
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. I URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIANS RETIRED
TEACHERS BY SUPPORTING S. B.
EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS BOYD AND THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE AND TAKING THE
TIME TO COME IN PERSON. TO BE
WITH US NEXT WE HAVE INFO
GLORIA- URBANOS THAT CORRECT I
HOPE. IT IS PRONOUNCED FAURIA
THE G. IS SILENT IF MILLION
FOLIAGE LIKE AN ITALIAN. AND NOW
IF YOU SAY FOR YOUR KNOWLEDGE
MULTI. READ FULL. THEY YOU VERY
MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON- MY NAME IS
A FULL YEAR. I AM IN A MERGING
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY FOR S. B.
EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT. THANK SENATOR
CORTEZ YOU FOR CARRYING THIS
BILL TO HAPPEN HOW TO HELP THE
PALLISTER'S MEMBERS WHO RETIRED
PRIOR TO NINETEEN NINETY NINE. I
AM A RETIRED MIDDLE SCHOOL
TEACHER WHO BEGAN MY TEACHING
CAREER IN NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN.
WITH A STARTING SALARY OF FORTY
TWO HUNDRED. A YEAR. I RETIRED
IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR. WITH
THIRTY FIVE YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
A MASTER'S DEGREE AND A SALARY
OF FORTY SIX THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS. MANY WHO
RETIRED IN THE SEVENTIES AND
EIGHTIES NO LONGER HAVE THE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO CARE FOR
THEIR BASIC NEEDS WITHOUT S. B.
M. MAY BENEFIT IN SOME CASES THE
BENEFIT IS MORE DINNER BASIC
PENSIONS. DURING MY TEACHING
CAREER I WAS ELECTED PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION. IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE CTA'S SPONSORED.
LEGISLATION THAT ESTABLISH THE
SUPPLEMENTAL BENEFITS
MAINTENANCE ACCOUNT BECAUSE OF
THE HIGH INFLATION RATES OF THE
SEVENTIES AND EIGHTIES THAT
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED OUR CAL
STIRS PENSIONERS. MANY WHO UP
CANCERS LIVE LONGER THAN ANY
OTHER GROUP OF RETIRED AMERICANS
. WE HAVE FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN RETIREES OVER ONE
HUNDRED YEARS OR OLDER. S. B.
EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT WILL HELP
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FOUR RETIREES KEEP UP
WITH THE RISING COST OF LIVING.
I AM PROUD THAT CTA IS A SPONSOR
OF LEGISLATION SUPPORTING
RETIRED TEACHERS WHO HAVE MADE
TEACHING THEIR LIFE'S WORK. AND
THEY NEED TO FISCAL SUPPORT IN
TODAY'S ECONOMY AYE URGENT AYE
VOTE PINE S. B. EIGHT SIXTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER FOLIA- NOW WE WILL MOVE
ON TO ANYONE WANTING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT- AND WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH WITNESSES HERE IN THE
ROOM IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
SO IF YOU WILL COME UP. AND. AT
THIS POINT BECAUSE THAT WAY TO
SIT DOWN AT THIS POINT WHAT WE'D
BE ASKING FOR IS. YOUR NAME AND. YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE A RETIREE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF YOUR NAME AND
WHO OR HOW YOUR ASSOCIATED AND
THAT WOULD BE IT WE'VE HAD OUR
TO- EXPORT EXPERT WITNESSES
ALREADY SPEAK. THANK YOU GO
AHEAD. HI DIXON CALIFORNIA
RETIRED TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
PRESIDENT ELECT AND GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS CHAIR I SUPPORT EIGHT
SIXTY EIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HI LANA ROSE GANNON AND I AM
IN FROM DIVISIONS I'M SIXTY
SEVEN AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS SHERRY
BECK AND I AM IN DIVISION FIVE
OF COLOR TA AND I SUPPORT THE
SIX EIGHTY SIX. IT IS SIXTY
EIGHT ON THE PHONE. BECAUSE WE
IS THE DIVISION THE GEOGRAPHICAL
AREA IF YOU WOULD SAY WHAT THAT
GEOGRAPHICAL AREA THEN I THINK
MORE PEOPLE WOULD OKAY YEAH
YEAH- DIVISION FIVE IS IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA OKAY. WONDERFUL
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS DONNA HOUSER I'M A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA. A
RETIRED TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
I'M WITH DIVISION SEVENTY FIVE
WHICH IS SACRAMENTO NORTHEAST
ALLIANCE SUPPORT S. B. EIGHT SIX
EIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'M
JEANNIE HELLO AND BARTERED
DIVISION SEVENTY FIVE HE JUST
MENTIONED AND I SUPPORT EIGHT
SIX EIGHT THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M MARK ALLEN I AM A
DIRECTOR OF THE AREA IS GOING A
BRIDGE TO OREGON TO THE VALLEY.
AND I SIT ON A THE BOARD OF
CALAR TA AND I SUPPORT THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'M BOB AND
SALAS DIVISION EIGHTY THREE
WHICH IS YOLO COUNTY AND I.
DEFINITELY SUPPORTERS FOR ALL
THE PEOPLE WHO REALLY NEED IT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SANDRA
BARRERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR MEMBERS
TRISTEN BROWN CFT UNION OF
EDUCATORS AND CLASSIFIED
PROFESSIONALS PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THIS BILL OR TYPE OF
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THURMOND
BORDER DIRECTORS FOR THE
SACRAMENTO YOLO SAN JOAQUIN.
PLASTER AND EL DORADO COUNTIES
HERE WHEN YOU PASSED THE BILL TO
RAISE IT 285% GREAT TO GO TO A
100% FOR THOSE UNDER YEARS OLD
THANK YOU WE SUPPORT THIS BILL A
HUNDRED PERCENT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SCENE NO ONE ELSE HERE IN
THE IN THE HEARING ROOM WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES- WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELEPHONE CONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU'D
PLEASE PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF S. B. EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND MODERATE IF YOU CAN
GIVE US THE- OF THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WILL WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE FOR. YOU IF YOU COULD
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND CALL
IN THE SUPPORT WITNESSES
INDIVIDUALLY. THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR STUFF BROWN BOTH
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND EDUCATED
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION ARE CO
SPONSOR THIS BILL AND URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. FINE ONE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ARE THE THEORY
GOES THE DS REPRESENTING DELTA
KAPPA GAMMA CALIFORNIA WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THE CHANNEL O'MALLEY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IMPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR CALLING. NINE ONE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WON TWENTY
TWO YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M
SORRY NO RESPONSE FROM NINE ONE
TWENTY TWO. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU HAVING HEARD FROM
ALL OF THE SUPPORTERS WE WILL
NOW FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION- IS ARE
THERE ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES
HERE IN THE ROOM. IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED. NOTE SAYING NONE OF
LET'S MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY ON A VIA.
MODERATOR FEW WOULD PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF S. B. EIGHT
SIXTY EIGHT. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SB EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB EIGHT SIXTY EIGHT. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE HAVE
NO ONE CARED FOR OPPOSITION OF
SB EIGHT SIXTY. THANK YOU
MODERATOR- NUMBER A SINCE THERE
ARE NO MORE- SUPPORT AND OR
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL NOT
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
MEMBERS IF ANY MEMBERS WISH TO
ASK QUESTIONS- HE- NOW'S THE
TIME. MADAM CHAIR SENATOR
LAYERED YEAH I HAVE A COMMENT
AND THEN A MOTION AND- IT WHEN I
WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY FROM
200-022-2000 EIGHT R. WAS BUDGET
CHAIR AND AT THAT TIME 22% COST
OF LIVING INCREASE WAS OPTIONAL
AND IT HAD TO BE ADOPTED EVERY
YEAR AND I HAD ONE OF THOSE
THINGS THAT YOU DREAD- I GOT A
LETTER FROM MY MOTHER THAT I HAD
WRITTEN ACROSS THE TOP IS THIS
TRUE. ABOUT NOT GETTING THE 2%
BECAUSE SHE IS A RETIRED
KINDERGARTEN AND FIRST GRADE
TEACHER WHO IS ON STIRRERS AND
SHE'S AT THAT POINT IN HER LIFE
NOW WHERE SHE COUNTS TO HALF
BIRTHDAYS AGAIN SO SHE'S AT
NINETY SEVEN AND A HALF AND
HOPEFULLY SHE'LL LIVE TO BE IN
THE HUNDRED BUT I KNOW EXACTLY
HOW MUCH ON A FIXED INCOME MMHM
THIS REALLY MEANS AND IT MAKES A
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE IN IT I
THINK THE REAL ISSUE IS THAT.
THE RETIREMENT SYSTEMS ROAD
DESIGNED WHERE WASN'T TOTALLY
ADEQUATE IN A DIFFERENT TIME.
AND THE MANDATORY 2% AND-
WALKING IN THE 85% MOVED ALONG
BUT THIS BILL TAKES AT HOME THE
WAY IT SHOULD BE. OUR OF
BECAUSE- THEY'RE REALLY PEOPLE
THAT GAYS AND OF LOS PURCHASING
POWER BECAUSE OF THE WAY IT'S
STRUCTURED IN THIS RECTIFIED
SAID SO I THINK IT'S A GOOD BILL
AND I'M PLEASED TO MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU SENATOR LAYERED-
I ALSO. WANT TO JUST MAKE A
COMMENT THANK THE YACHT THERE
BUT TO THANK ALL OF YOU. WHO
TOOK THE TIME TO BE HERE IN
PERSON IT'S GREAT- I KNOW IT'S-
OF IT TAKES MORE TIME IT TAKES
UP. MORE OF YOU TO NOT JUST CALL
IN BUT TO COME IN PERSON AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
FOR THAT. AND THANK YOU ALSO FOR
BEING THE EDUCATORS. OF OUR
CHILDREN AND OUR- GRANDCHILDREN
ALL THE GENERATIONS THAT THAT
YOU WERE ABLE TO TEACH- WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL TO YOU. A VERY
GRATEFUL TO ALL OF YOU. ARE FOR
WHAT YOU'VE DONE FOR WHAT YOU
CONTINUE TO DO BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO IS TO
SAY. I DID EVERYTHING I WANTED
TO DO I WAS SUPPOSED TO DO FOR
THE GENERATIONS THAT I TAUGHT.
AND NOW I JUST WANT TO HAVE SOME
CERTAINTY. SOME ECONOMIC
CERTAINTY SO- I CERTAINLY WILL
ALSO. BE SUPPORTING WE HAVE A
MOTION- BY SENATOR LAYARD. OF
THE MOTION IS- BECAUSE THE
CONSULTANT SHOULD SAY THIS PART
OF IT RIGHT. THE MOTION BEFORE
US YEAH HELLO I'M SORRY CENTER
CORTESE CLOSE PLEASE I WAS
CLOSING FOR YOU. IS KIM OF YOU
BOTH DID A WONDERFUL JOB OF THAT
I THINK. SOME DISCUSSION I TOO
WANT TO THANK OF THE WITNESSES
WHO ARE HERE TODAY BECAUSE ARE
STILL EDUCATING- THEY'VE DIDN'T
SPEND A LOT OF WORK ON THIS BILL
EDUCATING THEIR PEERS OTHER
RETIREES AS TO WHAT'S GOING ON
SORRY I SUSPECT YOUR- YOUR MOM
ALREADY KNOWS ABOUT THIS SENATOR
LAYERED AND YOU MIGHT GET
ANOTHER LETTER. THANK YOU FOR
THE MOTION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
CONSULTANT. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COURTESY. BYE COURTESY I OR CHOI
BOGUE THE RUSSELL I WRESTLE
LAYERED HI LAYERED AYE NEWMAN.
WE WILL PUT THE BILL ON CALL-
FURTHER REMAIN DURING MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU. WITH.
IT IS THREE ZERO SO FAR. THANK
YOU EVERYBODY.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO. OUR SECOND BILL- THIS WILL
BE. SKINNER PORTANTINO'S BILL SB. ONE ZERO ZERO TWO IN CENTER
FOURTEEN- IF YOU'RE PREPARED TO
MAKE PROCEED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING DILIGENTLY WITH MY STAFF
SPONSORS ON THIS BILL. TODAY I'M
PRESENTING SP ONE THOUSAND TWO
WHICH LOOKS TO ADDRESS THE
SHORTAGE OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS IN THE WORKERS
COMP SYSTEM THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKERS
LCSW TO BE ADDED TO OUR STATE'S
WORKERS COMPENSATION MEDICAL
PROVIDER NETWORK. THE US IS
FACING A MENTAL AND BEHAVIOR
HEALTH CRISIS ESPECIALLY AMONGST
FRONTLINE WORKERS. LIKE FIRST
RESPONDERS HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
GROCERY STORE EMPLOYEES AND
OTHER ESSENTIAL WORKERS THIS
CRISIS WAS EXACERBATED BY THE
STRESSES OF HOPE IN NINETEEN
OTHER STATES LIKE TEXAS AND NEW
YORK HAVE MOBILIZED THEIR LCSW
IS TO HELP FILL THE NEED FOR
MENTAL HEALTH CLINICIANS.
ACCORDING TO THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION INSURANCE RATING
BUREAU THERE APPROXIMATELY SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIMS FILED EACH
YEAR HOWEVER CALIFORNIA HAS ONLY
SIXTEEN THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
LICENSED PSYCHOLOGIST AND FIVE
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FOUR PSYCHIATRISTS IN THE ENTIRE
STATE. CLEARLY THERE ARE NOT
ENOUGH MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS TO ADDRESS THE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS IN INJURED WORKERS
BY INCLUDING LCS W'S IN THE- M.
P. PROVIDER LISTINGS- THE
NETWORK ACCESS CAN BE EXPANDED
TO INCLUDE UP TO TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SIX LCSW C. TO HELP MEET THE
NEEDS. HERE TODAY I HAVE WITH ME
LISA AND BACK FOR DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR
COVENTRY AND BLUE AND A BOARD
MEMBER OF THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF PAYERS
ADMINISTRATORS AND NETWORKS. AND
HERE ARE MONTEREY AN LCSW- OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER SO WHAT RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
SENATOR WILL MOVE ON THEN TO
LEASE AND BECKFORD DONE THE
FIRST LEAD WITNESS YOU MAY
PROCEED HI GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR THAT LOVE
LOVELY INTRODUCTION- I WOULD
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
LEGISLATION S. B. ONE ZERO ZERO
TWO- AS THE SENATOR MENTIONED- I
AM FROM. THE OF COVENTRY WHICH
IS PART OF THE AND LIGHT AND
MITCHELL FAMILY OF COMPANIES-
BUT I'M ALSO HERE REPRESENTING
THE PACIFIC REGION OF THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF PAYERS
ADMINISTRATORS AND NETWORK- OUR
ORGANIZATION IS THE LARGEST
ORGANIZATION THAT PROVIDES
MEDICAL PROVIDER NETWORKS IN THE
WORKERS COMPENSATION SYSTEM. I'M
NOT JUST IN CALIFORNIA BUT IN
OTHER STATES AS WELL- AND WE'VE
BEEN DOING THIS FOR MANY MANY
YEARS. AND I AM BILL JUST TELL
YOU OFFHANDEDLY FROM MY OWN
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE THAT WE HAVE
STRUGGLED AS A NETWORK PROVIDER
TO GET THE APPROPRIATE NUMBER OF
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS INTO OUR
NETWORKS TO HELP INJURED
WORKERS- I'M NORMALLY ONE WOULD
THINK IF ONE WAS ON THE PAYER
SIDE OR THE INSURANCE SIDE THAT.
I WOULD STAND UP HERE AND SAY OH
WE'RE OPPOSED TO ANYTHING THAT'S
GOING TO COST MOM BUT IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE I THINK WE HAVE
NEARLY UNANIMOUS SUPPORT I THINK
THE SENATOR CONVENTION ON THAT
AS WELL- BECAUSE WE ALL
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS A SEVERE
SHORTAGE OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS. AND THAT'S OF COURSE
TRUE COMMERCIAL HEALTH BUT IT'S
PARTICULARLY PERTINENT FOR
WORKERS COMPENSATION- MY
COLLEAGUE WHO'S GONNA SPEAK AND
FROM A CLINICAL PERSPECTIVE IN A
MORE MOMENT CAN TALK ABOUT THIS
BUT- I'M PARTICULARLY FOR OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS PERSONAL THAT
HAVE WORKED IN HOSPITALS. PEOPLE
THAT ARE ON THE FRONT LINES OF
THE PANDEMIC- HAS RESULTED IN AN
EXPLOSION OF MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
THAT WE HAD NEVER SEEN BEFORE
I'M FROM A NETWORK PERSPECTIVE
AND OF COURSE OUR OBJECTIVE IS
TO GET THESE FOLKS TO HELP THAT
THEY NEED TO GET THEM RETURNED
TO WORK AS- QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE-
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW US. TO
UPDATE AN ANTIQUATED SECTION OF
THE LABOR CODE THAT PREVENTS US
FROM USING LICENSED CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKERS. AS PROVIDE
TYPES. WORKS IT'S SORT OF A
GLITCH IN THE LAW- AT THE TIME
THAT THIS WAS WRITTEN IT WAS
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT AND OUR
PROVIDER DEMANDS HAVE CHANGED
DOWN THE PROVIDER TYPES OF
SHIFTED. AND THIS IS SORT OF
ALLOWING US AS A NETWORK TO KEEP
UP WITH WHERE COMMERCIAL HEALTH
IS- WHERE BEARS ARE THAT ARE IN
THE NON COMP WORKER'S
COMPENSATION SECTOR IT'S ADDRESS
SO IT ALLOWS US TO. BASICALLY
HAVE ACCESS TO THE PROVIDER
TYPES THAT THOSE ON THE
COMMERCIAL SIDE ALREADY HAVE- SO
AGAIN- LEASE AND BECKFORD. WITH
COVENTRY REPRESENTING MEDICAL
PROVIDER NETWORKS ALL THROUGH
CALIFORNIA AND WE WOULD URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
LEGISLATON. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND VOTE WILL MOVE ON
NOW TO CURA MONTEREY. WELCOME
HELLO- I ASK YOU ALL TO VOTE YES
ON SB ONE ZERO ZERO TWO I AM
HERE MONTEREY AND I'M A LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER AND ALSO
AN AIR FORCE VETERAN AND A
MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
ANNALY CLINICIAN FOR OURSELVES
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND PROVIDE
EVIDENCE BASED TREATMENT TO
INJURED WORKERS AS PART OF MY
JOB AND SINCE THE PANDEMIC I
HAVE SEEN AN INCREASE IN
EMPLOYEE SEEKING MENTAL HEALTH
BENEFITS ESPECIALLY FOR PTSD- AS
LCSW THREE IN TO PROVIDE THE
BEST QUALITY CARE. ACCORDING TO
A COM GUIDELINES. AND OUR
TREATMENT HAS BEEN SHOWN TO
INCREASE RETURN TO WORK RATES
AND DECREASE THE AMOUNT OF TIME.
TAKEN OFF FOR INJURED WORKERS
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKERS
ARE ABLE TO INDEPENDENTLY
DIAGNOSE COMMON MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS. RIGHT TREATMENT PLANS
PROVIDE INDEPENDENT TREATMENT
RESPOND TO CRISES AND WORK WITH
FOR WITHIN A VARIETY OF SYSTEMS
SUCH AS EMPLOYERS. SCHOOLS
HOSPITALS JUDICIAL SYSTEMS THIS
ADDRESS. LICENSED CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKERS ARE ADEPT AT
COMMUNICATING WITH OTHER
PROVIDERS TO EFFECTIVELY
COORDINATE. CARE AND AGAIN CARE
MONTEREY. THANK YOU THANKS FOR
TESTIMONY- WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON NOW TO THE MODERATOR A
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP- ANY TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MR CARE AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
ZERO ZERO TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE ZERO ZERO TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO. OUR
FIRST LINE IS ONE FORTY TWO.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
REBECCA GONZALEZ AND I AM WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER THANK YOU SENATOR
PORTANTINO WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE. PLAN IS ONE
FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
KATIE. RIETBERG IN THANK YOU IN
pCOMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF S. B. ONE
ZERO ZERO TWO. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU- THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WHO IS
THERE ANYBODY IN THE HEARING
ROOM THAT WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AND A COLLECTED TO. ASK
I APOLOGIZE. FOR PUTTING YOU
THROUGH THE- MOMENT OF TENSION
THANK YOU SENATOR I MUST ADMIT I
HAD A LITTLE BIT OF A PANIC.
THAT'S OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY- AND
WE'RE ALREADY LISTED IN SUPPORT
I'M LORI KAMMER IN SUPPORT- ON
BEHALF OF NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF WOMEN BUSINESS OWNERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER. SMALL
BUSINESS CALIFORNIA AND THERE
ALSO A GROUP OF ABOUT TEN OTHER
SMALL BUSINESS ASSOCIATIONS- WHO
BELIEVE THIS BILL IS GOING TO
HELP BRING WORKERS BACK TO WORK
MORE TIMELY- BY GETTING MENTAL
HEALTH. TREATMENT SOONER RATHER
THAN LATER SO WE URGE YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANYBODY ELSE HERE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL-
IN AGAIN FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION- WE AS A PEOPLE STATE
THEIR NAME THEIR AFFILIATION. IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OPINION-
AS THE CASE MAY BE- WE'RE GONNA
COME BACK NOTE AND NOTE THAT ON
THIS BILL SB ONE THOUSAND TO
THEIR- THERE IS NO LISTED LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS BUT WE WILL-
ASK THERE'S ANYONE HERE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. SO PLEASE COME FORWARD
. C. NONE WAS THE MODERATOR TO
QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES ON THIS BILL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO THE SP ONE ZERO
ZERO TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SD ONE ZERO ZERO
TWO. PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
OUR FIRST COMIC COMES FROM ONE
ONE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN IT'S ALL AHEAD. HE MONTEL
MISTER ARE YOU MY NAME IS LAURA
HAIDAR MOST MENTAL ILLNESSES ARE
SHOULD THE CALL. COME FROM
DECREASED IMMUNITY WHICH IS
HAPPENING YOU'RE ONLY ALLOWED TO
SAY YOUR NAME- YOUR OPPOSITION
AND THE AFFILIATION NOT
NECESSARILY IN THAT ORDER BUT-
YOU TO SAY. A FEW OPPOSED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'M SORRY THAT'S
ALL WE CAN ALLOW EVENLY TO ALL
WITNESSES ARE WHO WERE
TESTIFYING TODAY OTHER THAN THE
LEAD WITNESSES ANYBODY ALSO
MODERATOR. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF SB ONE
ZERO ZERO TWO ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS. FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I WOULD MOVE THE BILL
RATE CENTER WHERE IT IS-
OFFERING A MOTION. BEFORE WE GO
TO THE MOTION- BLASTS- CENTER
PORTANTINO HE'D LIKE TO CLOSE.
JUST VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
EXPAND THE POOL OF FOLKS IS OUR
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS IN WORKERS
COMP NEEDS CONTINUE TO INCREASE
IN RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IBM.
THANK YOU SENATOR OF WILL GO TO-
THE CONSULTANT AND ASK FOR A
ROLL CALL VOTE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COURTESY HI COURTESY I OR CHOI
BOGUE. THE REST OF. THE DRESSER
I LAYERED. AYE LAYERED AYE
NEWMAN. THREE ALL RIGHT SO WE
HAVE THREE VOTES. IN FAVOR ON
THAT BILL AND- WE'LL PUT IT ON
CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH. AND
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON NOW TO
SENATOR SKINNER'S BILL SB ELEVEN
FIFTEEN CENTER SKINNER I THOUGHT
I SAW HER STEP IN YES THEY DID.
IF YOU'RE- IF YOU'RE PREPARED-
YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL TO
STORM CENTER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS FROM SB. ONE ONE
ONE FIVE WILL HELP US ADDRESS
THE WORK FORCE SHORTAGE WE
CURRENTLY HAVE IN THE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES. BY SETTING
UP A- OFFICE IN THE DIVISION OUR
DIVISION OF- ALWAYS FORGET THE
NAME OF ITS DIVISION OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS. TO HELP
GET INFORMATION TO WOMEN AND
HELP RECRUIT WOMEN INTO TRAITS-
WE KNOW THAT OUR SKILLED TRADES
ARE MOST ALL ARE ALL OF THEM ALL
OF THEM COULD BE FILLED BY
WOMEN- HISTORICALLY THERE'S BEEN
VIEWED AS- A MALE DOMINATED
PROFESSIONS THERE'S NOT
NECESSARILY ANY NEED FOR THAT.
THESE ARE GREAT PAYING JOBS
THESE WOULD GIVE WOMEN THEIR
FAMILIES. AND RETIREMENT
SECURITY BENEFITS SECURITY GOOD
WAGES AND WOULD HELP US BECAUSE
WE ARE WITH FEDERAL MONIES IN
STATE MONIES DURING A BOOM OF
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS AT A
TIME WHERE WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
WORKERS. SO LET ME INTRODUCE MY-
KEY WITNESSES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND THIS IS
A BILL THAT IS JOIN AUTHORED BY
THE PRO TEMAS ATKINS AND MY A.
R. KEY WITNESSES ARE MAKE VC.
WHO IS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
TRADES WOMEN INCORPORATED AND
WHEN NEEDED DOUGLAS WHO IS
SENIOR MANAGER OF CONSTRUCTION
LABOR RELATIONS AT RISING SUN
CENTER FOR OPPORTUNITY. ALL
ANYTHING SOONER ANDERSON THEY'RE
BOTH- ON THE CALL IN LINE SO I'M
IN A COLON MIG VCFIRST IF YOU'RE
PREPARED YOU MAY TESTIFY AT THIS
TIME. THANKS SENATORS AND GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE AND THANK YOU
FOR HEARING MY TESTIMONY IN THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY REMOTELY.
AS A SENATOR SKINNER SAID MY
NAME IS MADE BASICALLY I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF PRISM
INKS. I'M ALSO RETIRED MEMBER I.
D. E. W. LOCAL THREE OH TWO AND
WORK. FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS WITH
THE TOOL. PRIMARILY IN THE
REFINERIES AND COMMERCIAL
PROJECTS. IN CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY. I'M HERE. WORK IF. ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AT ELEVEN
FIFTEEN. AM HELLO THIS IS THE
FOURTH PROJECT THREE- ECONOMIC
FIFTY FADING CAREER WILL COLOR
WOMEN AND SUPPORT BY FIND YOUR
FACE IN FACT THE WORKERS. IN
CALIFORNIA. YES WE SB ELEVEN
FIFTEEN WOMEN MAKE UP 4% OF THE
CONSTRUCTION WORK FOR THE FOR
FACILITY OFFENSIVE. AND EVEN
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE FACT
INDUSTRY AS A WHOLE. INCLUDING
THE FACT OF THE FOLKS WITH. THE
NUMBERS RESPECT THAT THE LONG.
FIVE ONE FOUR ONE THE BILL. IN
THE- I ABLE TO BUILD A CAREER
BUT IT'S AM. WILL GO BACK. MY
LAW DEGREE MUCH HIS. JEFF
EXACTLY THE SEVENTH AND EIGHTH.
BOB FROM MY OVER FORTY. OF
WORKING WITH THE. FOR
BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE YOU WITH A
FEW. IN THE VERY HANDY ADDRESS
NUMEROUS THE STATES HAVE A
HIGHER LEVELS OF WOMEN IN THIS
VERY. SEVERAL OF THE PROGRAM-
HAVE. MORE THAN DOUBLE DOUBLE
STATE LEVEL. SB ELEVEN FIFTEEN
PROVIDES THE PLATFORM ON WHICH
TO BUILD CIVIC CENTER FOR THE
INDUSTRY AS A WHOLE. NO ONE AT
THIRTY IN THE FEDEX BRAG ALL THE
PIECES TOGETHER IN THE LONG RUN
WE NEED TO CONTACT ME FOR
EXAMPLE. FOR PLAN. AFFORDABLE
FROM FOURTEEN FIFTY FUNDS FOR
PROGRAMS AND EFFORTS. ARE
FOCUSED. FOR THE FULL. ALMOST
THE OF HIS IN THE FUNDS IN THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS. HUNDRED A
THIRTY FOUR FOUR FOUR OF THE
FIVE. IT WILL BE WHAT THE PHONE
OF THE COURSE CAN YOU TELL ME
POLE OF FOR THE OWNER FIVE DAY.
I KNOW ALL THESE MANY. SUPPORT
WE FOR FIVE THANK VOTER. BENEFIT
BUDGET OFFICE. EQUIPMENT BENEFIT
FROM OF WORKFORCE. FOR THE
MOBILE WE COULDN'T STAND WITH
EFFORTS FOR THE WORK FIVE. I
FEEL FIFTEEN THE FROM THE- ROOM
RIVER PARK THE EFFORT. WELL FOR
THE INCLUDES ABOUT THE FIFTH
THAT. ON THE DEPARTMENT OF IN
THE AVE. WITH NEED TEN. OFFICE
AT THE- WOULD BE PROVIDED BY
TEMPLE FOR THE AND BECAUSE WITH
THE.
SPEAKING OF THE LAND SURVEYOR
I'M SORRY FIFTEEN IS A
COMMERCIAL CARPENTER AND TWENTY
WITH THE LAND HERE. ACT THE
RETIRING I ACTUALLY STARTED
WORKING TEACHING AND TRAINING.
PROGRAM HELLO COMMITTEE BEALE
IT'S AN INDUSTRIAL CERTIFIED
CONSTRUCTION TRAINING PROGRAM.
PROVIDING A PATHWAY THAT YOU
NEED TO PRINT A SHIP'S IN THE
SKILLED TRADES RIGHT AT THE
MOMENT I'M RUNNING A TEN WEEK
HANDS ON TRAINING IN OUR
PORTLAND FACILITY AND I HAVE
WORKING. WOMEN EVERY CLASS THAT
I HAVE MARIA THEN. TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT IS THE BIG WOMEN PLUS. AND
IT- ONE ON ONE JOB PLAY
RETENTION. THE GRADUATE. CAREERS
IN YOU NEED TO TRADE. COMING
METAL WORKERS ARE IN CARPENTERS
AND- YEAH. B. ONE ELEVEN TO IT
WOULD REALLY REALLY HAVE MAKE
THIS. AND BRING IN WILL THE- I
WORK IN THE- THIRTY SEVEN YEARS
I WOULDN'T THINK OF MY- I ABLE
IN MY PHONE TO CALL HE HAS
COMPUTER IN DEGREE HE HAS NO
SIGNAL NO. HE'S NOW WANTED HEAR
IT I PECAN WITH MARIA COUNTY LAW
. SO I FOR A FACT THIS. BOB THIS
BILL PASSED. THROUGH REALLY
REALLY HELP GET MORE MORE IN
WHEN I IN WAS ONE TO. RIGHT NOW
I IT'S WORK THEM SO WE REALLY
REALLY NEED TO AND THE- OPEN Q.
R. A. THANK YOU MISTER. WE'RE
GONNA ASK NOW THERE'S ANY SO.
TESTIMONY IN THE COMMITTEE IS SO
STEP FOR. IN A WORKS UNDER THIS
- PERIOD OF TESTING. NAME THE-
IN YOUR BILL. GOOD AFTERNOON
SEARCH NUMBER JUST STAND BEHALF
OF EQUAL RIGHTS. IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WISHING TO
STEP FORWARD AS SEEN NONE A
MODERATOR- IF YOU'D PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANY SUPPORT WITNESSES ON OF
THE PHONE LINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR CARE AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN FIFTEEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN FIFTEEN. ME PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE ONE FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN SPORTS
. NINE ONE FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MATT
BROWN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT
. LINE ONE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HANG ON
BEHALF OF THAT HAPPENED. AND
WOMEN OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF ITSELF
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF
SB ELEVEN FIFTY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR- AGAIN I WANT TO
KNOW THAT THERE'S NO LISTED LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS ON THIS BILL
SB ELEVEN FIFTEEN. SKINNER IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE ROOM
WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL SO YOU MISTER FORD
AT THIS TIME. THE SCENE IN- WILL
MOVE TO THE MODERATOR AND ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. THANK
YOU MR CARE AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN
FIFTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB ELEVEN FIFTEEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE HAVE
NO ONE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
ELEVEN FIFTEEN IN Q. OR THINK
MODERATOR GONNA COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE IN A SEVERE SO ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE SENATOR
ALSO. SO GROWTH DRAWS OFFERED A
MOTION ON THE BILL- ANYTHING
FURTHER SISSY NONE CENTER
SKINNER YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
ASK FOR OUR VOTE. ALL RIGHT-
WILL GO TO THE CONSOLE AND THEN
FOR ROLL CALL VOTE. THE MOTION
IS TO PASSED THE FIRST REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS COURTESY ALL
RIGHT. WHERE DOES THE I. R. CHOI
BOGUE THE RUSSELL. THE RUSSELL I
LAYER BY LAYER HI NEWMAN. ALL
RIGHT SO THERE'S THREE VOTES IN
SUPPORT BUT WE'LL PUT OUT A CALL
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
CENTER. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
SENATOR HOMEOWNER WHO'S HERE. TO
PRESENT SB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO.
WELCOME IN THE HE MAY PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. SB ELEVEN
SIXTY TWO ADDRESSES AN ISSUE
THAT IS AFFECTING WOMEN AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR ACROSS THE STATE
THE GENDER AND RACE PAY GAP
ACCORDING TO RECENT ANALYSIS OF
PAY DATA CALIFORNIA WOMEN IN
TWENTY TWENTY LOST FORTY SIX
BILLION DOLLARS DUE TO THE
GENDER PAY GAP. AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR IN THE STATE LOST SIXTY
ONE BILLION DOLLARS TO THE RACE
PAY GAP. THE WAGE GAP PERSISTS
ACROSS INDUSTRIES OCCUPATIONS
AND EDUCATION LEVELS AND EXACTS
A HEAVY TOLL NOT ONLY ON WOMEN
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR BUT ALSO ON
THE FAMILIES THE SUPPORT. AND
THE ECONOMY AS A WHOLE. OVER THE
COURSE OF A FORTY YEAR CAREER A
WOMAN BEGINNING HER CAREER TODAY
TYPICALLY STANDS TO LOSE OVER
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
THE WAGE GAP. WOMEN OF COLOR
STAND TO LOSE THE MOST WITH
BLACK AND NATIVE WOMEN NATIVE
AMERICAN WOMEN LOSING NEARLY
NINE HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND LATINAS LOSING OF
ONE POINT ONE MILLION OVER THEIR
LIFETIMES THE WAGE GAP AS
COMPARED TO WHITE NON HISPANIC
MEN. HE TRANSPARENCY IS KEY TO
ACHIEVING PAY EQUITY. SB ELEVEN
SIXTY TO THE PAY TRANSPARENCY
FOR PAY EQUITY ACT WILL HELP
IDENTIFY THE GENDER AND RACE
BASED HE DISPARITIES BY
REQUIRING FEE TRANSPARENCY AT
EVERY STAGE OF EMPLOYMENT
PROCESS. FROM HIRING PROMOTION
AND ONGOING EMPLOYMENT.
SPECIFICALLY SB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO
WILL HELP NARROW THE WAGE GAP BY
REQUIRING THE DISCLOSURE OF
SALARY RANGES ON ALL JOB
POSTINGS. AND MAKE AN EMPLOYER
FOR INTERNAL PROMOTION
OPPORTUNITIES AVAILABLE TO
CURRENT EMPLOYEES. INCLUDING THE
MINIMUM AND MAXIMUM SALARIES AND
JOB POSTING PROVIDES JOB SEEKERS
WITH THE INFORMATION NEEDED TO
NEGOTIATE FAIR SALARIES AND HELP
BUSINESS. BUSINESSES EFFICIENT
EFFICIENTLY HIRE AND RETAIN THE
BEST TALENT THAT MATCHES THEIR
NEEDS. SB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO ALSO
REQUIRES COMPANIES TO PUBLICLY
REPORT PD THAT BROKEN DOWN BY
RACE ETHNICITY AND SEX FOR BOTH
DIRECT EMPLOYEES AND EMPLOYEES
HIRED THROUGH A THIRD PARTY
STAFFING AGENCY. MANY MAJOR
COMPANIES ARE ALREADY DISCLOSING
THEIR FEDERAL PAY DATA REPORT AS
PART OF THEIR COMMITMENT TO
DIVERSITY EQUITY AND INCLUSION
INITIATIVES AND RACIAL JUSTICE
INCLUDING HALF OF THE TOP ONE
HUNDRED PUBLICLY TRADED
COMPANIES IN THE UNITED STATES.
P. EXCLUDING HALF OF THE TOP ONE
HUNDRED PUBLICLY TRADED
COMPANIES IN THE UNITED STATES
ALREADY DISCLOSED THE STATE UP
PUBLICLY. ENSURING EUAL PAY IS
NOT ONLY CRITICAL FOR WOMEN AND
THEIR FAMILIES BUT ALSO BENEFITS
EMPLOYERS. EQUITABLE EMPLOYMENT
PRACTICES INCLUDING PREVENTING
AND ADDRESSING PAY DISPARITIES
CAN COME FOR A WIDE RANGE OF
BENEFITS ON A COMPANY INCLUDING
ACCESS TO THE BEST TALENT
INCREASED EMPLOYEE SATISFACTION
AND PRODUCTIVITY. WE MUST
INCREASE PAY TRANSPARENCY IN
ORDER TO NARROW THE GENDER AND
RACIAL WAGE GAP WHICH PREVENTS
WOMEN PARTICULARLY WOMEN OF
COLOR FROM ACHIEVING ECONOMIC
SECURITY I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION WITH
THE OPPOSITION A HOW TO TAKE
MEANINGFUL STEPS TO NARROW THE
GENDER AND RACIAL PAY GAP. TO
DATE WE HAVE JUST NEKRON AND
HANNAH HOLLOWAY THE TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU SENATOR OF
WILL GO AHEAD IN FIRST. CALL ON
I HAVE- JUST IN THE GROUND AS
THE SECOND LEAD WITNESS- HELLO%
THIS CORRECTLY TRY CALLING ON
HIM THE WHOLE WAY. SHE'S HERE.
GREAT YES. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
JERRY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ALSO THANK YOU DODD SENATOR THEM
I'M FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP. ON THIS
ISSUE. I'M HANNAH HOLLOWAY WITH
TECH EQUITY COLLABORATIVE A
PROBLEM FOR THE SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL. AS A SENATOR OUTLINES THE
BILL BEFORE YOU REQUIRES
EMPLOYERS DISCLOSE PROMOTION
OPPORTUNITIES TO CURRENT
EMPLOYEES AS WELL AS PAY SCALES
AND JOB POSTINGS IT ALSO
INCLUDES TEMPORARY WORKERS AND
PAID OUT OF REPORTS.
TRANSPARENCY IS GOOD FOR WORKERS
THE STUDY'S FINDING THAT WOMEN
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE MORE
WILLING TO NEGOTIATE AND MORE
SUCCESSFUL IN DOING SO. WHEN THE
PARAMETERS FOR NEGOTIATIONSARE
CLEARLY OUTLINED. RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT THAT'S GOOD POLICY FOR
COMPANIES TO. ADDRESS CAPITAL
CITY FOUND THAT COMPANIES THAT
PUBLICLY. RELEASED THEIR PAY
DATA INFORMATION. FORM HERE'S ON
THE STOCK BUT TWO POINT FOUR.
FOLLOWING SOME CLAIM YOU MIGHT
ABOUT TRANSPARENCY EFFORTS
HAMPER ACT ECONOMIC GROWTH OR
BUSINESS COMPETITIVENESS. THERE
ARE ARGUMENTS FROM A POSITION OF
TRANSPARENCY HURTS BUSINESSES BY
INVITING LAWSUITS. THE BILL DOES
ADDRESSES CONCERNS BUT LIMITING
THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION TO
ONLY AGGRIEVED PARTIES AND ALSO
REQUIRING ONLY ADVOCATE PAID
OFF. WHICH CANNOT BE THE BASIS
FOR INDIVIDUAL EQUAL PAY CLAIMS.
THE RESEARCHERS ALSO DOESN'T
SUPPORT THE FLOWS TO CLEAN. THE
STUDIES ON THE EFFECT OF THE
PUBLICLY START HAS ENDURING PAY
DISPARITIES ATTRIBUTED PROGRESS
NOT TO LAWSUITS BUT TO VOLUNTARY
CORPORATE PRACTICE CHANGE. SO
COMPANIES CAN AVOID LIABILITY BY
PROACTIVELY FIXING. GAPS UNDER
TO BE ABLE TO. WE JUSTIFIED
FACTOR. AND IN THE SUN.
INSTANCES OF IN. THESE SYSTEMIC
FIXES RATHER THAN RELYING ON OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM OF INDIVIDUAL
COURT CASES TO FIX THE ISSUE.
THE EVIDENCE TRANSPARENCY CAN
HELP PREVENT LAWSUITS FACT THAT
COMPANIES MIGHT BE. SUSCEPTIBLE
TO SUSCEPTIBLE TO. IN THE LAST
ELEMENT OF THIS BILL HIS
INCLUSION STAFFING AGENCY
WORKERS IN THE EXISTING
CALIFORNIA PAID OUT OF REPORTS-
THESE WORKERS ARE SIGNIFICANT
AND GROWING PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE TEMPORARY
EMPLOYMENT HAS INCREASED 75%
SINCE THE GREAT RECESSION
COMPARED TO JUST 19% OF THAT
TOTAL. ACCORDING TO PROTECT HIS
OWN RESEARCH THESE WORKERS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY LIKELY TO BE
WOMEN NON BINARY AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR. AND EARNED A FRACTION OF
THE PAY AS DIRECT WORKERS EVEN
WHEN PERFORMING SIMILAR ROLES.
THE STAFFING INDUSTRY HOWEVER
HAS LOBBIED FOR EXEMPTIONS TO
NEARLY ALL PUBLIC ACCOUNTABILITY
AND REPORTING SO WE DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHERE THIS INDUSTRY
GROWTH IS COMING FROM OR THE
FULL EXTENT OF THE DISPARITIES
WITHIN IT. SUCH A SIGNIFICANT
SUBGROUP OF CALIFORNIA WORKERS
SHOULD BE REFLECTED IN STATE
OVERSIGHT. I DON'T JUST CLOSE BY
SAYING THAT THIS BILL MEARS
CALIFORNIA PAID ON A REPORTS.
AND THE FEDERAL EEO ONE. THE
DECISION OF PAY DATA TO THOSE
YEAR ONES WAS APPROVED AFTER AN
ESTIMATED BURDEN TO EMPLOYERS
WAS FOUND TO BE MINIMAL- WHICH
WILL ALSO BE FOR THE LARGE
EMPLOYERS LIKE THOSE COVERED IN
THIS BILL. SB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO.
SIMPLY EXPANDS ON EXISTING BEST
PRACTICES TO THE BENEFIT OF ALL
CALIFORNIA WORKERS I
RESPECTFULLY HER DRIVE OFF. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
TESTIMONY JUST LIKE RON IS
SUPPOSED TO BE ON THE LINE THE
MODERATORS LINE ARE YOU THERE.
YEAH ARE YOU MAY PROCEED WITH
YOUR TESTIMONY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH I JUST WANNA SAY
THANK YOU TO MR CARE AND THE
MEMBERS OF THECOMMITTEE FOR
LETTING ME SHARE MY STORY
FAMILY- I'M A THIRTY TWO YEAR
OLD LATINO WOMAN AND I'VE WORKED
EXCEPTIONALLY HARD TO GET WHERE
I AM IN MY CAREER. I'M CURRENTLY
FOUNDER AND CEO OF RECKON MEDIA
AND I'VE WORKED IN A VARIETY OF
MEDIA COMPANIES IN MY CAREER
INCLUDING THE VIDEO GAME COMPANY
RIGHT AND- RIGHT. FROM TWO
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN- I
SERVED AS A CLASS AND TALK
REPRESENTATIVE EQUAL PAY CASE I
CAN TRANSFORM WE'RE WE OBTAINED
ONE OF THE LARGEST EQUAL PAY
CLASS ACTION SETTLEMENT IN THE
HISTORY OF THE UNITED STATES AND
THIS INCLUDED ROBUST
PROGRAMMATIC RELIEF. UNDER THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT MORE THAN A
pTHIRTEEN HUNDRED CONTRACT
WORKERS WILL GET RELIEF FOR THE
PAY DISCRIMINATION WE
EXPERIENCED WHILE WORKING AT
RITE AID WILL NOT SETTLEMENT UP
RECORD APPROVAL IN JUST A FEW
WEEKS. WHAT I AND OTHERS
EXPERIENCE. THAT RIGHT AND
SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN. WHEN I
WORKED THERE I FOUND OUT THE
PERSON WHO ROLE I PACKED BILLS
HAVE BEEN PAID. THREE HI MORE
THAN MORE FOR THE SAME JOB. IT
WAS IN THE FACE WHEN I WOULD
THEN ASK THE TRAIN AND MENTOR
THE MAN WHO GOT A PROMOTION THAT
HAD BEEN PROMISED ME. WHEN I
STARTED ASKING QUESTIONS ABOUT
MY K. COMPARED TO THE PAY OF
MYSELF HERE'S IT NEARLY BROKE ME
WHEN I WAS TOLD IN NO UNCERTAIN
TERMS. THAT I HAD NO BIG LOSS
ASKING TO BE PAID AT THAT LEVEL.
LIKE MANY WOMEN I'M TIRED OF
PROVING MYSELF IN THE WORKPLACE
BEING TRUSTEDWITH MORE
RESPONSIBILITY AND EARNING
POSITIONS OF LEADERSHIP. ONLY TO
BE FEATURED ISLAND THE SUBJECT
TO PAY COMES UP AND IN SOME
CASES OUTRIGHT. HELLO HEY
TRANSPARENCY IS VITAL TO MAKE
SURE MARGINALIZED WORKERS ARE
EXPLOITED. IF WE'RE UNAWARE OF
THE INEQUALITY IS IMPACTING US
WE CAN'T APPROPRIATELY ADVOCATE
FOR OURSELVES. TRANSPARENCY KEEP
LEADERSHIP ON THAT AND KEEP
EMPLOYEES INFORMED EVERYONE WINS
WHEN YOU VALUE YOUR TEAMS AND
THEY CAN CLEARLY. SEE THAT
THEY'RE BEING VALUE. HI OF THE
SETTLEMENT ALSO. CON KENNEDY IN
THE OF A YEAR THIRTY IN THE- OF
GENDER EQUITY. PAY OR JOB. IN IT
REQUIRED RIGHT GAINES PHOTOS TO
WORK THE STATE KIND OF EIGHT DE
AND- THAT WOULD BE TO BE TO.
UNDER THIS BILL. I ONLY BECAME
AWARE THAT I WAS UNDERPAID
COMPARED TO MY MALE PEERS
BECAUSE SOME OF THEM HAPPEN TO
BE WILLING TO TELL ME WHEN I ASK
THEM OUT RIGHT. THE BAD
EXPERIENCE IN MIND I TRULY DON'T
BELIEVE ACCOUNTABILITY WILL
HAPPEN WITHOUT INTERVENTION
WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
DESERVES TO KEEP EARLY FOR THE
WORK THAT WE DO AND WE DO HAVE A
TRANSPARENCY COMPANIES
ACCOUNTABLE AT THE STOP HARMFUL
. OF ALL OF. THE THAT IN MIND A
STRONG URGE COMMITTEE TO SB
ELEVEN TWO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR CURRENT. OKAY THANK YOU FOR
TESTIMONY WE'RE GONNA AUTHORS
ANYONE THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO IS
TO SO FORWARD. WITH POSITION ON
THIS. GOOD AFTERNOON MR BURKE
JUST CENTER ON BEHALF OF EQUAL
RIGHTS. PRACTICE FONG IN THE-
AND ALSO AND- ON BEHALF OF STRAW
FOR. EQUALITY CO. YOU C. W. STAY
COUNTS AND WAS A FROM. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS VERY CLEAR SHE
ARE ABOUT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PLUMMET LAWYERS ASSOCIATION ALSO
PROUD TO SPONSOR OR DO SUPPORT.
HI MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I'M SANTA
GORDON I'M WITH TECH EQUITY
COLLABORATIVE WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSORS AND I'M ALSO OFFERING A
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF HEALTH THAT
WORKERS UNION AND THE WAREHOUSE-
WORKERS RESOURCE CENTER. IF YOU
. I THINK IT WAS THE CARE
MEMBERS RENEE BAYARDO AS HERE
YOU CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT.
OKAY THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO. EXPRESS SUPPORT-
WILL GO THE MODERATORS SO LINE
THE PHONE LINE AND S.
MODERATORS. QUEUE UP ANY SUPPORT
WITNESSES AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN SIXTY
TWO. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
GENERAL ASPECTS ON. BUT AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
ELEVEN SB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. OUR
FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM NINE
ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KATHY BAND
OFTEN REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NINE ONE FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IF YOU
CARE MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE- TRANSIT UNION
TEAMSTERS ENGINEERS AND
SCIENTIFIC CALIFORNIA MACHINE IT
UNITE HERE AND THE UTILITY
WORKERS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FINE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS JENNIFER
MALEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION COURT. ONE ONE SIXTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON KAREN
MEMBERS CHRIS RESPONSIBLE ALL
SET TO GO WASHINGTON ALONG
PROPERTY TRANSPORT. FIND ONE
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND THEN WAIT
WHEN I'M WITH COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT IF THAT'LL-
NINE ONE SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. EIGHT
WATER SPECIFIC CALIFORNIA
WORKING FAMILIES COALITION.
ARCHITECT THE WITH. ONE FOURTEEN
LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
HEAR ME. YES. I'M WITH WORK LIKE
OTHER OFFER ACTION COURT WERE
EXTREMELY MEDIC. THANK YOU CAN
YOU REPEAT NAME PLEASE. ONE MORE
PLEASE. ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
GATHER THE LINE. BACK INTO THE
QUEUE. IF YOU MAY REPEAT YOUR
NAME PLEASE THE- RIGHT BUT WORK
THANK. FOR SOME REASON THE- FOR
SOME REASON THE OF THE
MICROPHONE DOES NOT WANT TO HELP
YOU STATE YOUR NAME SO TWICE-
I'M IN A- HERE NOW YES
CONSISTENT YOUR NAME PLEASE
THAT'S ALL WE NEED AT THIS
POINT. OF COURSE. EVERYBODY IN
THE CALL RIGHT. GOT IT CORRECTLY
GOT IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHO
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT WAS ON
THE RECORD ALL RIGHT MODERATOR
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. ONE ONE ONE
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE NINE ONE SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE BILL ARE QUITE ON
BEHALF OF NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA INTO FOUR THANK YOU.
THE NINE ONE SIX THREE TWO IF
YOU COULD PRESS ONE AND THEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS A COMMON SHOCK
MAJEK WORKER WITH THAT CHECK
EQUITY COLLABORATIVE AND I WANT
TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR SB. ELEVEN SIXTY TWO. AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN SUPPORT
OF IT SB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU GREAT JOB
MODERATOR WE'RE GOING TO COME
NOW TO THE OPPOSITION SIDE THERE
ARE TWO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES THE FIRST ONE LISTED
AS ASHLEY HOFFMAN- ASHLEY. YOU
ARE HERE. YES OFFICERS YES THE
OTHER LEAD WITNESS OPPOSITION
WITNESSES JAMIE HOPE SO TO HELP
WILL GO FIRST AND THEN WE'LL
COME BACK TO. ASHLEY HOFFMAN
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
VERS TAKE ME UP ON BEHALF OF
SEJAK ADDRESSING THE COMMITTE
TODAY WAS SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT
THE IMPACT THIS BILL WOULD HAVE
ON EMPLOYER LIABILITY IN
CALIFORNIA. WILL BE ABSOLUTELY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S WANTING
TO HIGHLIGHT GENDER BASED WAGE
GAPS SEJAK IS INCREDIBLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE EXPANDED AN
ONEROUS LITIGATION THAT WOULD
SURELY BE DIRECTED. AT EMPLOYERS
OF FORCETO DEFEND THEMSELVES
AGAINST MISLEADING WAGE DATA
PUBLISHED ONLINE. DATA ALONE
DOESN'T TELL THE WHOLE STORY OUT
OF CONTEXT THERE ARE VALID AND
LEGAL REASONS WHY PAY
DISPARITIES EXIST. NONE OF WHICH
WILL BE HIGHLIGHTED ALONGSIDE
THE DATA UNDER THIS BILL
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES SHOULDN'T
BE SUBJECT TO LAWSUITS
REPUTATIONAL BACKLASH. FOR
REASONABLE AND LEGAL PAY
DIFFERENCES THAT EXIST IN THEIR
WORK FORCE. COLLECTION OF THE
STATE IS NOT THE CONCERN THE
STATE ALREADY REQUIRES EMPLOYERS
TO PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION THE
CONCERT IS THE PUBLICATION. OF
THE DATA- CREATING BASICALLY A
SEARCHABLE A DIFFERENT DATABASE
ONLINE FOR PLAINTIFFS TO USE TO
SOON PLAYERS. ONCE THIS TYPE OF
DATA IS MADE PUBLIC ALL OF
PLAINTIFF ATTORNEY WOULD NEED TO
DO A SEARCH THE COMPANIES. THE
PERCEIVED PAY DIFFERENCES AND-
STATE. OF DEMAND FOR A- FOR
LITIGATION. IT'S WERE MENTION
THAT THE ENABLING LEGISLATION
THAT REQUIRES WAGE DATA
COLLECTION SPECIFICALLY REJECTED
THE IDEA OF MAKING THE DATA
PUBLIC. FIVE YEARS AGO THE STATE
HAD THE SAME CONVERSATION ABOUT
PAY ONLINE DATA. THEN THE
GOVERNOR BROWN WHO IS A LONG
TIME CHAMPION OF PAY EQUITY I
RECOGNIZE THE THREAT OF
LITIGATION IS A SERIOUS ISSUE
AND VETOED A BILL SIMILAR TO
THIS ONE. NOTING IN HIS VETO
MESSAGE THE WALL TRANSPARENCY IS
A GREAT WAY TO IDENTIFY A
PROBLEM PROVIDING DATA OUTSIDE
OF CONTEXT CREATES AMBIGUITY.
AND COULD BE EXPORTED TO
ENCOURAGE MORE LITIGATION THAN
PAY EQUITY. IN AN ARTICLE
PUBLISHED SAY NEAR A PLAINTIFF
ATTORNEY QUOTED AND PARAPHRASING
HERE ABOUT PUBLISHING THIS TYPE
OF DATA ONLINE IS THE GOVERNMENT
BASICALLY GIVING UP PLAINTIFF
ATTORNEYS THE DATA THEY NEED. TO
GO OUT AND SEE COMPANIES.
PUBLICIZING THE STATE WOULD PUT
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS IN A
POSITION TO DEFEND THEMSELVES
AGAINST MERITLESS LITIGATION
WITHOUT THE ADDED BENEFIT OF
IDENTIFYING INTENTIONAL WAGE
GAPS. FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANKS. OKAY
THANK YOU. THE NOW- ASHLEY HOPE
. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
ACTUALLY OFTEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION SB ELEVEN SIXTY
TWO. WE HAVE TO THE CONCERNS OF
MISS HELP REGARDING PART ONE OF
THE BILL SOMEONE LIMIT MY
TESTIMONY TO PARTS TWO AND
THREE- PRESENTLY- THE
LEGISLATURE HAS RECENTLY ENACTED
LEGISLATION SAYING THAT YOU
CANNOT RELY ON SALARY
INFORMATION YOU CAN ASK AN
APPLICANT FOR SALARY
INFORMATION. YOU CANNOT PROHIBIT
SOMEONE FROM ASKING ABOUT WAGES
ARE TALKING ABOUT IN THE
WORKPLACE AND AN APPLICANT MAY
ASK FOR A PAY SCALE- AFTER
THEY'VE GOTTEN THEIR FIRST ROUND
INTERVIEW- AND SO WE HAVE
SEVERAL CONCERNS IS MANDATING
THE PAY SCALE TO BE ON EVERY
SINGLE JOB POSTING. FIRST I WANT
TO KNOW WHO IS GOING TO HAPPEN
IS THAT EMPLOYERS ARE GOING TO
BE FORCED TO PUT QUITE A LARGE
RANGE ON THOSE JOB POSTINGS.
THEY NEED FLEXIBILITY IN THEIR
PAY SCALES I'M FOR A LOT OF
DIFFERENT REASONS WHETHER THAT'S
TO BE ABLE TO LEARN TALENT TO
FIT IF THEY CAN'T FIND AN
APPLICATION WHO EXACTLY NEEDS OF
QUALIFICATIONS THAT ARE LOOKING
FOR. OR IF THERE ARE CHANGES IN
JOB DUTIES SO WE ARE GOING TO
GET ON THESE JOB POSTINGS IS NOT
GOING TO BE SOMETHING OF THAT'S
HELPFUL FOR THE WORKER. WHO ARE
GOING TO BENEFIT IS THE BIG
BUSINESSES BIG BUSINESSES THAT
ARE TO BE ABLE TO PUT THESE
REALLY STRIKING NUMBERS ON THERE
THAT SMALL BUSINESSES AND MEDIUM
AND LOCAL BUSINESSES ARE JUST
NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO COMPETE
WITH. LEASE NOW IF THEY HAVE AN
INTERVIEW THEY CAN TALK TO THE
APPLICANT OTHER BENEFITS WORK
ENVIRONMENT WHAT HAVE YOU
THEY'RE JUST SIMPLY NOT GONNA BE
ABLE TO COMPETE ESPECIALLY IN
TODAY'S LABOR SHORTAGE- MORE
THEY'RE BARELY GETTING
APPLICANTS TO BEGIN WITH. PART
THREE OF THE BILL REQUIRES
DOESN'T NOTIFY EVERY SINGLE
EMPLOYEE OF NOT ONLY ANY OPEN
JOB VACANCY BUT IN ANTICIPATED
JOB VACANCY. SO IS THIS
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS NOTES AND
THAT'S GONNA END UP ITH A LOT
OF PROBABLY POTENTIALLY HUNDREDS
AND SOME BIG COMPANIES
NOTIFICATIONS CONSISTENTLY GOING
OUT TO PLEASE WHICH IS NOT
EXACTLY THE BEST USE OF
RESOURCES. AND FINALLY ARE
CONCERNED WITH A PROVISION IS
REALLY FLEXIBILITY PEOPLE LEAVE
ALL THE TIME WITHOUT NOTICE OR
THEY'RE TERMINATED. YOU CONSIDER
RESTAURANT RIGHT YOU HAVE A HEAD
CHEF WHO OFTEN MIGHT LEAVE TO GO
START THEIR OWN RESTAURANT OR
WHAT HAVE YOU. AND YOU CAN'T
SIMPLY THEN JUST PROMOTE THE
DEPUTY THE SECOND IN COMMAND AT
TO DO DINNER SERVICE AT NIGHT
UNDER THIS BILL. THAT'S OUT. FOR
YOU WOULD HAVE TO- THAT HAS. UP
TO EVERYONE IN THAT RESTAURANT
EVEN IF THEY'RE NOT QUALIFIED OR
THEY HAVE NO INTEREST BEFORE YOU
COULD EVEN TEMPORARILY PROMOTE
SOMEONE. UP TO THE NEXT
POSITION. AND ANY MISSTEP HERE
SUBJECT YOU TO A PRN PAGO IN
CONTRARY TO WHAT WAS STATED
BEFORE. IT'S NOT ACTUALLY
LIMITED TO PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR
GRIEVED. UNDER PAR THAT ANY
PERSON CAN SUE FOR ANY TECHNICAL
VIOLATION OF THE LABOR CODE
THERE'S CASE LAW ON THAT. YOU
DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE TO BE HARMED
YOU COULD HAVE A PAGA PLAINTIFFS
WHO HAD NO INTENTION OF EVER
APPLYING FOR ANY OF THESE JOBS.
SERVICE PLAINTIFF ON BEHALF OF
AN ENTIRE CLASS. THE FOR THESE
OTHER REASONS WE ARE URGING NO
VOTE. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE- WE WILL NOW. ASK
TO SEE WHEN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WHO WISH TO EXPRESS IN OPPOSE
POSITION OTHER THAN THE ME
WITNESSES. IF SO PLEASE COME
FORWARD. HI HI GOOD AFTERNOON
SHERRY MEMBERS KATIE HANSON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE HERE AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION FOR THE
REASONS STATED THANK YOU. OKAY
ANYBODY ELSE PATIENTS. EVERYBODY
ELSE HERE TO EXPRESS IN OPPOSE
POSITION SEEN NONE AT LEAST NONE
COMING FORWARD- WE'RE GONNA GO
THE MODERATORS LINUS MODERATOR
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE THERE
WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MISTER TURNER AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP ELEVEN IF
YOU YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN
ZERO. LINE ONE SIXTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN ONE
WORKSHOP ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION. ONE SIXTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH YOUR CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RUNNING VERTIGO HERE
I'LL BE OUT THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION ONE ECHO
THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE WE
OPPOSITION. ALL THE DISHES THANK
YOU. NINE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SARAH GARFINKEL VALLEY INDUSTRY
AND COMMERCE ASSOCIATION VIKA
AND WE OPPOSE S. B. ONE ONE SIX
DEAR THANK YOU. BY ONE SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS JAMIE CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATED
GENERAL CONTRACTORS AND WE ARE
IN OPPOSITION TO ELEVEN SIXTY
TWO THANK YOU. FIND ONE SEVENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS BRETT BEAR WITH
THE NATIONAL ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION UNITED
CONTRACTORS AND THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL CONFERENCE
OF THE PLUMBING HEATING AND
PIPING INDUSTRY IN OPPOSITION TO
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION OF S. ELEVEN SIXTY
TWO. OKAY THANK YOU MODERATOR
WE'RE GONNA COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND ASKED IF THERE
WERE ANY COMMENTS HERE AT THE
COMMITTEE LEVEL. IN THE SCENE NO
ONE WISHING TO BE RECOGNIZED- WE
WILL BEFORE WE ENTERTAIN A
MOTION WILL ASK CENTER WOMAN
SHE'D LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU
CHAIR AND YOU KNOW A THINK THAT
THERE'S BEEN A LOT SAID BUT I
JUST WANT TO REMIND FOLKS THAT
INTEL'S ONE OF THE COMPANIES
THAT'S MADE THIS INFORMATION
PUBLIC AND THEY HAVE YET TO HAVE
A LAWSUIT- AND SO WE ARE ALSO
LOOKING AT JUST NOT SPECULATION
BUT ALSO WHAT THE EVIDENCE IS.
CONSIDERING THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS THIS MAY THIS
MANDATE AND THAT YOU KNOW FOR
SOME OF THE COMPANIES OVER TO
LIKE I SAID OVER HALF OF THE-
TOP ONE HUNDRED TRADED PUMP
COMPANIES RELEASES INFORMATION
SO THIS IS NOT JUST A
SPECULATION BUT WE ARE LOOKING
AT OTHER PRACTICES THAT HAVE
CONTINUED AND I FEEL VERY
CONFIDENT THAT MOVING IN THIS
DIRECTION IS THE BEST AS ALWAYS
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION. AND SEE WHAT THEY
CAN. BRING TO THE TABLE THAT'S
NOT SIMPLY KILLING THE BILL.
OKAY YES SIR DRAWS WITH A JUST
WOULD MOVE BILL AND I THANK
AUTHOR I THANK THE SUPPORTERS
AND SPONSORS- FOR MOVING AHEAD
WITH THIS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SURE IF APPRECIATE EVERYONE WHO-
CAME TO TESTIFY TODAY AND
WITHOUT WILL MOVE ON TO THE
CONSULTANTS FOR ROLL CALL VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY COURTESY RIGHT.
COURTESY I OR CHOI BOGUE THE
RUSSELL. TO WRESTLE I'D LAYERED.
LAYERED HI NEWMAN. OKAY SO THE
BILL HAS THREE VOTES BUT WILL
PUT ON CALL FOR THE UP TO
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
OKAY OF WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE
ON TO S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
THIS BILL IS A BILL BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ SAID SHE IS HERE. I'M
CENTER IS ALWAYS IN THE PRESENT
DIFFERENT E. LET ME- WHILE
YOU'RE MAKING YOUR WAY TO THE
PODIUM I JUST WANT TO INDICATE I
USUALLY AM CLEARER AT THE OUTSET
ABOUT. OF LEAD IN OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY WE WILL LIMIT THAT- TO
A MAXIMUM TODAY- AND I WOULD
VERY- I MADE CHANGES FROM
MEETING TO MEETING BUT A MAXIMUM
TODAY OF. FIVE MINUTES PER
WITNESS TEN MINUTES PER SIDE. IN
A MINUTE ASCO CONSULTANT TO HELP
ME KEEP TRACK OF THAT I WILL
INTERRUPT YOU IF YOU'RE GOING
OVER PEOPLE DONE A PRETTY GOOD
JOB TODAY BUT- I'M NOT SURE I
MADE IT CLEAR WHAT THE RULES
WERE IN. NOT EVERY COMMITTEE IS
THE SAME SO CENTER GONZALEZ
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- BEFORE I
BEGIN I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THE TO
YOUR ALL RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS
THAT WOULD ALLOW. FOR A PAUSE ON
DIVESTMENT FOR SPECIFIED
UNFORESEEABLE EVENTS WOULD
REQUIRE THE BOARDS OF CALPERS
AND CAL STIRS TO PRODUCE AN
ANALYSIS ON HOW RAPIDLY PENSION
FUNDS. CAN REDUCE THEIR
DEPENDENCE ON FOSSIL FUELS.
MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY- ONCE
AGAIN TO PRESENT SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE WHICH WILL AND THE
USE OF PUBLIC EMPLOYEES HARD
EARNED PENSIONS THE FINANCE
FOSSIL FUELS. SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE- IS NOT JUST A POLITICAL
STATEMENT IT IS THE CREATION
FROM YEARS AND YEARS OF ADVOCACY
BY TEACHERS FACULTY MEMBERS AND
STATE EMPLOYEES. HAVE DEMANDED
THAT THE BOARDS OF CALPERS AND
STIRS THIS CONTINUE INVESTING
NEARLY TEN BILLION DOLLARS OF
THEIR HARD EARNED PENSIONS TO
FINANCE THE VERY INDUSTRY.
RELATED TO CLIMATE CHANGE THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS ALONG
WITH LOCAL CHAPTERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
REPRESENT HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF PERSONS THERE'S MEMBERS
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND ONCE THE
LEGISLATURE TO ACT NOW
ESPECIALLY AFTER TODAY. AFTER
THE IPCC THE INTERGOVERNMENTAL
POLICY AND CLIMATE CHANGE JUST
TODAY ANNOUNCED THAT IN THE NEXT
THIRTY MONTHS NOT THIRTY YEARS.
THIRTY MONTHS WE WILL SEE THE
WORST IMPACTS AND CLIMATE CHANGE
IF IMMEDIATE CUTS. IN EMISSIONS
IN ALL SECTORS ARE NOT DONE.
THERE IS PRECEDENT GLOBALLY
WE'VE SEEN OVER THIRTY NINE
TRILLION DOLLARS INVESTED WITH
HUNDREDS OF PENSION PORTFOLIOS.
TAKING ACTION BUT NOT JUST
SETTING THAT ZERO GOAL BUT BY
PER. DIVEST HERE IN CAL. THIS
YEAR USES IN THE UC HAVE
CONFIDENTLY AND PROACTIVELY
REMOVE FOSSIL FUEL INVESTMENTS
OUT OF THEIR PORTFOLIOS. THE
UC'S INFECTIOUS THING OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS OF INVESTMENTS
IN TWENTY TWENTY INTO NEW. CLEAN
TECHNOLOGY PROJECTS AND IN
TWENTY TWENTY THE STATE OF NEW
YORK IS ALSO COMMITTED TO THE
INVESTMENT OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS SIMILAR TO THIS BILL. AND
IN FACT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
HAS OPENED COMMON AT THIS POINT-
IN FACT HE BACK. LAST YEAR.
CREATED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER ON
CLIMATE RELATED FINANCIAL RISK.
WELL THE LET THE SECRETARY OF
LABOR AND SECRETARY OF TREASURY.
OF TREACHERY EXCUSE ME ARE
TAKING COMMENTS ON A FEDERAL
PENSIONS AS WE SPEAK. WELL THE
BOARD'S COMMITMENT TO INVESTING
IN RENEWABLE ENERGIES AND
COMMITMENT TO REAP REACHING A
NET ZERO GOAL BY TWENTY FIFTY OR
ADMIRABLE. IT IS NOT ENOUGH IN
FACT MANY OF THE FOSSIL FUEL
COMPANIES PER- THE CLIMATE
ACTION ONE HUNDRED WEBSITE
FOUNDED BY CALPERS INVESTORS.
ARE NOT EVEN HITTING THEIR OWN
NET ZERO- FOR- GIGI REMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS BY TWENTY FIFTY SO-WHY WOULD WE BE INVESTING IN
THEM. AND WHY WOULD THE
INVESTMENTS GO. OF THAT. REDUCE
EVEN FURTHER THAN A TWENTY FOUR
BELOW TWENTY FIFTY A LEVELS.
OPPONENTS ARGUE THOUGH THAT
FUNDS WILL FACING NEGATIVE
FINANCIAL IMPACT IF WE DIVEST
AND- TO THE CONTRARY IN FACT.
INVESTMENT MANAGEMENT FIRMS IN
STUDIES HAVE CONCLUDED THAT
MOVING AWAY FROM FOSSIL FUELS
ACTUALLY IMPROVE NOT WEAKENS
INVESTMENT RETURNS. AND WE KNOW
THIS BECAUSE OF FOSSIL FUEL
SECTOR. HAS A DIMINISH PRESENCE
IN THE S. AND P. FIVE HUNDRED
AND ESG AND FOSSIL FUEL. OF
BUZZELL FEEL FREE INDEXES ARE
BEATING THE S. AND P. FIVE
HUNDRED. AND APPROVING TO BE A
RISKY INVESTMENT FOR CUTS PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT FEATURES
THAT IS ALSO FEELS THAT IS.
FINALLY THE BILL CONTAINS
LANGUAGE THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER
CHAIR EMPOWERING BOTH BOARDS TO
REFRAIN FROM DIVESTMENT SHOULD
THEY DETERMINE IN GOOD FAITH.
THAT THIS POLICY WOULD BE
SUBJECT. TO MEMBERS- SIGNIFICANT
LOSSES IN THEIR PENSIONS WHICH
WOULD THEN IMPACT THEIR
FIDUCIARY. DUTIES UNDER THE
STATE CONSTITUTION. I MUST
STRESS. THIS IS ON JUST NUMBER
GOAL BUT THAT THE INTENTION HERE
IS TO ENSURE THAT WE MINIMIZE
RISK OF UNDERPERFORMING FOSSIL
FUELS AND MAXIMIZE RETURN WITH
CLEAN INVESTMENTS WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY TAKING A STAND ON
CLIMATE CHANGE. AS A CALPERS
MEMBER MYSELF FOR OVER A DECADE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND TESTIFYING TODAY I
HAVE RUN RAP LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION. AND
THOMPSON ZERO DIRECTOR FINANCIAL
ANALYST ANALYSIS FOR THE
INSTITUTE FOR ENERGY ECONOMICS
AND FINANCIAL ANALYSIS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE.
AND SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE.
THANK YOU SENATOR- ONE CURVE
KITCHEN WHICH I THINK IS JUST A
MINOR THING APPRECIATE YOU-
EXPRESSING YOUR ACCEPTANCE OF
THE- COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS- IN
THE IN THE PORTION OF. YOUR
PRESENTATION WHERE YOU TALKED
ABOUT REQUIRING THE PHONE
ANALYZE MATH IS AN OPPORTUNIST
RAPIDLY AND EFFECTIVELY REDUCE
DEPENDENCE ON FOSSIL FUELS. AND
TRANSITIONAL TURN OF ENERGY
SOURCES- IN A REALISTIC TIME
FRAME. THAT AVOIDS NEGATIVELY
CONTRIBUTE TO ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS PARTICULARLY DAMAGING
TO PUBLIC EMPLOYEE RETIREMENT
FUNDS. OTHERS ALSO AT. AN END IN
THERE TWO OVERALL. IN ADDITION
TO OVERALL- IT. TO REPORT BACK
ON ANY DAMAGE CONDITIONS TO NET
EMPLOYMENT EARNINGS OF THE
STATE'S WORKFORCE AND I JUST
WANTED TO. MAKE SURE WE WERE IN
AGREEMENT. THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION WE ARE IN
AGREEMENT ON THE ISSUE OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
WE WILL MOVE TO. THE LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESS AT THIS TIME RUN
CRAP CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IS. MR RAP ON THE ON
THE LINE OF SO YOU MAY PROCEED.
YES SIR GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
CORTESE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RON RAPP LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION WHICH
REPRESENTS OVER TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND FACULTY INCLUDING
TENURE TRACK PROFESSORS
LIBRARIANS COUNSELORS AND
COACHES FROM ALL TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM SPEAKING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE. YEP THERE'S A
PROBLEM CO SPONSOR OF THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION AND WHAT
LIKE TO THANK SENATOR GONZALEZ
INSIDE THEIR WIENER FOR CO
AUTHORING THIS BILL. AS WE ALL
ARE AWARE CLIMATE CHANGE IS REAL
CALIFORNIA HAS SEATING CONTINUES
TO SEE THE DEVASTATING IMPACT OF
CLIMATE CHANGE SEVERE DROUGHT
DEVASTATING WILD OUR PLAZA FIRES
AND MORE SEVERE WEATHER PATTERNS
THE SEVERE ECOLOGICAL CHANGES OF
THE RESULT ARE YOU PRODUCTION OF
FOSSIL FUELS. HELLO GONNA DEAL
COULD CLIMB CHANGE THERE'S STILL
MUCH TO BE DONE A MAJOR
CONTRADICTION AND ARTWORK FROM
CLIMATE CHANGES THAT OUR PUBLIC
PENSION SYSTEMS COMBINED HAVE
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT POINT NINE
BILLION DOLLARS CURRENTLY
INVESTED IN FOSSIL FUEL
COMPANIES. WE BELIEVE THAT THE
PASSAGE OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE WILL SIGNIFICANTLY FURTHER
OUR WORK TOWARDS A CLEANER AND
MORE LIVEABLE FUTURE FOR US AND
FOR OUR CHILDREN. THE BILL HAS
SUPPORT FROM OVER EIGHTY
ORGANIZATIONS AND GROWING DAILY
INCLUDING SEVERAL STATEWIDE
UNION ORGANIZATIONS THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE UNITED DOMESTIC
WORKERS OF AMERICA AND THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
COUNCIL OF THE INTERNATIONAL
LONGSHORE AND WAREHOUSE UNION.
IN ADDITION THE MAJORITY OF CFA
IS TWENTY THREE LOCALS FROM SAN
DIEGO LOS ANGELES BAKERSFIELD
AND FRESNO THE SAN FRANCISCO
STANISLAUS HUMBOLDT AND MORE
HAVE CALLED FOR DIVESTMENT FROM
FOSSIL FUELS. FINALLY AS THE
AUTHOR STATED THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS ARE DEAD
BENEFITING FROM FOSSIL FUELS NOT
ONLY IF DIVESTMENT FROM FOSSIL
FUELS OF SOUND MORAL AND ETHICAL
DECISION BUT IT IS ALSO A FOUND
FINANCIAL DECISION I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR VOTE
ON THIS IMPORTANT. LEGISLATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN THE NEXT
SUPPORT WITNESSES TOM. ST ZERO
FOR THE DIRECTOR OF FINANCIAL
ANALYSIS AS I UNDERSTAND IT FOR
ENERGY ECONOMICS AND FINANCIAL
ANALYSIS IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE
YOU MAY PROCEED. YES LIST AND
THANK YOU CAN HEAR ME YES WE CAN
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MY NAME'S
TOM SINCE- ON THE DIRECTOR
FINANCIAL ANALYSIS FOR THE
INSTITUTE FOR ENERGY ECONOMICS
AND FINANCIAL ANALYSIS- MONA
THANK YOU- FIRM GIVE ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE SPONSORED BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ- THE BILL REQUIRES
CALPERS AND CAL STIRS TO DIVEST
FROM FOSSIL FUEL COMPANIES- I
SERVED IN SENIOR MANAGEMENT
POSITIONS IN THE NEW YORK CITY
IN NEW YORK STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS- EACH
OFFICE PLAYS A PIVOTAL ROLE
MANAGING THE RESPECTIVE PENSION
SYSTEMS- DURING MY TENURE IN
THE- POSITION THERE WERE PLEASE-
TO- DIVEST PENSION FUNDS RELATED
TO SOUTH AFRICA TOBACCO NUCLEAR
POWER. ISRAEL GUNS AND
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS BY FAR THE
CASE FOR THE INVESTMENT OF
FOSSIL FUELS IS THE MOST
FINANCIALLY COMPELLING- THE
FOSSIL FUEL SECTOR CLAIM 28% OF
THE STANDARD AND POOR'S FIVE
HUNDRED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY.
TODAY IT IS JUST OVER FOUR.
RETURNS OVER THE PAST DECADE
HAVE BEEN PARTICULARLY WEAK AND
MSCI'S FOSSEL FREE INDEX HAS
OUTPACED INDEXES THAT CONTAIN
FOSSIL FUELS. DESPITE RECENT
HIGHER OIL PRICES AND A SPIKE IN
STOCK VALUES THE LONG TERM
OUTLOOK IS NOT POSITIVE. OIL AND
GAS COMPANIES ARE USING CURRENT
CASH SURPLUSES TO PAY DIVIDENDS
AND REDUCE THAT. AS OF MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY SOME ELEVEN
HUNDRED INVESTMENT FUNDS OF
DIFFERING SIZE AND VARYING
MISSIONS OF THE VESTED IN SOME
FORM. BLACKROCK UNDER CONTRACT
WITH THE CITY OF NEW YORK
CONDUCTED A SURVEY OF
INSTITUTIONAL FUNDS THAT DECIDED
TO DIVEST OF THOSE FUNDS THAT
EXPLICITLY MEASURE DIRECT
FINANCIAL PERFORMANCE NO
INVESTORS FOUND SIGNIFICANT
NEGATIVE PERFORMANCE. BUT RATHER
HAVE REPORTED NEUTRAL TO
POSITIVE RESULTS. THE INVESTMENT
MANAGEMENT COMPANY BLACKROCK HAS
MADE IT CLEAR THAT THEY ARE NOT
ADVOCATES OF DIVESTMENT. HOWEVER
WHEN A CLIENT POSED THE QUESTION
TO BLACKROCK THE COMPANY
PROVIDED FIFTY SHIRLEY FOUND
EVIDENCE THAT A FUND COULD
ELIMINATE FOSSIL FUEL
INVESTMENTS FROM A PORTFOLIO AND
STILL MEET FINANCIAL PERFORMANCE
TARGETS. DIVESTING FROM FOSSIL
FUELS IS A DICE DEFENSIVE
MEASURE DESIGNED TO PROTECT
INSTITUTIONAL INVESTORS FROM THE
RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE. BLACKROCK AND OTHER
INVESTMENT HOUSES I FOUND THAT
MOST FOSSIL FUEL COMPANIES ARE
NOT PREPARED TO HANDLE THE
PHYSICAL AND TRANSITION RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE EXTRACTION
AND SELLING OF FOSSIL FUELS.
MOST INVESTMENT STRATEGIES ALSO
DEVISE AN ON RAMP SO THAT
COMPANIES WITH WELL THOUGHT OUT
STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE CAN BE HELD IN PORTFOLIOS
THAT OTHERWISE THAT ARE
OTHERWISE THE VESTING FROM
FOSSIL FUELS. FOSSIL FUEL
COMPANIES WERE ONCE MAJOR
CONTRIBUTORS THE INSTITUTIONAL
FUNDS. AND TO THE WORLD ECONOMY
TODAY THE FINANCIAL PERFORMANCE
IS UNSTABLE AND THE OUTLOOK IS
NEGATIVE FOR THOSE WITHOUT SOUND
STRATEGIES TO COPE WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE THANKS. Q. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE. HI THANK
YOU MY NAME IS CJ CAP I WITH
ALSO FREE CALIFORNIA AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE I ALSO WANT TO
BRIEFLY NOTE THAT A NUMBER OF
OUR SUPPORTERS ARE STRUGGLING TO
CALL IN- RIGHT NOW DUE TO.
RESTRICTED CAPACITY ON A LINE.
NEXT PLEASE MY NAME IS SERRA
DECEMBER CALPERS RETIREE AND A
MEMBER OF FOSSIL FREE CALIFORNIA
AND I FOR DEFERRED YOU TO VOTE
YES ON THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ONE FIELD
MANI'M A CALPERS MEMBER AND I'M
ALSO A MEMBER PHILOSOPHY
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY URGE
YOU TO VOTE YES ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY. MY NAME IS
MERRIAM I'D I'M A MEMBER OF ALSO
FREE CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT SB ONE ONE
SEVEN THREE. SANDY EMERSON FROM
FOSSIL FREE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. HI I'M SIMPLY A SALAD A
VOLUNTEER WITH INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA STATE STRONG THE
GREEN TEAM AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE I AM ALSO A MEMBER OF
CALPERS AND I TELL YOU I'M VERY
GRATEFUL FOR MY PENSION CHECK I
GET EVERY MONTH BUT I'M WOULD BE
HAPPY TO HAVE A REDUCTION IN
THAT PAYCHECK IF IT MEANS THAT
YOU'LL DIVEST FROM FOSSIL FUELS
I SUPPORT SB SEVENTY POINT ONE
SEVENTY THREE. THNK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KRISTEN BROWN
WITH CFTA UNION OF EDUCATORS AND
CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
FOR READING ONE ELSE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
NAME AFFILIATION. POSITION A
RATE- WE WILL GO TO THE
MODERATOR IN ASK IF THERE'S
ANYONE THERE WHO WISHES TO
EXPRESS NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION. THANK YOU MR CARE AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE. MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO
ASSISTS NINE. CURRENTLY WE DO
HAVE- IN A THRIVING WE DO HAVE
FIFTY SEVEN IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR GIVEN
NAME AFFILIATION POSITION HELLO
. ONE ONE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JESSICA OF ELLIE FOR CLIMBING
THE NEW LEFT UNCOLLECTED STOP
MONEY PIPELINE INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA STATE FOR ON THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S
OUR ENVIRONMENTAL CAUCUS
STRONGLY SUPPORT AT THE ONE ONE
SEVEN THREE THANK YOU. IN MIND
ONE FOR WE DID NOT HEAR YOUR
FULL NAME MAYBE HAVE YOU REPEAT
THAT PLEASE. JESSICA CREEDON
THANK YOU. ONE FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS CAN'T TALK FOR THREE THE
PEOPLE CAN RALLY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK. ONE ONE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE ONE FIFTY FIVE YOU
MAY BE A NEW PLEASE GO AHEAD-
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
THIS IS JERRY BROWN AND- WITH
THAT HERE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA-
WELL WE'VE NOT FOR PHYSICIAN
WE'RE WORKING AT THE AUTHOR TO.
FIVE ONE ZERO. THE AS CHAIR AND
STAFF- AMENDMENT THE BILL IS
SURROUNDING YOU NEED TO SEE YOUR
POSITION PLEASE. WE ARE NEW TO
TOMORROW LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING IN THE OFFICE TO GET
WORK THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE
ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR ON WHAT
WE FIND WITH MAGNETIC WORKERS AT
YOUR LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY
THE COURT. THANK YOU. NINE ONE
OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WHEN ONE OF FIVE-
REMOVE THEMSELVES FROM Q. NINE
ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS JONATHAN KARL I'M A
MEMBER OF CALPERS AS WELL AS A
CALPERS RETIREES OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORTS SD ONE ONE
SEVEN THREE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. ONE ONE NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JIM LINDBERG
ON BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION THAT
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. ONE
SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM DOCTOR
KEVIN WE'RE OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION WHEN VICE
PRESIDENT AND PROFESSOR AT CSU
SACRAMENTO AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
I REQUEST YOUR VOTE HERE I
THOUGHT THANK YOU. ONE ONE FIFTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
TO BAN HIM I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
CREEK EARNED FOR KIDS DOT ORG
AND CALPERS MEMBER CALLING ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF AND ALL OF OUR
TEACHERS VOLUNTEERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE ONE
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WHEN YOU MAKE IT. I
HAVE. HEAR ME YEAH YES. OKAY
GREAT MEDINA CAROLINE MILLER I'M
FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND THE
CAL STAR MEMBER AND I WORK WITH
THE FIRST APOCALYPSE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT. NINE FORTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS ADRIAN COULTER
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF INDIVISIBLE
VENTURA AND OUR GROUP STRONGLY
SUPPORTS SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE. BY FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIX BUT HE
WON YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS RAVEN CONDUCTED ANYTHING
FROM YOU FOR THE APOCALYPSE AND-
WEREN'T STRONG SUPPORT. LINE ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OF COURSE
GERMAN OF EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD
SENIOR BERKELEY HIGH SCHOOL OF
COLLEGE THAT I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE ONE ONE SEVEN THIRTY. NINE
ONE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
IAN ANDERSON BACK I LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE JUST
TOOK THREE AND A HALF THAT YOU
LOOK FOR SENATE BILL ONE ONE
SEVEN THREE THANK YOU. NINE
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS MARK
COSTELLO AND FIFTEEN YEARS OLD
WHEN I GO TO BERKELEY HIGH. SB
ELEVEN AM ET. NINE FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD HI. HI MY NAME IS PAULA
HOFFMAN I AM A HIGH SCHOOLER AND
MEMBERS YOU CAN EXPECT LOS
ANGELES AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB ONE ONE SEVEN THREE. EIGHTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M HI<c.cyan> YEP WHAT ON</c>
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS CONNIE LOBBY NORTH
ORANGE COUNTY SOUTHEAST L. A.
COUNTY CHAPTER THREE FIFTY
VENTURA COUNTY CRIME YOU HOP
THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YES
MY NAME IS CHRISTINE CAMPBELL
SHOEMAKER A RESIDENT OF WOODLAND
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE THANK
YOU. NINE ONE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M MORE SECRETARY OF FRESNO YOU
GET FRACKING WHICH SUPPORT SB.
ONE ONE SEVEN THREE. TWENTY
DIFFERENT OVER TWENTY DIFFERENT
EITHER LATER OR LECTURE TRACTION
. CLIMATE CHANGE AIR POLLUTION
WATER POLLUTION THE VEHICLE
KIDNEY FAILURE ALZHEIMER'S
PARKINSON'S VIRAL BACTERIAL
DISEASE. MORE THANK. NINE EIGHTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI I'M DR KELLY MAKE YOU
CHARACTERS NUMBER AFTER OF
ENGLISH IS A GOOD CITY COLLEGE
AND CHERUB YEAH HE'S LABOR AND
CRIME INFESTED EDUCATION
COMMITTEE IN ADDITION TO BEING A
VICE PRESIDENT OF EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THIRTY ONE. I CERTAINLY
URGE YOUR SUPPORT SB. ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU. ONE
FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CHRISTOPHER I'M FOURTEEN YEARS
OLD I'M CALLING FROM OKAY
CALIFORNIA ENERGY FROM SUPPORT
SB LIVE TWENTY THREE. LINE ONE
EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT THE BILLION CONTRACT FROM
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS
AND CALLING IN SUPPORT SB THREE
THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS ROBERT WILL BE ON THE
SPOUSE OF THE COASTERS NUMBER
AND I'M WITH FOSSIL FREE
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY SUPPORT
TESTING ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE.
NINE ONE SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M CLEAR GROUND
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY ECONOMICS PROFESSOR WHO
WORKED ON THE CLIMATE RELATED
FINANCIAL RISK OF FOSSIL FUEL
ASSETS I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE. THANK YOU
. ONE ONE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M STEVE SANDER I
CALPERS MEMBERS SCIENTIST
WORKING IN STATE GOVERNMENT AND
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE SACRAMENTO
CLIMATE COALITION I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE. NINE ONE OH EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ALL OF YOU WILL A RETIRED
MEMBER WITH BOTTLE THE
CALIFORNIA SPEAKING INCOME
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE ONE
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS A
MORE UPRIGHT I'M A JUNIOR IN
HIGH SCHOOL AND A MEMBER OF THE
U. S. CLIMATE STRAIGHT AWAY. AND
I STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF
SB ONE ONE SEVEN THREE. FIVE ONE
FIFTY TWO TWO. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
HEARING MEMBERS OF THE DECADE
FETAL KERR CALLING ON BEHALF OF
STATE TREASURER FIONA MA AND
WITH THAT BUT IF YOU'RE A GUARD
RAILS INCLUDED IN THE BILL THE
TREASURE IS PROUD TO SUPPORT SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU.
ONE ONE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
THIS IS WILL PREPARE ON MY
CALPERS RETIREE AND GRANDFATHER
AND I SUPPORT ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE. NINE ONE SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS JEANETTE FACT MELON
I'VE BEEN A STATE EMPLOYEE FOR
TWELVE YEARS I'M A CALPERS
MEMBER AND I'M A MEMBER IF HE-
BURKE CASE MEMBERS FOR EXAMPLE
INVESTING AND I FOR YOUR STRONG
SUPPORT IN THE. ONE FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD HELLO MY NAME IS ROSE AND
WITH I'M A CO FOUNDER OF THE
KANEKO KLIMEK COALITION IN
VENTURA COUNTY. AND OUR
COALITION URGES YOU TO VOTE YES
ON SB ONE ONE SEVEN THREE THANK
YOU. ONE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ARGHA FREE ON THE FIFTH SCREEN
FEATURE CHARACTERS MEMBER IN A
CROWD ETA MEMBER TODAY I'M
REPRESENTING MY ETA LOCAL
HARMONY UNION TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND SONOMA COUNTY
WHICH UNANIMOUSLY. VOTED TO
SUPPORT S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE THANK YOU. MY NINETY SIX
YOUR MIND OPEN GO AHEAD. BY
NINETY SIX YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT MY NAME'S
ALEX DAY- OF TEACHER AT BERKELEY
HIGH SCHOOL THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS MEMBERS
LOCAL TEN SEVENTY EIGHT ACCOUNTS
THERE'S CONTRIBUTOR AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE. ONE ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
PAMELA CAL AND A TEACHER
LIBRARIAN AND CONSISTS OF A FEW
YEARS BACK I'M NOT CALPERS
MEMBER AND PPA. AND HERE HE
MEMBER AND I'M URGING YOU TO
STOP WITH THE POOR AT ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU. BY
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME YEAH CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
. MY NAME IS ELECTED FORSTER AND
I'M A CHARACTERS MEMBER AND
PROFESSOR IN SANTA ROSA
CALIFORNIA CALLING ON BEHALF OF
MY FELLOW FACULTY MEMBERS MY
STUDENTS AND MY KIDS I ARGUED
URGE YOU TO STRONGLY SUPPORT AT
E. ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE THANK
YOU. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO. YOU CAN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE WE'VE GOT
ONE AND A ZERO AT THIS TIME ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB. ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AND AT THIS TIME WE DO
HAVE A THIRTY IN THE QUEUE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE NINE SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CARL MILLER CLIMATE HAWKS
VOTE IN THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ACTIVIST WHOSE
RESOLUTION LEADS TO SB ONE
EIGHTY FIVE PREDECESSOR OF THIS
BILL. WITH SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I MEAN
EUGENE. CALLING IN SUPPORT. NINE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I'M UC
CURRICULUM I MAKE CHARACTERS
BENEFICIARY ARE RETIRED SCIENCE
TEACHER- EIGHTEEN YEARS IN
CANADA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND THE CONVENER OF THE CLIMATE
CURRICULA COMMITTEE. OF LOS
ANGELES AND- I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
. ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. JUNICHIRO
MCALISTER'S MEMBER BUT THE
BERKELEY FEDERATION OF TEACHERS
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S.
B. ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE. TWENTY
ONE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M DEBORAH
SHELBY MCALISTER'S BENEFICIARY
AND A MEMBER OF THE OFFICE H
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE. MY
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M PHILIP
MORTON I'M WITH EXTINCTION
REBELLION SAN FRANCISCO BAY AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S.
B. ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE. NINE
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FORTY EIGHT
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I DID
FRANKLIN COUNTY I'M CALLING FROM
LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA NATURE
WITH THE FOR THE BILL. AND MAY
WE HAVE YOU REPEAT YOUR NAME
PLEASE. THANK IN COUNTY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NINE ONE TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HE NAY GAILLARD FOR
THREE FIFTY SACRAMENTO IN STRONG
SUPPORT. ONE ONE OH SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS DR MARGARET CHAN ON A
MOBY TO WEIGH IN IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND I'M WITH THE BAY
AREA. HERSELF RESPONSIBILITY
INCOMING HELP NOW. STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
FOR THE HEALTH OF OUR PATIENTS
AND THE PLAN THANK YOU. NINE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS LISA
SPUR ROCCO I AM A CALPERS MEMBER
AND WITH THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR VOTE. ONE ONE
NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY YES OKAY
SO- I'M A STUDENT AND SATELLITE
AND I WE'RE GONNA CIRCLE I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF HAS BEEN ONE
ONE. MY YOUR LINE OPEN GO A-
YEAH MY NAME IS STEVEN MURPHY I
LIVE IN DAVIS CALIFORNIA AND
ALREADY A MEMBER- WELCOME TO
CALIFORNIA AND AS A STEERING
COMMITTEE MEETING NUMBER OF INTO
THE WILL BE A WE ARE STRONG
SUPPORTER. SB ONE ON SEVENTY
THANK YOU. NINE ONE NINE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ALLEY OR
A CLEANING OF AN EIGHTEEN YEAR
OLD COLLEGE STUDENT THAT STUDENT
CALLING FROM LOS ANGELES TO
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT PRESS THREE
ONE ONE SEVEN THREE. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE NINETY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR NUMBER'S BEEN
SIMPLER MODEL WITH A CLIENT
CENTERED TRANSPORT THANK YOU.
NINE TWO ZERO THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS ANNE STANTON CALLING IN FROM
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA TO EXPRESS
MY SUPPORT FOR SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE THANK YOU. ONE TWO HUNDRED
AND SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS EVIDENT IN
TEN WITH VOICES FOR PROGRESS
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT. NINE
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS HANNAH STARTED LOOKING
FOR HIS APOCALYPSE AND I'M
CALLING HIM TO SUPPORT SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE. NINE TWO HUNDRED
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS MICHAEL
MY DOG CAMP I AM CALLING ON
BEHALF OF EVERY AS GUARDIANS
CREW AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT AT SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
ONE ONE EIGHTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THERE
THIS IS JOAN WOMAN FROM OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA I AM WITH THE PRE
CALIFORNIA NINE MCALISTER'S
BENEFICIARY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. NINE ONE
NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SH DR OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOONCHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS KATHY DURBIN
CALPERS MEMBERS AND I HEARD YOUR
AYE VOTE ON SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE THANK YOU. ONE TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS COREY VAN
GELDER AND I'M WITH GREEN STAGE
CLIMATE ACTION IS THE STUDENT
AND TEACHER CLIMATE GROUP AND WE
ALL STRONGLY SUPPORT SB. ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU SO MUCH
. NINE ONE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS ELENA ANGLE I'M A
CALPERS RETIREE AND A MEMBER OF
THREE FIFTY BAY AREA I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE. AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB. ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO. NINE TWO HUNDRED
AND FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS KEVIN J. PATEL I'M WITH THE I
AM A STUDENT AT LMU ANNIE I'M
ALSO WITH THE YOUTH CLIMACTERIC
GROUP. I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT-
SB ELEVEN COUNTY THREE. ONE TWO
HUNDRED AND ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME'S IS TWENTY BROADCAST NINE
PRODUCERS COOPERATIVE AND I HAVE
BEEN TO YOUR INFORMATION CALL
THE NAME OF CHRIST WE WILL BE
LOOKING. MY NUMBER ONE NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. EIGHT NINE ONE NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE. K. N. MIND ONE
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND THEN SHARED
MEMBERS THIS CALL ON HOLD ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LONG BEACH
IN SUPPORT. NINE ONE TWENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ROGER
HALSTON I'M A MEMBER OF FOSSIL
FREE CALIFORNIA AND OF- CAL
STIRS AND OF ALBANY TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NINE ONE FIFTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY ONE FIFTY FOUR YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CONTRACTUALLY IN STRONG AT
ELEVEN THE NEW. I'M SORRY COULD
YOU REPEAT YOUR NAME WE COULD
NOT HEAR. NOW. MISTER KERR WERE
YOU ABLE TO HEAR THE NAME. WE'LL
GIVE IT TO A WARMER CHOI THREE'S
A CHARM TONIGHT. IT IS TONIGHT
NUMBER OF. YEAH 30% DANSKO I
THINK I THINK WE HAVE ENOUGH FOR
NOW ON THE RECORD OKAY OKAY
THANK YOU. NINE ONE EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE. HELLO MY NAME IS
ANDRE I'M A SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD
STUDENT FROM BERKELEY HIGH WALL
AND I'M CO PRESIDENT OF BERKELEY
HIGH SCHOOL ZERO WASTE CLUB. I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
ONE SEVENTY ONE A LOT ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE. MY AND ONE
HUNDRED AND TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES. YES MY NAME IS
DANNY FARIA REMEMBER HELP
THURSDAY THE MEMBERS ETA ANY A
RETIRED AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
AT ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE. NINE
NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JAMES STONE I'M A CALPERS AND
CAL STIRS MEMBER AND I'M WITH
CCPA CHAPTER AT MOUNT SAN
ANTONIO COLLEGE AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE.
NINE TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS OLENA
GREGORIO I AM A GEOGRAPHY
PROFESSOR IN THE CULTURE AND THE
INABILITY COMMITTEE AT WORK IN
COLLEGE AND THE CPA CAPTORS
NORTH ORANGE COUNTY. COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT MY CHARACTER
MEMBER AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE. ONE TO
TWENTY ONE. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
PLAN TO TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD YES THANK YOU MY
NAME IS FRANCESCA LONGER I AM A
TOP RIGHT I AM A CALPERS MEMBERS
I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THREE
SACRAMENTO INDIVISIBLE
SACRAMENTO INDIVISIBLE ALLOW
INDIVISIBLE SAN FRANCISCO AND
CALIFORNIA STATE STRONG AND-
AWKWARD. REPORT I'M SEVENTY TURN
. NINE TWO TWO ONE YOUR IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS SIMON THING I AM A MEMBER OF
YOU FIRST APOCALYPSE AND OTHER
STUDENTS AND A YOUNG PERSON I AM
IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE. OF ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE. NINE ONE SEVENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS A
PROCESS I RESIDE IN GRAND NORTH
ORANGE COUNTY AND THE CALPERS
THREE FIFTY IN AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
THANK YOU. ONE FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES HI I'M DONE
WITH THAT SENATE MOVING OCT
ANGELES AND HEALTHCARE POLICY
ANGELES AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
SUCH DEAL AND SEVENTY THREE. BY
ONE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
SHEILA FOR I'M A RETIRED CFA
MEMBER AND THE CALPERS
BENEFICIARY AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT FC ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE.
NINE TO SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS CAROL LEAD I'M
REPRESENTING THE DEMOCRATS THAT
FOR US. IN MOMENT QUICKLY AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT YOU. ONE TWO
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
CARLA MIKE HELLO HI MCALLISTER
THE END IN A RETIRED MEMBER OF
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND I MIXED TRONG
SUPPORTIVE SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE. ONE SEVENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARTY FERGUSON
I'M CALLING FROM DAVIS I'M A
MEMBER OF INDIVISIBLE YELLOW IS
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE INDIVISIBLE
STATE STRONG WORKING GROUP ON
CLIMATE JUSTICE WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
THANK YOU. TWENTY TWO NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS JEFF FISHER
ARMED I'M A CALPERS RETIREE. I
MENTAL SCIENTIST AND IN
SACRAMENTO AND I ALSO BELONG TO
THREE FIFTY FACT. AB THREE THANK
YOU. NINE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS JANET NINE I LIVE IN
CLARKSBURG CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF INDIVISIBLE YELLOW.
AND I'M CALLING TO SAY THAT I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU. I'M
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS KRISTEN KESSLER I'M CALLING
FROM MENTOR I'M A MEMBER OF
CHARACTERS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT- ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
THANK YOU. THANK TO TWENTY
SEVEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS RILEY
HUMANITY'S CARNAGE CHECK LOS-ANGELES AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AT ELEVEN PM. THANK
YOU. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE YOU MAY PRESS. LET
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS PURSUING THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE ONE
NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE MINE ONE TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
ONE TWENTY TWO YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD WITH THE
PHONE NUMBER. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND MY TO TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE MIME THROUGH
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS RIGHT HERE AND I'M A FEW
CONTRACT LOS ANGELES AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE. THANK YOU TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS GREG
EMPIRE ON MY CALPERS MEMBER WITH
THE CSU EMPLOYEES UNION AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE. NINE TWO HUNDRED
AND NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. OKAY HI MY NAME AS
MONDAY HERE I CALL YOU FROM
LISTENING CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF- YBA ARE THIRTY IN
AND CANYON ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TO
SAY THAT WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT
OF THAT 11-3. THANK YOU.
NINETEEN THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS JOANNE I'M IN SECOND GRADE
AND I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ROUGHLY AROUND SEVENTY THREE.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. FIND ONE NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES HI MY NAME IS
CYNTHIA COFFMAN AND FACULTY AT
DE ANZA COLLEGE CALPERS MEMBER
AND A MEMBER OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND I SUPPORT
ONE ONE SEVEN THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY TWO
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LIFE IS ON
MUTE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. TWENTY
TWO THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS SASHA. I AM. FIFTEEN AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT- SB ONE ONE
SEVEN THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THIRTY TWO PHILANDER'S OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONCE AGAIN MY
TWO THIRTY TO THREE LINE IS OPEN. ONE TO THIRTY NEAR ME RIGHT
LINE BY TWO THIRTY THREE ITEMS
OPEN. OKAY THANK YOU CAN YOU
HEAR ME LYING TO CREATE FREE.
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YEAH YES
PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY WE'RE
OPPOSED TO SB ONE ONE SEVEN
THREE WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN LINE WITH MODERATE
FACTORS COUNTY HOME BUILDINGS
DISTRICT COUNCIL MANY. THIS IS A
SUPPORT LINE- WILL BE OPENING UP
AN OPPOSITIONAL AND SHORTLY AND-
EVERYONE HAVE A CHANCE THANK YOU. LEVINE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONCE AGAIN NINE TWO THIRTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD OF. FIVE THE NEW DONALD
FOR KIDS DOT ORG AND I AM IN
FULL SUPPORT OF A LOT OF. THERE
ARE NO FURTHER LINES IN THE
SUPPORT YOU FOR SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE YEAR- I'M SORRY
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. ARE WE DO
HAVE TWO MORE THAT QUEUED UP TO
SINCE EVERYTHING THAT. I WANT
ONE TO THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS MEGHAN MARKLE AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF A POPULAR VERSION S.
B. ELEVEN TWENTY THREE. YOU.
TWENTY TWO THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN MY
NAME IS. MY NAME IS GREG CLOSER
I AM A TEACHER IN OAKLAND
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I
HAVE. TWENTY YEARS OF SERVICE IN
MY MONEY IN CHARACTER WHILE
CALPERS AT THIS POINT IN THE
MINISTRY- AND I AM STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL THE
LEGISLATURE NEED THE STAFF AND
DO WHAT'S RIGHT AND ENSURE THAT
OUR SO THAT'S AND SEE SO MANY.
AND WATER HEATER ZACKS INCLUDE
THE FOLK- IN Q. ONE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER TERREUS TOUCH
OKAY THANK YOU GREAT JOB WITH
THAT WE ARE GOING TO COME NOW TO
THE OPPOSITION. AND LEAD
OPPOSITION- INCLUDES TWO
WITNESSES- JOCELYN. MARTINEZ
WEIGHED IN AARON LEVINE SO- I
BELIEVE IT WOULD BE MISS
MARTINEZ WEIGHED WHO WOULD BE
FIRST ON ON THE LINE IF YOU'RE
ON THE LINE YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON TO YOU AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THE SISTER HELEN
MARTINEZ WEIGHED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SYSTEM. IN OPPOSITION
TO SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE THE
BOARD'S POLICY PROPOSED
LEGISLATION THAT INFRINGES ON
ITS FIDUCIARY DUTY ON INVESTMENT
AUTHORITY IN ORDER TO SECURE THE
FINANCIAL FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA'S
EDUCATORS. AND INVEST THE TRUST
FUNDS FOR THE EXCLUSIVE BENEFITS
OF THE TRUST'S BENEFICIARIES.
HEALTHCARE SHARE THE SENSE OF
URGENCY REGARDING CLIMATE CHANGE
AND IS FOCUSED ON UNDERSTANDING
AND RESPONDING TO THE RISKS IT
PRESENTS BOTH TWO CHARACTERS
PORTFOLIO AND ABLE ECONOMIC
GROWTH. IN ORDER TO MINIMIZE
RISKS THE PORTFOLIO WE ARE NOT
WAITING WE'RE PROACTIVELY TAKING
STEPS NOW TO REDUCE EMISSIONS
FROM OUR PORTFOLIO IN BOTH THE
SHORT AND LONG TERM DEBT LIKE TO
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO GO OVER
SOME OF THOSE. INVESTMENTS IN
LOW CARBON SOLUTIONS WE HAVE TO
ENTER NINETY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN GREEN BONDS AND ARG
FIXED INCOME PORTFOLIO WE HAVE
FOURTEEN POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS. IN LEED CERTIFIED
BUILDINGS AND OUR REAL ESTATE
PORTFOLIO WE HAVE FOUR POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS DEDICATED TO LOW
CARBON STRATEGIES AND OUR PUBLIC
EQUITIES PORTFOLIO. AND WE HAVE
ONE POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
IN RENEWABLE POWER AGRICULTURE
TIMBERLAND AND LEAVE CERTIFIED
STRUCTURE INVESTMENTS IN OUR
INFLATION SENSITIVE PORTFOLIO.
WE ARE PARTICIPATING IN SOLVING
FOR THE LACK OF ROBUST AND
COMPREHENSIVE CARBON EMISSIONS
DATA AND DETERMINING APPROPRIATE
CARBON RELATED METRICS AND
INTERIM EMISSIONS REDUCTION
GOALS THAT ALIGN WITH THE
FIDUCIARY DUTIES AND ACCEPTED
CLIMATE SCIENCE. AT ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE MOVES CHARACTERS
AWAY FROM THE FRONTLINE EFFORTS
BY CHANGING THE FOCUS TO THE
INVESTMENT WHICH IGNORES CAL
STIRS EXPOSURE TO THE BROADER
ECONOMY AND UNDERMINES EFFORTS
TO REDUCE EMISSIONS AND
TRANSITION TO A LOW CARBON
WORLD. SERIES SOCIO WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE CANNOT SIMPLY BE DIVESTED
AWAY. THERE'S NO WAY TO KNOW FOR
CERTAIN WHETHER THE PORTFOLIO
WILL DO BETTER OR WORSE WITH
INVESTMENT OF A CERTAIN SECTOR
WHAT. WE DO KNOW IS THAT
DIVESTMENT RICH YOU DIVERSITY OF
OUR- WHICH ADDS TO THE- AND
POLITICS. HAS SHOWN THAT IS
AFFECT THANK YOU RESULT LONG
TERM LAW TO THE- COMPOUNDED POTS
OF DIVESTMENT FOR CALIFORNIA TO
DATE ARE ESTIMATED TO BE NEARLY
NINE BILLION DOLLARS. IN FOR
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE SB ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE.
HOPE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON
HOLISTIC SOLUTIONS THAT
ACKNOWLEDGE BOTH THE COMPLEXITY
AND THE URGENCY OF THIS GLOBAL
CHALLENGE. THANK YOU. EVERYTHING
THROUGH TESTIMONY- WILL NOW MOVE
TO ERIN LINE. IT AFTERNOON
SENATOR CORTEZ THE MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE LABOR COMMITTEE I
MEAN VERY MONEY AND I PROBABLY
APPEAR BEFORE YOU ON OF THE
NEARLY HALF MILLION HARD WORKING
MEMBERS OF THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA. INCLUDING OUR TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
AND RETIREES IN STRONG
OPPOSITION SB SEVEN ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE HAVE A CRITICAL
SKILLS GENDER GRANT HEADLINES
YOU STABILIZE AT LEGAL INDUSTRY.
WIDE MAGICIAN AND THE THOUSANDS
OF OUR MEMBERS AND RICH THE
HARDER PENSIONS. OF CALIFORNIANS
GROUNDS STATE. YEAH HAVE TO LIKE
THE OIL AND GAS FINISH TO REJECT
THIS. IT WILL FORCE THANK YOU.
FOR THE PENSIONS OUR PUBLIC
CENTRAL. TO DIVEST FROM INDUSTRY
THE AUTHORS OF THIS BILL WOULD
VERY MUCH LIKE THE BILL OF FIVE.
MEANWHILE THERE UPWARDS OF
THIRTY MILLION CARS AND TRUCKS
ON THE ROAD IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THAT'S THE VERY SAME INDUSTRY
THIS BILL WHICH SEEKS TO
DESTABILIZE SUCCESSFUL. MAKE NO
MISTAKE THIS BILL WILL DO
NOTHING TO DECREASE DEPENDENCE.
ON THAT. OIL GAS IN CALIFORNIA.
SILICON WOULD FAVOR PENSIONS
BECAUSE THE SUPPORTS COUNTRY
AROUND THE STATE. PEOPLE WHO ARE
GIVEN THEIR ANTI WORK LIFE TO
THE STATE WHO ARE NOW WATCHING
PUBLIC. USING AT THE POLITICAL
PINE BAG NOT TO ADVANCED. SIMPLY
TO MAKE SOME NOISE. NOT ONLY
CALPERS AND CAL STIRS AT THE
DEFENSE FROM OIL AND GAS
INVESTMENTS INVESTMENT FORMED
FIELD RETURNS BUT THEY WOULD
HAVE TO TAKE THAT FROM THE
MULTITUDE OF SUCCESSFUL. THAT
CARRY OIL AND GAS MASKS FOR
EXAMPLE BLACKROCK BERKSHIRE
HATHAWAY DILUTED HUNDRED TWELVE
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS RESPECTFULLY.
CALLING INSTABILITY AND THE
PENSION OF COURSE TO PRETTY MUCH
SO OFF WILL PERFORM AND THAT.
FINALLY IF THE AUTHORS TO GATHER
ONE FUND INVESTMENTS AND HELP
THE WORKING PEOPLE CALIFORNIA
FISH COULD LOOK TO ENCOURAGING
DEVELOPMENT FROM THE ANTI UNION
PUBLIC COMPANIES HANGING OUT ON
WALL STREET. WALMART AMAZON AND
TESLA COME TO MIND FOR IS CHILD
LABOR IS ON THE RISE FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN A VERY LONG TIME
MAYBE LOOK TO DIVEST FROM TE
COMPANIES ARE PROFITING OFF OF
THE CHILDREN MY NAME IS THE M.
IN FOREIGN LANDS. OR. LOOK AT
DISCOURAGING INVESTMENT. DO YOU
LIKE ACTIVE TO. WHO ACCORDING TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT FAIR.
SKILLS WELL. WE CALL AND JUST A
WEEK AGO WALDRON EIGHTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS GOVERNMENT TO
BEGIN TO COMPENSATE THE
MULTITUDE OF WOMEN. A FROM THE
JOB. THE BUILDING TRADES FOR CAN
TO PROTECT WORKERS WHAT YOU'RE
BEING WOMEN OR EVEN CHILDREN IN
THE WORKPLACE WORKERS FIGHTING
ANTI UNION EMPLOYERS AND NOT
FIGHT THE ACTUAL WORKERS
THEMSELVES. THOSE WITHIN THE
ENERGY SECTOR FOR THOSE RELYING
ON PUBLIC PENSION. THE LAST TWO
YEARS HAVE CERTAINLY BECAUSE I'M
NOT FINISHED ABILITY FOR WORKING
FAMILIES. ON BEHALF OF THE
NEARLY HALF A MILLION MEMBERS WE
ARE BROKERS. FIFTY EIGHT PEOPLE
KILLED AND VAST MAJORITY OF
RENEWABLE ENERGY PRODUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA WE URGE A NO VOTE ON
UNNECESSARY AND HYPOCRITICAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SORRY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
ORGAN ASKED AUTHORS ANYONE HERE
THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
STEP FORWARD WITH OPPOSITION A
TO SENATE BILL OF SEVENTY THREE
. HI HI GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR CENTER FOR ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE NOT TAKEN%
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THIS BILL
BUT WE DO HAVE CONCERNS. OUR
CONCERNS COME DOWN TO EVEN
CAN'T- INDICATE CONCERNS ONLY
THE LEAD WITNESSES CAN DO THAT I
APOLOGIZE BUT- THIS IS- WE'RE
NOW ON THE SEGMENT OF.
IDENTIFICATION AND SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION IS SOMEWHERE HEARING
THAT YOU'RE YOU HAVE CONCERNS
THE CORRECT THAT WOULD BE YOUR
POSITION THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
APPRECIATE IT. HAVE TO BE FAIR
TO EVERYONE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE. WAITING ON THE ON THE
MODERATORS LINE AS WELL ANYBODY
ELSE HERE. WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU AND I WANT
TO CLARIFY- ACTUALLY BOTH
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION- FOLKS
HAVE INQUIRED ABOUT. THE
CAPACITY OF THE LINES AND
WHETHER OR NOT THE LINES WOULD
WOULD STAY OPEN AS PEOPLE ARE-
SORT OF DISMISSED OUT AS AS A
COULD THEIR TESTIMONY. AND IT'S
OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT IS
WHAT'S HAPPENING YOU FOR THE
MODERATOR ON THE SUPPORT SIDE-
SEVERAL TIMES CONTINUE TO QUEUE
UP. FOLKS WERE WAITING OUT
THERE- OR LET PEOPLE KNOW WHAT
THE NUMBER IS IF THEY'RE WAITING
OUT THERE SO THAT THEY CAN CALL
IN. AND MODERATOR CORRECT ME IF
THAT IF THAT SCENARIO-
INACCURATE- BUT OTHERWISE- IF
THAT IS ACCURATE TO- WE JUST
WANT TO GET THAT OUT THERE FOR
THOSE WHO ARE WATCHING OR
LISTENING ON THEIR DEVICE. THAT
THEY CAN CALL IN- AS THE LINES
OPEN UP IN WILL TURN IT BACK
OVER TO YOU NOW TO QUEUE UP
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. YES THAT
IS CORRECT THAT THE LINES WOULD
BE OPENED AS OF FOLKS TO DROP
OFF. AND. CURRENTLY IF YOU WISH
TO ASK OUR FIRST COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF THE SB. ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MODERATOR AND HOW
MANY ARE IN THE QUEUE PRESENTLY-
WE HAVE TWENTY TWO. AND THAT
NUMBER IS RISING A LITTLE BIT.
OF COURSE THANK YOU. AND OUR
FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM ONE
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SENATE MINORITY
HANNAH. HELLO THIS IS THE FIRST
HAND AND EXECUTIVE SECRETARY OF
THE LOS ANGELES ORANGE COUNTY-BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL REPRESENTING OVER FIVE
THOUSAND PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
THOUSANDS OF WHICH THEY ARE IN
CALPERS WE SPEAK AND- STRONG
OPPOSITION TO ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE. NINE TO TEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS IS KEITH
DONE ON BEHALF OF THE DISTRICT
COUNCIL OF IRON WORKERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. ONE ONE NINETY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHE OTHER CHAPLAIN OR
LOG. WITH THE HUMBOLDT DEL NORD
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES. WERE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO S. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE ALSO OPERATING
ENGINEERS PUBLIC EMPLOYEES UNION
STRONGLY AT THIS TIME DO NOT
SUPPORT IT. THANK YOU. ONE ONE
EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVERAL MEMBERS
HEY HOW'S CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. ONE ONE FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS GILBERT
PREETO LOCAL FOR THIRTY ONE
TEAMSTERS UNION AND AYE OPPOSED
SB ONE ONE THREE LEAN AGAINST
DOLLARS. NINE EIGHTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME'S JESSIE
THING WITH THE OPERATING
ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE. AND I'M
JOINING THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES INOPPOSITION S. B. ONE
ONE SEVEN THREE THANK YOU. ONE
TWO FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
CAROL CAMPBELL THE SAN DIEGO
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
. MY NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. KIM
BALDRIDGE OPERATING ENGINEERS IN
OPPOSITION OF CLASS BE ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE. NINE ONE THIRTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THIS IS GREG HARMON
WITH THE INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL. ONE FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
CASE SO WITH LOCAL SIXTEEN HEAT
ACROSS INSULATORS AND INSULATORS
ARE STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL THANK YOU. ONE TWO ZERO
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT THIS IS JOHN CARTER
THE IBEW LOCAL FOUR TWENTY EIGHT
STANDING IN STRONG SUPPORT IN
THE- STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION OF AT LEAST ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU. NINE TO
TWENTY FULLER YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
JOHN SPAULDING WITH THE KERN
INYO AND MONO COUNTIES BUILDING
TRADES COUNCIL STANDING WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL ONE
ONE SEVEN THREE. ONE NINETY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING BENITO
OAKLAND BILL REPRESENTATIVE FOR
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
COUNCIL OF LABORERS AND WE
RESPECT POLITICAL POLLS S. B.
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU.
ONE ONE HUNDRED AND FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BOB GROUND CLOSER LOCAL FOR
THIRTY THREE IRONWORKERS LOT
THAN THAT WE OPPOSE THE LEVY
FAMILY TREE WELL THANK YOU. ONE
TWO FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS MIKE WEST DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND
ALLIED TRADES BECAUSE OF LOCAL
SIXTEEN TWENTY ONE WE STAND IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BUILDING TRADES
THANK YOU. ONE TO THIRTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS CHAD BOJO ON
THE COUNCIL REPRESENTATIVE WITH
THE LOS ANGELES ORANGE COUNTY
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
ONE ONE SEVEN THREE THANK YOU.
ONE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. KEVIN FIRST
SEXUAL SEARED BUILDING EXTRA CAN
TRACE AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. ONE TWO FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DROPPER CURLING WITH THEM
. THIRTY SIR CALIFORNIA STATE
PROFESSORS AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL. FIVE THIRTY
SECONDS THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE THIS. THANK YOU
THIRTY SEVEN YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. RIGHT AFTER THE GLOBAL
ENTRY DOWN WHAT WE OPPOSE. S. B.
ONE ONE SEVEN THREE. THANK YOU
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SORRY MAKE THAT OUT
ORGANIZER LOS ANGELES ORANGE
COUNTY BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL EMPLOYEE
REPRESENTATIVE. SHOULD STILL
WORK FOR. WHAT FEDERAL FUEL
COOLED DISTRICT I STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES INSTRUCTOR OF S.
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE. NINE FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE FIFTY EIGHT YOU
MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE IS OPEN. WILL MOVE ON TO
LINE SIXTY FOUR LINE SIXTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ALL RIGHT MARIO KART OF
THE WITH OPERATING ENGINEERS.
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE AT THE
ELEVEN THIRTY THREE THANK YOU.
ONE TWO FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS
COULD RECOGNIZE AGAINST THE
RECORD WITH A CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL LABORS WE ARE NOT
POSITION THANK YOU. ONE TO
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU HEAR
ME NOW. YES HELLO YES. OKAY SO
MANY PARALLEL MODERATE FACTORS
COUNTY BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL WE ARE POSTED THE
ONE ONE SEVEN THREE IN THE FORTY
STATE BUILDING TRADES. THANK YOU
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS RICK SMILES THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT COUNCIL
MEMBERS NOTHING HAPPENED A
DENTURE CAL POLY STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION OF
AT THE ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION OF SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE. FLORIDA
THANK YOU MODERATOR AND WILL
COME BACK NOW TO THE COMMITTEE
AND LOOK FOR COMMITTEE COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS. HI ANYBODY WISH WE
RECOGNIZE OUR VOICES HERE TO A
VOTE. RIGHT AS A NEW MEMBER I.
IT'S VERY HARD TO HEAR SO MANY
GOOD INTENDED BILLS- AND I'M
BEING TO EXPRESS MY CONCERNS
THAT I HAVE RIGHT NOW WHICH HAVE
. I ALWAYS TRY TO BE VERY FAIR
BALANCED AND WHEN I THINK ABOUT-
BILLS AND I TRIED TO REALLY
THINK THROUGH THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT COME FROM. AT
WHAT IT CALLED WARM HEARTED AND
GOOD INTENDED BILLS SOMEONE IT
JUST BEGAN BY EXPRESSING WHAT
I'VE LEARNED THIS PAST YEAR-
WITH REGARD TO THE OIL INDUSTRY
AND- THE ENVIRONMENT. ONE I'VE
LEARNED THAT- CALIFORNIA ONLY
PRODUCES OF ABOUT30% OF THE OIL
THAT WE UTILIZE IN THE STATE IN
THAT WE IMPORT ABOUT 70% OF THE
OIL WHICH AS YOU CAN IMAGINE WE
IMPORTED FROM AREAS THAT DON'T
HAVE THE SAME STANDARDS-
ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICE THAT WE
HAVE SO. LET ME JUST BEGIN BY
THAT- LET ME ALSO STATE THE FACT
THAT CALIFORNIA. IS THE LEADING
STATE WHEN IT COMES TO
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS LABOR LAWS
GENDER LAWS. AND EVERY OTHER LAW
YOU CAN THINK OF CALIFORNIANS
LEADS THE WAY SO IF WE'RE GOING
TO TALK ABOUT ENVIRONMENTALLY
RESPONSIBLE- AT MARKET
EVERYWHERE WE CAN PRODUCE
MANUFACTURE DISTRIBUTE. OIL IT
WOULD BE US SO I'M A LITTLE BIT
QUITE FRANKLY DISTURBING THE
FACT THAT WE WOULD TRUST OTHER
COUNTRIES TO PRODUCE THE OIL
THAT WE UTILIZE IN CALIFORNIA-
THEY DON'T HAVE THE SAME
STANDARDS THAT WE DO AND BY.
BASICALLY CLOSING OUR EYES AND
SAYING OKAY AS LONG AS WE DON'T
SEE HOW THEY DO THAT THINGS WERE
GOING TO TAKE THEIR OIL I THINK
WE HAVE A PROBLEM. SO THAT'S
NUMBER TWO NUMBER THREE THE
OTHER CONCERN THAT I HAVE WITH
THIS WITH THIS BILL- BUYS THAT
DIVESTMENT OF IT IS THAT THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF
CURBING INNOVATION- TOWARDS LOW
IN ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGY
BECAUSE MANY OF THESE COMPANIES
ARE ALSO TRYING TO- ARE HAVE
SHOWN AN EFFORT. IN TRYING TO
LEAD THE- BASICALLY THE EFFORT
OF TRYING TO FIND NEW WAYS OF
UTILIZING TECHNOLOGY- THAT IS
ZERO AND LOW EMISSION. NUMBER
FOUR- SOMETHING THAT I HEARD I
HEARD TODAY AND THAT'S THE- THE
UNINTENDED. THE CIVILIZATION OF
THE LOCAL WORKFORCE THAT WHAT
HAPPENED- WITH THE DIVESTMENT-
THAT WOULD OCCUR- WITH REGARDS
TO OUR LOCAL MARKETS BECAUSE WE
STILL HAVE THAT 30% OF THAT
WORLD IT'S BEING MANUFACTURED
MOVES TO REACH YOUR LOCALLYSO
THAT'S ANOTHER CONCERN THAT I
WOULD HAVE. IN THE AREA- SO. I
AM ONCE AGAIN GOING BACK TO
CALIFORNIA BEING THE LEADER IN
ENVIRONMENTAL LABOR GENDER IN
EVERY SINGLE OTHER- FIELD WHEN
IT COMES TO LAWS WE HAVE IT
HERE. SO IF I WOULD TRUST IN AND
I'M NOT SURE WHETHER OR NOT THE
BILL ADDRESSES THAT I WAS TRYING
TO REACH HERE IN THE NIGHT THE
ANALYSIS AND I COULDN'T FIND IT
SO. I'M NOT SURE IF I OVERLOOKED
IT BUT IT DIDN'T SPECIFY WHETHER
OR NOT YOU WERE REFERRING TO
DIVESTMENT OF OIL COMPANIES HERE
IN THE U. S. AND- INTERNATIONAL
COMPANIES OR IS IT JUST
INTERNATIONAL COMPANIES THAT YOU
WANT TO DIVEST FROM- SO THAT'S-
I'M NOT SURE IF YOU OUT INTO THE
CHAIR AT THE TIME. WHEN YOU KNOW
WHEN THE TIME COMES I WOULD LOVE
TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT THAT WOULD
BE OUT- SOMETHING THAT I MISSED
HERE SOMEWHERE BUT- TO ME- THOSE
ARE SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT I
HAVE WITH THIS BILL- THAT I
FEEL. ARE PROBABLY NOT
SOMETHING. I CAN'T SUPPORT IT
TODAY- AND- I HOPE THAT I'VE
MADE CLEAR AS TO SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE WITH REGARD
TO THIS BILL. THAT
WHOLEHEARTEDLY WELL INTENDED.
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES I
THINK IN THE LONG TERM AND
CURRENTLY WITH THAT WOULD NEED
TO HAVE THE PRODUCTION OF OIL-
WITH REGARDS TO I SEE. NEEDY NOT
OIL IN CALIFORNIA AND- CURBING
THE ABILITY TO DO THAT FOR
COMPANIES HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WOULD BE A HUGE CONCERN SO-
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
MEMBERS SURE OTHERS- CENTER
NEWMAN. THANK YOU MISTER SO I'M
SORRY YOUR DOLLARS YOU YOU AND
I'VE SPOKEN WITH THE BILL I MEAN
I'M I'M VERY CONFLICTED- AS I'VE
- HOLD YOU- NOT AS A MATTER OF
PURPOSE BUT AS A MATTER POLICY
RIGHT AND I THINK WE CAN ALL
AGREE ON THE PURPOSE OF THE
BROADER IMPERATIVE TO
DECARBONISE. BUT WITH RESPECT TO
THE POLICY DID IT'S YOU KNOW
THERE'S TWO COMPONENTS IS A
MORAL ARGUMENT- THERE'S A
FIDUCIARY I'VE BEEN OUT ON THE
ON THE MORAL ARGUMENT. YEAH-
PART OF MY CONCERNS ARE
DEFINITIONAL SO GET BUDGET
QUESTIONS SO. YOU KNOW THIS IS
BASED ON THE DEFINITION OF
FOSSIL FUEL COMPANIES IT'S
PROBABLY WORTH NOTING THAT NONE
OF THESE COMPANIES RECALL
THEMSELVES FOSSIL FUEL COMES
THIS POINT SO YOU KNOW WITH
RESPECT TO THAT. HOW DO WE
ACCOUNT FOR A COMPANY THAT HOLDS
SUBSTANTIAL CARBON ASSETS- BUT
IS AT THE SAME TIME MAKING
MATERIAL INVESTMENTS- IN
ALTERNATIVE FUEL TECHNOLOGIES
SUCH AS REMOTE RENEWABLE
HYDROGEN OR OTHER ACTIVITIES
CALIFORNIA THAT DOES THE BILL
MAKING ALLOWANCE FOR THAT OR
COULD IT. SO THROUGH THE CHAIR
THANK YOU- THANK YOU SENATOR
NEWMAN FOR A QUESTION SO. TO
SORT OF ADDRESS WHAT YOU'RE
REFERENCING AS WELL AS AS UNDER
A CHOI BOGUE IS WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE C. THE CARBON UNDERGROUND
TWO HUNDRED THIS IS A LIST. OF
THE LARGEST OIL GAS RESERVES
THAT HAVE A SPECIFIC CARBON
INTENSITY THAT IS SO HIGH- THAT
UP AGAIN DRITTEN DETRIMENT TARDE
BARNETT. AND SO WE'RE JUST
LOOKING AT THOSE TWO HUNDRED
COMPANIES WHICH IS BASED OFF OF
WHAT OTHER- THE VESTMENT
POLICIES HAVE DONE THE C. S. USE
THE UC'S ETCETERA. AND SO IT
DOESN'T TAKE IN ACCOUNT WE HAVE
AS A AS A LEGISLATURE OUR
PURVIEW IS JUST TO LOOK AT
DIVESTMENT WE CAN'T- ADDRESS. WE
CAN'T WITHIN OUR PURVIEW TELL
THE- CALPERS MISTERS BOARD- WHAT
TO INVEST IN NECESSARILY BUT IT
DOESN'T PRECLUDE THE INVESTMENTS
FOR CLIMATE SAFE- I'M SORRY
MAYBE THAT THAT'S NOT WHAT I'M
ASKING WHAT WHAT I'M WHAT I'M
ASKING ABOUT IS. THERE MAY BE
COMPANIES WITHIN THOSE TWO
HUNDRED THAT HOLD CARBON ASSETS
BUT AT THE SAME TIME DOING
RESEARCH MAKING INVESTMENTS IN
ALTERNATIVE FUELS FEARS. THAT WE
SHOULD WELCOME RIGHT AND SO IS
IT FAIR TO INCLUDE THEM AS A
MATTER AS A DEFINITION OR SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY HOLD ASSETS RIGHT
SO YOU KNOW A BUNCH OF BIG
ENERGY COMPANIES APPROACH AT
THAT DESCRIPTION. INCLUDING
CHEVRON FOR INSTANCE- WILLING
SEPARATE FROM THIS BILL THANK
YOU SIR EVEN SEPARATE FROM THIS
BILL. THE CALPERS AND STIRS
BOARD HAS TAKEN A POSITION ON
NET ZERO GHG EMISSIONS BY TWENTY
FIFTY. WHICH IS THE PARA CLIMATE
OF PARIS CLIMATE AGREEMENT AS
WELL SO BASED OFF OF THAT EVEN
LOOKING AT THAT. ON THEIR
CLIMATE ACTION ONE HUNDRED
WEBSITE WHERE THEY LIST ALL THE
COMPANIES IN THAT CARBON
UNDERGROUND IF YOU LOOK UP THE
EXXON OR CHEVRON THEY'RE NOT
EVEN HITTING THOSETWENTY FIFTY.
MARKS A REGARDLESS OF THE
INNOVATIONS THEY'RE NOT EVEN
HITTING THEIR OWN STANDARDS THAT. CALPERS AND SERVICES AS PUT
FORWARD. YEAH WHAT DO WE ACCOUNT
FOR. THEY'RE NOT EVEN HEADING
INTERIM SAID TO THIRTY TWO
THIRTY FIVE WHICH IS THE
TYPICAL. GOAL FOR CALIFORNIA
STAND. YOU DO I THANK THAT'S
AFFECT OF THAT BRINGS ME TO THE
SECOND. COMPONENT WHICH IS THE
FIDUCIARY MAIN SHOW IT SO I WANT
HIM WE'VE HEARD ARGUMENTS FROM
FOLKS IN SUPPORT. THAT HAVE SAID
FAIRLY CLEARLY THAT THIS IS IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
ENVIRONMENT NUMBER OF ISSUE WITH
THAT BUT ALSO WITH RESPECT TO
THE INVESTMENT. PORTFOLIOS OF
CALPERS CLUSTERS BUT WE'VE ALSO
HEARD FROM MISS. MARTINEZ WITH
THAT THEY DISAGREE SO IT SHOW
HOW. WITH RESPECT TO. YOU KNOW
THE FIDUCIARY PLEASE- YOU KNOW
WHAT HOW DO I SQUARE THAT WHERE
IT WHERE IT SEEMS REASONABLE TO
ME TO ASSUME- THE INVESTMENT
MANAGERS AT BOTH FUNDS ARE
ACTUALLY ALREADY DOING. THEIR
VERY BEST- IN LIGHT OF THE
FUTURE RESPONSIBILITY. AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
CENTER THE NEWMAN I'LL GO BACK
INTO THE TWENTY FIFTY GOALS WERE
NOT EVEN HITTING THOSE PEOPLE
CAN'T WAIT THIRTY YEARS AS A
MENTION. THE IPCC CAME OUT TODAY
WITH A REPORT OF OVER A HUNDRED
SCIENTISTS THAT SAID WITH THIRTY
MONTHS. TO FIGURE THIS OUT. THE
THIRTY YEARS IS TOO LONG- FOR
ONE NUMBER TWO BY THE CALPERS
OWN FIVE YEAR DIVESTMENT REVIEW.
WHICH I HAVE WHICH IS ONLINE
FOR. THE ACTUALLY ANALYZE THE
FIVE CURRENT INVESTMENT POLICIES
THAT FOR LIKE THE VESTING FROM
SADDAM SIX THE DAY LESSON FROM
TOBACCO. THE VESTING FROM COAL.
ALL FIVE OF THOSE IN WHAT IT
MENTIONS HERE'S LEGISLATIVE
MANDATES OT JUST READING OFF OF
THIS. CALPERS CANNOT THIS IS
JUST FOR IRAN DIVESTMENT.
HELPERS CANNOT DEMONSTRATE HOW
THIS DIVESTMENT DISADVANTAGES
THE FUND AND THE ANY FEASIBLE
INVESTMENT ALTERNATIVES WOULD
YIELD. A LOWER RETURN RATE OF
RETURN. TO BUY THEIR OWN
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT. IS FIVE THE
BEST POLICY. DON'T REALLY. LOWER
RATES OF RETURN. I I'M NOT SURE
THAT IS THEIR ONLY DOLLARS IT'S
A GOOD COULD I ASK MISS MARTINEZ
WAY TO TESTIFIED IN A POSITION
FOR HER RESPONSE TO THE- YOU MAY
HAVE MISSED MARTINEZ WEIGHT IS
STILL AVAILABLE AND I HAVE DONE
IT BY NOW. THE NEW MAN- I
BELIEVE THAT'S A- BUT AS HELPERS
REPORT SO FORTUNATELY CAN'T
BECAUSE THAT IS I'M WITH
CHARACTERS. FROM OUR DIVESTMENTS
WE DO SEE A REDUCTION IN OUR
FIND OF THAT THE COMPOUNDED
COSTS- FOR ALL OF OUR
DIVESTMENTS TO DATE WHETHER
MANDATED OR ON THE BOARD HAVING
VOTED ON THE MEASURE. A COST OF
NEARLY NINE BILLION DOLLARS.
IT'S OF A IF I ASK YOU MENTION
IN YOUR TESTIMONY MS MARTINEZ
WOULD. CARBON RELATED METRICS-
SO YOU KNOW AGAIN IN IN KEEPING
WITH YOUR PRODUCERS POSSIBILITY
HOW ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT
COURTLY METRICS SPECIALLY AS
DISTINCT FROM THIS BILL. VERY
GOOD QUESTION SENATOR WE'RE
WORKING WITH OTHERS WHO ARE ARE.
TRYING TO GET THOSE MEASUREMENTS
TOGETHER RIGHT NOW THERE ARE A
LOT OF APPLES TO ORANGES
COMPARISONS ARE NOT THERE'S NOT
CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE INDUSTRY
AND THE HAPPY WITH SCOPE ONE
SCOPE TWO AND SCOPE THREE
EMISSIONS. AND SO WE'RE LOOKING
TO HAVE THOSE MEASUREMENTS BE
CONSISTENT ACROSS THE INDUSTRY
SO THAT A HOLISTIC ANALYSIS CAN
BE DONE TO DETERMINE HOW TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS AND IN A ONE
PIECE OF ACTION IS HAPPENING ON
THAT IS THAT THE SEC AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. WHEN THERE ARE
TRYING TO GET THAT CONSISTENT
MEASUREMENT OUT THERE NOT FOR
EXAMPLE. AND I APPRECIATE THAT
AND SO. SOMEBODY I THINK IT WAS
THE TREASURE'S OFFICE MENTIONED.
THAT THE FIDUCIARY GUARDRAILS
THAT ARE NOW INCLUDING THE BILL
IS THAT A REFERENCE- TO I GUESS
TO THE CHAIRPERSON EXHAUSTED TO
THE NEW AMENDMENTS. THE MOST
RECENT QUARTER AMENITIES OR
SOMETHING ELSE. I BELIEVE SO BUT
DO TRAFFIC LIGHT TO FOCUS ON AS
WELL. THERE IS THERE EXISTING.
IN THE BILL- PRIOR TO THE
AMENDMENTS HAD BEEN ACCEPTED BY
THE AUTHOR TODAY- THAT- THAT
REQUIRED DEFERENCE TO THE
PRODUCE FIDUCIARY. DUTY OF THE-
OF THE OF THE FUNDS M. IF
THERE'S BEEN FURTHER CLARIFIED
IN THE AMENDMENTS- CLARIFY THAT
FOR YOU KNOW IT'S VERY URGENT TO
QUESTIONS WITH RESPECT TO EACH
ONE FOR EACH OF THE MEMBERS SO.
ON THE FIRST AMENDMENT- YOU THAT
TALKS ABOUT FORCE MAJEURE- AND
NOW THAT THAT IS PART OF THE
BILL. HOW DOES THAT AFFECT. THE
FUNDS MOVING FORWARD IS THE
REASON WAS CENSORSHIP GIVEN CUT
THE UKRAINE SITUATION THAT THAT.
THAT CIRCUMSTANCES IN AFFECTING
OUR WILL BE AT THE TIME OF
SHELTERING THE THAT THE BILL
PASSES. WE THINK YOU OF THE
CENTER WAS TALKING ABOUT EARLIER
IS THAT YOU KNOW BASED ON ON THE. ADVICE OF THIS COMMITTEE- WE
AS ALLEGES- CAN I. DICTATE TO
THE PENSION FUNDS- HOW DO THIS
WITH WE CAN DIVE WE CAN ASK HIM
TO DIVERSE ACTUALLY WE CAN
DICTATE TO THEM TODAY BECAUSE-
WE CAN'T TELL THEM HOW TO INVEST
SO. THE AMENDMENTS CALL FOR. DO
CREATE A KIND OF FORCE MAJEURE
CLAUSE THAT ALLOWS YOU KNOW THE
FUNDS TO SUSPEND THE
REQUIREMENT- BASED ON. THEIR
FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY TO
REACT. UP TO IDENTIFY AND REACT
TO THE TYPICAL KINDS OF-
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT YOU SEE IN IN
THAT KIND OF FORCE MAJEURE
CLAUSE ACT OF GOD WAR
UNFORESEEABLE. EVENT CREATES
CONDITIONS THAT. THE IMPACT
NORMAL MARKET MECHANISMS. WHAT
IS SAYS IS SO INEFFECTIVE
INFECTED WITH READING THROUGH IS
THAT. ONCE THAT DETERMINATION
HAS THEN BEEN RELAXED BY THAT
SEEM MORE NOW BY THE
LEGISLATURE- THEY HAVE- A ROLE%
TO BE SHORT PERIOD OF TIME-
CALLED OUT IN IN THE AMENDMENTS
IN IN THE IN THE IN THE BILL
LANGUAGE AS IT. IS IT WOULD NOW
STAND- TO BEGIN REINVESTING
AGAIN- HOWEVER NOTED THAT GOES
BEYOND TWENTY THIRTY FIVE WHICH
WAS JUST A TIED TO. A SUMMER
CLIMATE GOALS AS YOU KNOW THAT
BECAUSE EITHER THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE SIX AT THE SECTOR BRANCH
LEGISLATURE IS ALREADY PUT IN
PLACE. AND I DON'T THINK THAT I
WOULD THAT BE THE SUNSET IF
YOU'D LIKE US TO MAKE SENSE BUT
I I'M STILL UNCLEAR AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT- THESE CONDITIONS
WOULD APPLY NOW DID THIS IS A
MATTER OF SEVEN ASSERTION BY THE
FUNDS THEMSELVES. SO THAT THAT
DEMOCRATS SUGGEST MISS. MARTINEZ
WAITED YOU KNOW TO THE EXTENT
THAT THERE IS A YOU KNOW A
GLOBAL CONFLICT GOING ON WHICH
IS HAVING A MEANINGFUL IMPACT.
ON ENERGY PRICES IN THAT MARKET
HE WOULD WITH THAT APPLY NOW.
WITH THAT BE A GOOD BASIS FOR
SUSPENDING- YOUNG. LIQUIDATION
DIVESTMENT ON THE BASIS. THANK
YOU CENTER I CAN'T TO THE EXACT.
BUT WE ARE. SCANNING THE PORT
FOR RISK ALL THE TIME WE HAVE.
TO FIVE RE FACTOR THE WE ARE
LOOK AT- AND OUR INVESTMENT
MANAGERS ARE MAKING DECISIONS
BASED ON THAT SO SOMETHING RISES
TO A LEVEL THAT IT WILL HAVE A
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE FUNDS
THEY DO TAKE ACTION OF THEIR
INTERNAL BUSINESS AFTER THEY
WORK WITH OUR EXTERNAL MANAGERS.
OF EXAMPLE OF THAT IS WITH THE
RUSSIAN INVASION OF UKRAINE.
THAT TRIGGERED ARE RISK FACTORS
RELATED TO WAR AND VIOLENCE AND
SO THERE WERE ACTIONS THAT WERE
TAKEN ALMOST IMMEDIATELY. FROM
LATE FEBRUARY TO EARLY MARCH
THAT REDUCED OUR DIRECT
INVESTMENTS IN RUSSIA. I
APPRECIATE THAT AND SO IT'S ON
THE ON THE SECOND. AMENDMENT IT
IT IT REQUIRES AN ANALYSIS
METHODS OPPORTUNITIES- YOU KNOW
SO AS TO MAKE A SMART TRANSITION
AND ACTUALLY WITH A PARTICULAR
ON ECONOMIC CONDITIONS. ABOUT
FORTY BOTH RETIREMENT FUNDS AND
THE NET EMPLOYMENT EARNINGS OF
STATE WORKFORCE. AND SO EACH OF
THESE ARE RELATIVELY NEW MEMBERS
SO I WANT TO SEND STAND THEM. TO
THE EXTENT THAT THIS IS NOW
INCLUDED. WOULD WOULD THE
CONDUCT OF THAT ANALYSIS BE A
SUFFICIENT TO HOLD IN ABEYANCE.
YOU KNOW DIVESTMENTS OF SUCH
TIME IS AN ANALYSIS IS COMPLETED
. I GUESS IF I IF YEAH IF I MEAN
THIS IS A TEACHER BECAUSE-
COMMITTEE. DRAFTED A MEMBER'S
HAVE BEEN ACCEPTED- THAT IS PART
OF A SECTION OF THE BILL THAT
REQUIRES A REPORT TO COME BACK
ANNUALLY TO THE LEGISLATURE
WHICH WITHIN T. UP- SO TO SPEAK
THOSE THOSE ISSUES SO. IT WOULD
IT WOULD ALLOW THIS DEBATE TO
CONTINUE ON INTO THE
DELIBERATIONS AND DEBATE THAT
WE'RE HEARING TODAY ON ON AN
ANNUAL ASIS OF COURSE- IN IN
CERTAINLY IT WOULD BRING THAT
INFORMATION FORWARD TO THE
LEGISLATURE WANT TO STEP IN. AND
MODIFY THIS APPROACH OF
WORKFORCES IS STRUGGLING WE JUST
GOT THAT FROM THE FIRST ANNUAL
REPORT- NET IMPLEMENTER RESERVE
DROPPED OFF THE TABLE AND- THESE
OTHER CIRCUM THERE'S THE
TRANSITION- WHAT WE'RE GETTING
FROM THE ANNUAL REPORT IS THAT
OPPORTUNITIES ROUGHLY
EFFECTIVELY. A REDUCE FOSSIL
FUELS AND TRANSITION ARE NOT
AVAILABLE IF THAT WAS IN THE
REPORT THE I THINK THE IDEA IS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE COULD THEN.
ACT BY BRINGING FORWARD A
SUBSEQUENT BILL. OKAY BUT BUT
BUT BUT DID NOT OF THIS WOULD
WOULD SLOW DOWN OR OTHERWISE
INTERFERE WITH INVESTMENT
PROCESS IS CALLED UPON. NOT THE
BILL NOT OTHERWISE EXCEPT FOR
THE EXERCISE OF THE BOARD'S
FIDUCIARY. DUTIES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES SO THEY THEY
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
THAT ANALYSIS THEMSELVES- TO THE
EXTENT THAT. THIS OF. COURSE
MEASURE LANGUAGE EARLY IS IN
EFFECT- IF HEY'RE IF THEY'RE
CONTINUING ON THEIR MERRY WAY-
THEY HAVE TO AT LEAST. A
DISCLOSING TO CLEAR WHAT'S GOING
ON THIS ANNUAL REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE SO THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER ACTION I SAW IT
SO I GUESS I MEAN. MIGHT BE
CONFUSING- ASSIST WITHOUT THEIR
MERRY WAY IS THE BILL'S
PRESCRIBED WAY. BABY FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND FROM TESTIMONIES.
THERE THERE. CURRENT INCLUDE IS
TO DO A SIR WAY OUR FIRST IF
THIS PASSES TO DO IT ANOTHER WAY
RIGHT AND SO THE ANALYSIS. MAKES
PERMISSIVE. THERE OBSERVE
ADDITION ALICE'S INACTION OR
DOES IT SIMPLY. KOREANA STRIP
COMBINE THESE TWO THINGS
SERVICES TWO TRACKS LATER IN THE
DAY WOULD THEY WOULD STILL I
ASSUME- BE REQUIRED BY
LEGISLATION TO DIVEST SO WHAT
WHAT IS WHAT IS THE ANALYSIS TO
BY WAY OF. SLOWING THAT DOWN OR
NOT- THE I THINK THE BILL'S
PRETTY CLEAR THAT DIVESTMENT HAS
TO OCCUR BETWEEN JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN- FIRST. THOUGH I
THINK THIS FIRST PART OF THE
ANSWER- HOWEVER THE BILL. HAS
VERY CLEAR LANGUAGE- THAT WITH
DEFERENCE TOWARDS THE PENSION
FUNDS OWN FIDUCIARY DUTY
RESPONSIBILITY AND IN IN THE
CASE OF THE LEGISLATURE HAS NO
THERE'S NOTHING IN THE BILL OR
FOR THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT- TO
ENCROACH UPON THEIR FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITY SO HOW THEY
INVEST. FUNDAMENTALLY COMES DOWN
TO IT THEY'RE ON THE SAME DAY
MISTER CHAIRS WELL TO ADD YOU
KNOW SOLD ON THAT- THESE ARE
YOUR AMENDMENTS NAY APPRECIATE
THEM I THINK AT THE END OF THE
DAY THAT OVER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND UNION MEMBERS THAT
CALLED FOR THIS DIVESTMENT BILL.
ARE ALSO ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL
TRANSPARENCY AS WELL I THINK
THAT'S ALSO PART OF THIS- YOU
KNOW FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND PART
OF THIS AND I KNOW THAT- YOU
KNOW. FOR SOME TIME CALPERS AND
CAL STIRS HAVE RELIED ON ONE
TYPE OF POLICY WHICH IS
ENGAGEMENT POLICY WITH BIG OIL
WHICH IS FINE. WE HAVE TO BE AT
THE TABLE IF THAT'S WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO THAT'S GREAT TO BE
ABLE TO PUSH FORWARD. YOU KNOW
AN AGENDA OF NET ZERO AT BY
TWENTY FIFTY OR TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE. BUT IT SHOULDN'T TAKE OFF
THE TABLE DIVESTMENT AS WELL
WHICH IS PROVEN TO BE- TO BE. A
GOOD RETURN ON INVESTMENT FOR
MEMBERS OVERALL SO THAT ANY AND
AGAINST THAT SENATORS I WAS I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE WHERE WERE
YOU IN CENTER WE'RE TRYING TO
HEAR- BUT THERE'S NOTHING
PREVENTING EITHER THESE FUNDS
FROM DIVESTING NOW SO WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS. WE'RE GIVEN VERY CLEAR
GUIDANCE THAT THAT IS IN FACT
WHAT THEY'RE LEGALLY REQUIRED TO
DO. AND YOU KNOW YOU KNOW YOU
YOU MENTIONED- UNION MEMBERS AND
AGAIN I DO APPRECIATE AND I'VE
HEARD FROM LOTS OF. THAT BUT WE
HAVE ALSO HEARD FROM MANY IN
OPPOSITION TODAY AND I HAPPEN TO
KNOW. A FAIR NUMBER OF THESE
FOLKS DID YOU KNOW MANY OF WHOM
WERE FOR THE BUILDING TRADES-
ARE THEMSELVES.
ENVIRONMENTALISTS WHO ARE
THEMSELVES. FULLY COMMITTED TO
DECARBONISING CALIFORNIA'S
ENERGY ECONOMY. BUT IT IS THEIR
VERY STRONG OPINION THAT THIS
WILL HAVE A- AN ADVERSE EFFECT
ON ON THEIR WORKING CONDITIONS
AND SO. HOW DO WE RECONCILE THAT
. BUT I WOULD SAY AGAIN- GOING
BACK TO THIS BILL WHICH IS WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
DIVESTMENT. YOU TO BE ABLE TO
DIVEST ON THEIR OWN HOWEVER IF
YOU LOOK ON THEIR WEBSITE THEY
HAVE A CLEAR POLICY THAT ALREADY
SET DEEMS DIVESTMENT AS A AS A
RISK WHEN WE KNOW IT'S REALLY
NOT THAT ALREADY DEEMS IT- IN A
NEGATIVE LIGHT IN MY OPINION AND
SO WHAT I'M SAYING WITH THIS IS
THAT WE HAVE TO DO THIS BECAUSE
ALL THEY WANTED TO DO IS ENGAGE
WITH. AND SIT DOWN AT THE TABLE
WITH EXAM WHICH IS FINE YOU SIT
ON THE TABLE WITH EXXON MOBIL TO
GET THREE MORE ENVIRONMENT
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY BOARD
MEMBERS TO A TWELVE MEMBER BOARD
THAT'S GREAT THAT'S NOT A QUORUM
NUMBER TWO IT'S STILL NOT MOVING
OF THE NEEDLE FAST ENOUGH FOR
WHERE WE NEED TO GO GIVEN YOU
KNOW WHERE WE ARE CURRENTLY. SO
AGAIN THIS IS NOT LOOKING AT
NECESSARILY THE WORK FORCE AND
WHAT THIS WILL DO THIS IS SIMPLY
A DIVESTMENT BILL THAT WILL LOOK
AT ENSURING THAT IF WE ARE
DIVESTING IN THIS MOVES FORWARD
THAT THE ASSUMPTION IS THAT THE
CALPERS AND STIRS BOARD WOULD
THEN START SHIFTING MORE
ENVIRONMENTALLY SET FRIENDLY-
INVESTMENTS BUT ALSO LABOR
FRIENDLY COME COMPANIES AS WELL
AS- ERIN LEHANE ALLUDED TO THE
ESG. RISK PORTFOLIO IS WHAT WE
WANT TO OUR ESG MORE- MORE ESG
INVESTMENT IS WHAT WE WANT TO BE
GEARED TOWARDS NOT JUST THE
ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND BUT ALSO
SOCIALLY RESPONSIBLE ARE THEY
PROTECTING LGBTQ EMPLOYEES DO
THEY HAVE GOOD GOVERNANCE AND
TRANSPARENCY CLASSES LIKE WHAT
WHAT ELSE CAN WE INVEST AND
THAT'S NOT JUST ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY BUT THE WHOLE PORTFOLIO
OF SOCIALLY RESPONSIBLE
INVESTMENTS- WHICH- IS WHAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING AND THEY ARE YOU
KNOW DOING SOME WORK BUT I THINK
THEY NEED TO GO FARTHER IN ORDER
FOR US TO HIT OUR GOALS. AND
THAT IS I THINK THAT IS THAT IS
A- YEAH. DIæN SO I GUESS IT DID
PROBABLY PREVENT MISLED. ONLY
SHE CAN RESPOND. FROM MISS LANE
ARE YOU BUILD STILL. SOME AYE
SHE WAS STRUGGLING WITH HER
VOICE A LITTLE BIT. I'M HERE.
DID YOU HEAR THE QUESTION ALL
RIGHT. CAN YOU SAY IT ONE MORE
TIME PUT OUT SO THAT I'M GONNA
PARAPHRASE CENTER GONZALEZ'S
ARGUMENT WHICH IS YOU KNOW THAT
THAT THAT YOU AMONG OTHERS HAVE
HAVE- SUPPORTED THROUGH THE
GENERAL APPROACH TO ESG
INVESTMENTS. BUT AS YOU KNOW
WITH RESPECT TO THIS BILL- THE
WHOLE VIEW AND MANY OF YOUR
MEMBERS HAVE MADE THE EXPLICIT
ARGUED THAT THIS BILL WILL HAVE
AN ADVERSE EFFECT ON THE STATE'S
WORKFORCE SO IF YOU COULD
RESPOND. TO THE SENATOR'S
ASSERTION THAT THAT YOU ARE
SUPPORTIVE BUT MORE GENERALLY
THAT YOU KNOW THIS IS EXACTLY
THE KIND OF THING WE SHOULD BE
DOING. WHAT THE IMPORTANT THING
IS WE CAN'T BE PICKING AND
CHOOSING. RIGHT UNFORTUNATELY
GOING TO. DIRECTION OF YOU KNOW
OF. I'VE BEEN DRESSING AND ALL
THE COMPANIES THAT WE USE
CALIFORNIA'S SHARE VALUES WITH
THE DEFENDER SAID YOU KNOW
COMPANIES THAT THEY YOU KNOW OUR
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY OR WHAT HAVE YOU IF TO
DO I HE. FEEL LIKE THIS IS
WHAT'S TROUBLING. THE WORD. THE
PENSION SYSTEMS LIKE WITHIN LIKE
A HALF HERE WITHOUT FULLY
LOOKING AT THIS IN A
COMPREHENSIVE WAY. AND THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE WHERE WE REALLY TAKE
EXCEPTION. YOU KNOW WHAT A LOT
OF THE DEVELOPMENT CONVERSATION
THAT HAPPENS OVER THE YEARS- YOU
DON'T I WANT TO BRING UP ANOTHER
YOU KNOW THAT WE SHOULD NOT A
BUILDING TRADE ISSUE BUT THE
CALL TODAY FROM ISRAEL THAT
HAPPENED YOU KNOW A COUPLE YEARS
AGO IT WOULD BE GETTING A VERY
MUCH A SELECTIVE CHOICE OF WHERE
WE WANTED TO GET BACK. OUT BASED
ON YOU KNOW. ARE LIVE OR NOT HE
- FOR AND YOUR OTHER VALUES IT
WOULD BE. MORE HELP IN THE
JORDAN SO I THINK IT'S A PICK
AND CHOOSE. ACTUALLY CONCERNING
TO US BECAUSE THAT IS. YOU KNOW
JUST BY THE NATURE DESTABILIZE.
WE WILL MOVING TOGETHER. IN A
MORE COMPREHENSIVE WAY IT WOULD
BE LESS DE STABILIZING. AND MAKE
MORE SENSIBLE PROBABLY OUR
MEMBERS. WELL IF YOU DON'T ALL
OF THE MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
DEPENDING ON THE PACKAGE BUT
THE- IT'S HYPOCRITICAL. TO JUST
GO AFTER YOU KNOW PULLING GAS
ENERGY SECTORS WHEREAS I THINK-
I THINK IT WAS BETTER NEWMAN
POINTED OUT THAT MANY OF THESE
COMPANIES ARE ALREADY YOU. KNOW
YOU HAVE. IN ALTERNATIVE ONE OF
ENERGY I. AND OTHER. GLOBAL OUR
CHEN OR LESS CARBON INTENSIVE
GENERATION THANK YOU MUCH YOU
KNOW BROADER WAY. HELLO TO
REALLY YOU KNOW RIGHT. THE
RESPONSIBLE. MAN AND THANK YOU
TO MR IBM AND I THOUGHT YOU
GONNA FOR US ALL LAST QUESTION
THAT I TO MISS LANE ON BEHALF OF
YOU KNOW ALL OF THE WITNESSES
THE OPPOSITION IT IS JUST TO BE
CLEAR IS IT TRUE THAT IT IS YOUR
ASSESSMENT THAT THIS BILL WOULD
NOT ONLY BE DETRIMENTAL TO THE
RETURNS OF THE INVESTING FUNDS
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY WOULD BE
WOULD HAVE AN ADVERSE EFFECT ON
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE. HUNDRED
PERCENT. THANK YOU. WORKING IN
THIS INDUSTRY. WE SHOULD THAT
SHOULD THANK YOU INDUSTRY
BECAUSE I APOLOGIZE FOR BEING.
SO THAT IS IF THAT'S HOW IT
FEELS- BUT AS I SAID I YOU KNOW
I DO BELIEVE IN THE IN THE
LARGER GOAL- RIGHT AND I AM
CONCERNED HOWEVER ABOUT THIS
POLICY. THANK YOU MISTER. MR
YEAH THANK YOU- JUST ONE SECOND
SIR WHERE IT IN. THE IF. ANYBODY
NEEDS THE EXACT- SECTION OF THE
BILL THAT DEALS WITH THE SHERRY
DUTY- JUST SPEAK UP WE CAN READ
THAT OUT. PEOPLE CAN LOOK IT UP.
THANK YOU A CENTER- THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANNA MAKE
SOME COMMENTS AND FIRST. BOB
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE PAINFUL
HEARINGS WHERE. I HAD A LOT OF
FRIENDS TESTIFIED ON EACH SIDE
AND SO. ARE THAT IS ALWAYS
DIFFICULT BECAUSE IT WAS
HEARTFELT AND WRONG ON EACH AND
I THINK ALTHOUGH IN SOME WAYS IT
LIBERATES US TO TRY TO DO WE
THINK IS RIGHT- WITHIN THAT. N.
IT IT IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE I
AM A FORTY YEAR. CREDIT MEMBER
IN THE PER SYSTEM AND IT IN THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES I WAS VERY
ACTIVE IN THE DIVESTMENT FROM
SOUTH AFRICA MOVEMENT AND THAT
HAPPENED THE VOTERS OF MY TOWN
WHEN I WAS MAYOR APPROVED THE
DIVESTMENT BALLOT MEASURE THAT
WE PUT ON THE BALLOT. INTO A LOT
OF THE SAME ARGUMENTS WERE MADE
WE HEARD TODAY A. N. THOSE
NEGATIVE THINGS DID NOT
MATERIALIZE AND I THINK IN
RETROSPECT ANYBODY THAT STOOD UP
ARE FOR NOT INVESTING IN SOUTH
AFRICA WAS ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF
HISTORY. IN A AND A LOT OF THE
SAME ARGUMENTS ARE MADE THIS IS
GONNA BE LOSE WE'RE GOING TO
LOSE MONEY IT'S GONNA PUSH THE
PENSION SYSTEMS INTO A CORNER
AND IT JUST DIDN'T I THINK THE
SIGNIFICANT THING IN THE DEBATE
THAT WAS GOING ON. WHAT THERE
FIVE YEARS TO DIVEST THERE'S ALL
THE OTHER THINGS THAT CAME IN IN
THE AMENDMENTS ABOUT. ACTS OF
GOD AND EVERYTHING AND YOU KNOW
NINE ELEVEN HAPPENED SO FOUR
YEARS AND ELEVEN MONTHS AND
TWENTY FIVE DAYS AND OKAY-
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT YOU WOULD
HOPE THAT THOSE AMENDMENTS WOULD
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT. BUT IN FIVE
YEARS WITH THE PENSION SYSTEM
SHOULD HAVE THE UPS THE DOWNS
THE EVERYTHING TO BE ABLE TO
DEAL WITH THIS IN A WAY THAT IS
RESPONSIBLE TO THE FIDUCIARY
INTERESTED AND TO ME THAT TIME
FRAME HAS BEEN THE TIME FRAME.
IS THAT THAT HAS BEEN USED IT IN
OTHERS AND THE- THERE THERE BEEN
A LOT OF ARGUMENTS MADE AND I
THINK SOME OF THEM ARE
CONFLATING THINGS BECAUSE IT'S A
WHOLE ISSUE OF NOT FROM
INVESTING IN FOSSIL FUEL IN
THESE TIMES BUT- THE SOMEBODY
THAT SUPERVISED THE OIL
REGULATOR FOR EIGHT YEARS IT THE
ISSUE IS RIGHT THAT WAS SAID WE
IMPORT A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF
OIL IN CALIFORNIA. AND I THINK
THAT IS AN ARGUMENT FOR THAT IS
NOT NECESSARILY RELATED TO THIS
BILL BUT IT IS A VERY VALID
ARGUMENT IF YOU. YOU KNOW JERRY
BROWN WAS FORTHRIGHT ON THAT
ISSUE THAT ARM JEEZ IF WE FORCE
ADDITIONAL. IMPORTS BECAUSE WE
CUT CALIFORNIA PRODUCTION AND
IT'S A CHOICE BETWEEN TANKERS
AND OIL TRAINS AND ALL THESE
THINGS THAT AREN'T NECESSARILY
SAFE HOW WAS THAT SMART PUBLIC
POLICY THE REAL PUBLIC POLICY.
IS ABOUT LOWERING DEMAND IT AND
THAT IS WHAT. HAS BEEN DONE IN
THERE ALWAYS ARGUMENTS THAT WERE
MADE LIKE. THAT CALIFORNIA WAS
GOING TO GOT THE AUTOMOBILE
INDUSTRY BY DOING THE TAILPIPE
STANDARDS AND WHAT HAPPENED.
THERE WAS SO MUCH IN THE MARKET
DRAINING TWO OUT OF THE COUNTRY
CAR COMPANIES THAT MET WHAT THE
CONSUMERS WANTED. THAT IN FACT
THE GOVERNMENT HAD TO BAIL OUT
OF THE U. S. AUTO COMPANIES IN
TIME TO ALLOW THEM TO SHIFT TO
WHERE THE PUBLIC WAS IN THE
MARKET WAS AND WHEN THE- THE
REGULATIONS WERE DONE
NATIONALLY. VERY ALARMED AT THE
OTHER FORTY NINE STATES WITH
CALIFORNIA THAT WAS THE WAY THEY
DEALT WITH IT AND THAT WAS. THE
LOWERING DEMAND AND THAT THAT IS
A LOGICAL ARGUMENT TO HAVE BUT
THAT'S NOT WHAT'S CENTRAL TO
THIS BILL. ON THIS BILL IS ABOUT
INVESTING IN THE COMPANIES AND
THE LOWERING DEMAND IS A
SEPARATE ISSUE THAT I THINK WE
STILL VERY MUCH HAVE TO ADDRESS.
IT AND THE TOUGH THING IS THAT.
I GROANED I HAVE A VERY RETAIL
DISTRICT AND I MEET WITH PEOPLE
ALL THE TIME AND I MEET WITH
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT ARE JUST
. YOU KNOW THE VERSION AS YOU
OLDER PEOPLE OF REALLY SCREWED
THINGS UP THANKS FOR LEAVING
THIS ARE WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT
YOU WON'T EVEN BE HERE WHEN WE
HIT THE BIGGER IMPACTS BUT- HE-
YOU KNOW. HE I LIVE IN THIS
PLACE WHERE WE TREASURE THE FOG
IN THE SUMMER AND THE SUMMER
BEFORE LAST. WE LOST NINE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE HOMES
AND PLACES THAT IT NEVER BURNED
BEFORE HISTORY. AND THE WE
DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES
WERE CONSIDERING A BILL NATURAL
RESOURCES TOMORROW MORNING WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES TO
FIGHT THE FIRE THE FIRE WAS AT
FAULT FOR THREE OR FOUR DAYS. WE
JUST HAD OUR FIRE DEPARTMENT AT
THE CITY LIMITS ONE BIG WIND AND
IT'S AND I WAS PACKED AND READY
TO GO IN THIS TEMPERATE SEASIDE
TOWN. AND EVERYBODY IS ASKING
WHAT ARE WE DOING HOW ARE WE
GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE MAKE
A STATEMENT AND WE DEAL WITH IT
AND IT'S- IT IS AND- I THINK
SOME OF THE CONCERNS. NOT NOT ON
THE INVESTMENT BUT ON THE JOBS
ARE REALLY LEGITIMATE AND IT AND
IT REALLY IS HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THAT. THAT THERE ARE JOBS THAT
ARE GOOD PAYING JOBS WITH
PENSIONS BUT- I DON'T THINK THAT
MEANS ACCOMMODATING THE CHANGING
CLIMATE IN A WAY THAT. THAT IS
AFFECTING US EVERY YEAR WE SAY
THE FIRE SEASON IS THE WORST IN
HISTORY AND NOW. ALREADY
PREDICTING THIS NEXT ONE'S GOING
TO BE THE WORST IN HISTORY AND-
AND WE ARE SEEING THE IMPACTS OF
THE CHANGING CLIMATE NOW. AND
SO. IT MAKES THIS REALLY
DIFFICULT. BUT I THINK THAT.
THERE'S ENOUGH BILL TO THIS BILL
ON THE PAST. OF THINGS LIKE
SOUTH AFRICA BUT SO CHAU WE HAVE
FIVE YEARS TO DEAL WITH THIS.
AND WE HAVE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
TAKEN TO EMERGENCY SITUATIONS
AND- IT N. I SUSPECT IF I WENT
DOOR TO DOOR. IN MY DISTRICT I
WOULD FIND OVERWHELMING SUPPORT
FOR THIS AND SO. OF EVEN KNOW I
WANT TO WORK TO TRY TO
ACCOMMODATE EVERYBODY THAT
TESTIFIED IN THEIR WAYS WE STILL
HAVE TO DO IT. ARM I'M GOING TO
VOTE FOR THIS BILL. FIVE ZERO
ZERO THANK YOU- I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR. FOR GETTING INVOLVED
IN THE WAY THAT IS GOING TO I
THINK TAKE IS MORE IN THE
DIRECTION. OF WHERE I PERSONALLY
FEEL WE NEED TO GET- THE FIRST
AMENDMENT I THINK IS. BECAUSE OF
WHAT WE'RE GOING THROUGH WITH
THE UKRAINE AND RUSSIA THAT
MAKES SENSE TO PUT THAT IN MAYBE
A FEW YEARS AGO WE WOULDN'T HAVE
THOUGHT OF THAT BUT WE ARE IN A
REAL LIFE SITUATION REAL REAL
TIME IN HERE- THIS IS NOT A-
GOOD GUYS VERSUS THE BAD GUYS.
THIS IS. GOOD GUYS BAD GUYS ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE OF THE LINER
THE EQUATION HERE ANNA I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT. THAT
EVERYONE WHO CALLED IN IN
OPPOSITION IS NOT OPPOSE. TO A
CLEANER ENVIRONMENT IS NOT
OPPOSE IS NOT FIGHTING FOR THE
JOBS BECAUSE THEY DON'T CARE
ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT AND I
THINK WE REALLY HAVE TO REMEMBER
THAT AS WE LOOK TO FIND THESE-
THE SOLUTIONS AND THE BEST WAY
OF GETTING WHERE WE HAVE TO GET.
OUT ONE THING- BUT IF IT WAS
BROUGHT UP TODAY OR IN THE PAST
IS THE AND I THINK THAT WAS A
QUESTION BY- SENATOR NEWMAN IS
THE IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE FOSSEL
FEEL WHAT IS A FOSSIL FUELS. IF
YOU'RE DOING BOTH YOU KNOW IF
YOU'RE DOING BOTH PRODUCTION OF
FOSSIL FUEL AND YOU'RE DOING
PRODUCTION OF CLEAN CLEAN ENERGY
SO I JUST WANT TO. FOR ME THESE
AMENDMENTS- INDICATED THE- AN
INCLUSION OF THE ISSUES THAT I
CARE ABOUT. THAT WERE NOT IN THE
OTHER VERSION OF. SO I WOULD
LIKE TO ESPECIALLY OF THE ONE
RELATED TO AND NOT CONTRIBUTING
TO ECONOMIC CONDITIONS THAT
WOULD DAMAGE THE RETIREMENT
FUNDS OR THE EMPLOYMENT EARNINGS
OF THE WORK FORCE IS SOMETHING
THERE THAT I THINK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT. MAYBE WE COULD
CONTINUE TO I HOPE WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK ON AND THE
OTHER ONE IS THE ADDAMS THE TIME
FRAME. TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN HI
WE'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN THEE
CONVERSATIONS OVER THE LAST FEW
MONTHS ABOUT WHAT YEAR HOW DO WE
GET TO THAT FINAL THE GOALS AND
YET YOU KNOW MAKE SURE- MOVING
IN THAT DIRECTION AND NONE OF
THEM ARE THIS. QUICK AND I KNOW
QUICK SOUNDS TERRIBLE BECAUSE
THINGS ARE HAPPENING- AS SENATOR
LEONARD SAID YOU KNOW THESE
FIRES AND EVERYTHING THAT'S
THAT'S GOING ON BUT TO ME
COMPARED TO THE OTHER ONES AND
I'M NOT SURE IF THE IF THE
AUTHOR HAS A- OF A PARTICULAR
EXPLANATION AS TO WHY TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN. COMPARED TO A LOT
OF THE OTHER STATES THAT WE'RE
WORKING TOWARDS AS A STATE
WORKING IN- AND UNDER MUCH YOU
KNOW MORE. 552-040-2040 FIVE I
KNOW THERE IS A CRISIS IS AN
URGENCY BUT WHY EXISTE. COMPARED
TO THE DATES THAT WERE
ADDRESSING AS A STATE- BETTER
FOR THEIR HUESO I HOPE. THAT
BOTH OF REGARDS TO THE DATE ON
BOTH OF AND THE SECOND AMENDMENT
ON THE ECONOMIC IMPACT- THAT WE
COULD. WORK FURTHER ON THAT
FRONT BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
THE- MORE I UNDERSTAND THAT ARE
CHAIR HAS BEEN WORKING ON THIS.
OKAY THANK YOU- IF YOU'LL LET ME
MAKE A COUPLE. THAT IS. THAT IS
NOT MAYES MEDINA SOMEBODY. WE
STILL HAVE A MODERATOR THAT CAN
ASK PEOPLE TO ME THAT WAS NOT ME
SOMEBODY JUST SPILLED ALL THEIR
DISHES ON THE TABLE FOR NOVEMBER
THAT'S RIGHT IT IS I THINK IT'S
WORTH NOTING HERE THAT JUST ONE
LAST COMMENT THAT CENTER LATE
ACTION MADE A VERY GOOD POINT
WHICH IS. EITHER THE WORK WE
SHOULD BE DOING THE WORK WE ARE
DOING BUT THERE THAT WE SHOULD
REALLY ALWAYS IS ON DEMAND ON ON
SHIFTING THE DEMAND CURVE IN
CALIFORNIA SO I THINK THE
QUESTION OF THE S. WITH RESPECT
TO THIS BILL AS ADMIRABLE AS ITS
INTENT IS DOES IT DO THAT AND I
THINK THE ANSWER UNFORTUNATELY
ISN'T NO IT WILL NOT DO THAT IT
MAY IT MAY DEGENERATE SHIFT THE
SUPPLY CURVE. RIGHT BY BY
CHANGING KIND OF THE YOU KNOW
THE FIVE FINANCIAL POSTURE BUNCH
COMPANIES WHO IN THIS INDUSTRY-
THAT MIGHT ACTUALLY HAVE THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THE
COSTING CALIFORNIANS MORE
BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT CHANGED THE
DEMAND IN CALIFORNIA WE WILL
STILL AS AS I THINK MISCELLANY
MENTION WITH YOU KNOW FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE- SOME. THIRTY
MILLION PEOPLE GIVER TAKING
CALIFORNIA WE DRIVING IT
INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINES AND
UNTIL WE. FIGURE OUT HOW TO GIVE
THEM AN ALTERNATIVE. MUCH OF
THIS WON'T MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE
WHEN FOR. ALTHOUGH IT WILL BE
EIGHT EIGHT. YOU KNOW IN ANOTHER
PRESENT FOR HOW WEAK- SORT
PRESCRIBE TERMS TO CALPERS AND
CAL STIRS. TO DO THEIR FIDUCIARY
DUTY WHICH AGAIN I THINK FOLKS
WHO MADE THEIR DOING THEIR BEST-
AS IT IS- SO. WITH THAT I'LL
TURN IT BACK TO YOU. OKAY THANKS
CENTER. LET ME. LET ME JUST. SAY
THIS AGAIN WHEN I THINK OF THE
AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS AT THIS COMMITTEES
COME UP WITH TO. IMPART I THINK
A SENATOR ALSO WAS ALLUDING TO-
TO. TO BEGIN. A AS THIS
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS HAS TO THIS
BILL CONTINUES TO GO FORWARD. TO
IDENTIFY ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE
OF FURTHER DEBATED AND
DELIBERATED- BE ON THE FIVE
PERSONS IN THIS COMMITTEE AND I
SAY. THAT EFFICACY THE EFFICACY
OF THIS BILL IS IN QUESTION I'M
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT. THE BILL
BUT- QUESTION OF WHETHER IN THIS
WILL MAKE AN IMPACT ON. THE
REDUCTION OF GHG WHICH ACCORDING
TO UNITED NATIONS THIS MORNING
NEEDS TO BE ACHIEVED AT A 43%
LEVEL BY TWENTY THIRTY OR WERE
IN BIG TROUBLE- IN THAT'S NOT TO
GIVE UP AFTER TWENTY THIRTY TO
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE AND SO ON BUT
THAT'S THE PIECE. THAT WE'RE
TOLD BY- FOLKS IT SHOULD BE
TRUSTED AT LEAST IN THIS
COUNTRY- THE UNITED NATIONS IN
IN SCIENTISTS AND EXPERTS FROM.
ALMOST TWO HUNDRED DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS AROUND THE WORLD
TELLING US THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE
TO GET TO THE QUESTION IS DOES
THIS PARTICULAR BILL HELP US GET
THERE ANYMORE RAPIDLY THEN WE'RE
GOING INTO THE GET THERE
WITHOUT. HURTING WORKFORCE DOES
HE GET THERE WITHOUT UNDERMINING
THE WORKERS WHO ARE CURRENTLY
PAYING IN OR WORKERS WHO ARE
CURRENTLY- ENJOYING THE
PENSIONS- I DON'T KNOW. I DON'T
KNOW WHO'S HERE TODAY- ABOUT THE
EFFICACY- I LISTEN TO EVERYONE
VERY CAREFULLY TODAY. IN HIS.
VERY DIFFICULT TO READ BUT WHAT
WE HEARD FROM THE OPPOSITION I
DON'T THINK I COULD DO IT TODAY
WHO WAS A BRILLIANT OPPOSITION-
BUT IT'S ALSO- IMPOSSIBLE FOR ME
TO READ BUT THE FACT THAT WE
NEED TO KEEP MOVING FORWARD. IN
I JUST WANT TO CLOSE MY OWN
COMMENTS IN IN SUPPORT TODAY OF
GETTING THIS BILL OUT OF
COMMITTEE BY SAYING THE ONLY
THING I'M ABSOLUTELY SURE OF
THIS IS HERE TODAY IS THAT WE
NEED TO GET THE BILL OUT OF
COMMITTEE. SO THAT THIS ISSUE OF
EFFICACY CAN CAN CAN ACHIEVE A
BROADER DEBATE IN THIS
LEGISLATURE SOMETIMES THAT
HAPPENS AND SOMETIMES.
OCCASIONALLY HERE AS EACH YEAR I
FEEL THAT MY JOB IS SIMPLY
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE LIKE EVERYONE
ELSE IT COMES FORWARD. BASED ON
MY VALUES. THERE ARE A FEW TIMES
. THAT COME ALONG WORK I FEEL
THAT MY JOB IS TO. MAKE SURE
THAT THE BILL ADVANCES TO THE
BROADER DEBATE THAT REALLY NEEDS
TO HAPPEN ON THESE ISSUES- AND I
THINK- EVEN IS ELAINE TALKING
ABOUT THE BROADER DEBATE OF IF
YOU'RE GOING TO DIVEST DO YOU
AVOID THAT SLIPPERY SLOPE OR DO
YOU EMBRACE THE ISSUE OF
ALIGNING CALIFORNIA'S VALUES
WITH THEIR PENSION INVESTMENT IS
A MUCH BROADER DISCUSSION- IF
THAT DISCUSSION IS GOING TO
HAPPEN THIS YEAR IN THIS
SESSION. WE NEED TO MOVE THIS
BILL FORWARD BECAUSE IT'S
OBVIOUSLY TRIGGERING THAT
CONVERSATION AND I THINK THAT'S
A GOOD THING- WE- IF THE BILL
GETS OUT TODAY LIKELY WE WILL
ALL. HAVE ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE A DECISION BASED ON OUR
THIS IS OUR VALUES IN BASED ON
WHAT WE THEN BELIEVE THE
EFFICACY OF THE BILL AS FURTHER
AMENDED IS AS FOR THE DEBATED-
IN THAT'S GOING TO BE A TOUGH
VOTE THIS COULD BE A TOUGH FOR
B. AS WELL BUT TODAY I'M GOING
TO VOTE FOR GETTING. THE BILL
OUT OF COMMITTEE INCLUDED ALONG
SO THAT BROADER DEBATE CAN
OCCUR- THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OF METAL BY
SHERRY I KNOW YOU HAVE TO
QUESTIONS ALREADY BUT WANT TO
MAKE SURE. THAT THE CIRCLE BACK
TO IN CASE THERE'S ANYTHING ELSE
YOU NEED TO SAY IT IS JUST
GETTING. BROWN TO OF COURSE. I
JUST WANT O SORT OF JUST
REITERATE THAT THE COMMENT THAT
. I UNDERSTAND THE INTENT BEHIND
THE BILL AND- JUST THE CONCERN
THAT I HAVE WITH REGARDS TO IF
WE'RE GOING TO ADVANCE ANY
ENVIRONMENTAL- PROGRESS YOU KNOW
WITH THE URGENCY I THINK
CALIFORNIA CAN LEAD THE WAY- AND
IT HAS BEEN LEADING THE WAY THE
PROBLEM IS THAT. WE WERE.
REGULATING OUR OWN STATE THE
POINT WHERE WE CAN'T DO. I DO A
JOB WELL DONE AND WE EXPECT
OTHER COUNTRIES TO DO IT ON OUR
BEHALF WHETHER IT'S INVEST
DIVESTMENT IN THIS IN YOUR WITH
YOUR BILL BUT THE IMPACT THAT
HAS ON THE MARKET- WITH.
LIMITING OUR ABILITY TO PRODUCE
AND MANUFACTURE HERE VERSUS
HAVING TO IMPORTED I THINK IT'S
JUST A MAJOR CONCERN FOR ME.
BECAUSE AS AS MENTIONED EARLIER
THE DEMAND IT HAS TO BE- AND I
THINK WE ARE DOING PROGRESS IN
THAT SENATOR- MAN I THINK I
THINK THE CONSUMERS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE BECOMING MUCH
MORE EDUCATED AND THEY ARE
MAKING. CHOICES THEY HAVE MORE
CHOICES THAN THEY'VE EVER HAD
BUT I THINK IT'S A SLOW PROCESS-
JUST THE WAY THE HUMAN NATURE IS
BUT I THINK CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
AND WILL BE LEADING THE WAY THE
PROBLEM THAT I SEE. IS MOSTLY
WHAT'S HAPPENING INTERNATIONALLY
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- IN
pBECAUSE I'VE BEEN IN THAT
SITUATION WE'RE GOING TO START
MOVING ALONG HERE AND TO TRY TO
PICK UP THE PACE OF THE
COMMITTEE AT THIS POINT- BUT AT
THIS POINT WE- ENTERTAIN AS WELL
SURE I WOULD HAVE. THE BILL. DID
YOU MOVE THE BILL JUST THINK
IT'S JUST GOING FOR A MOTION
THANK YOU FOR THAT- THERE'S ON A
MOTION FOR WAS CONSUMED CALL THE
ROLL CALL- I'M SORRY CENTER
CONSOLE AS YOU DO OF THE
OPTICAL- I WAS LIKE YOU BEEN
CLOSING ALL. ALONG HERE. KIND OF
SORT OF AND I APPRECIATE THE
DEBATEI REALLY DO REGARDLESS OF
WHAT SIDE YOU'RE ON AND IN THE
NEED FOR MORE DISCUSSION BECAUSE
I THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT I WANTED
WAS TO ENSURE THAT WE HAD MORE
DISCUSSION WE SHOULDN'T SHUT THE
DOOR- ON THIS JUST BECAUSE WE
HAVE SOME FRIENDS OPPOSE OR SORT
OF SUPPORTING ART CETERA. AND I
KNOW YOU'RE ALL- YOU ALSO
PROVIDED REALLY INCREDIBLE
INSIGHT AND I RESPECT THE
OPPOSITION DEEPLY IN FACT I
RESPECTED SO MUCH THAT I THINK
THAT IF WE WOULD HAVE INVESTED
QUITE HONESTLY A FEW YEARS AGO-
ED CALPERS AND STIRS WOULD HAVE
HAD ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
CLEAN ENERGY. WHICH WOULD HAVE
SAID HAD YOU KNOW PEOPLE ON THE
JOB RIGHT AWAY THIS CLEAN ENERGY
FIELD AND I THINK WE COULD HAVE
BUT EASE THE TRANSITION A LITTLE
BIT FASTER IN THAT SENSE BUT-
WITH ALL THAT SAID I JUST WANT
TO SAY AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE
DEBATE THERE'S AGAIN. THANK YOU
TO BOOKS HAVE COME IN PERSONALLY
TO DEBATE AND MANY MANY FOLKS
THAT CALLED IN- AT THE END OF
THE DAY WE HAVE TO REALLY LOOK
AT THE RISKS AND OF COURSE IN
THE RATE OF RETURN. THE BEST
MEANT- HAS BEEN PROVEN AGAIN
AGAIN AND AGAIN NOT JUST
GLOBALLY BUT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
TO NOT BE THAT RISK THAT HAS
BEEN- THE ALLUDED TO BY SOME OF
THE OPPOSITION. AND SO- I ASK US
TO CONTINUE THE DEBATE AND TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSING ON BOTH
SIDES AND I WELCOME THE
OPPOSITION OF THE LIKE TO SIT
DOWN WITH ME TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT AND IN A WAY THAT'S
RESPECTFUL BUT IN A WAY THAT
ACTUALLY GET SOME STUFF DONE
FOR. FOR A STATE THE WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE IN
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU SENATOR. NO
CONSULTANT FROM THE. PICKEREL
CALLED. THE MOTION TO PASS. THE
FIRST AMEND AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY COURTESY
. COURTESY I OR TROUBLED NO A
TROUBLED NOW THE RUSSELL. THE
RUSSELL BY LAYER BY LAYER HI
NEWMAN. NEWMAN AVOIDING. OKAY SO
THAT IS A THREE TO ONE VOTE-
WITH ONE ABSTENTION AND SO THE
BILLS OUT. THE SENATOR WORK.
ISN'T IT FIVE TO STEP OUT FOR A
LITTLE BIT COULD I MOVE THE ONE
CONSENT ITEMS WE'LL GET THAT ON
THE VERY MUCH THAT WAS THE NEXT
THING ON MY HAND WRITTEN NOTES
HERE'S WE NEED TO TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND- WOULD YOU
CAN LEAVE A COURSE FOR THE MOVIE
THEATER THE WHOLE TIME BUT THEN
WILL TAKE UP THE- THE CALL ON
THE ABSENT MEMBERS BEFORE WE
MOVE ON TO ASKING HIM VERY
QUICKLY SENATORS AND IN WAITING-
I WILL GO AHEAD IN- GO TO
CONSENT. NOW SO. ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN S. B. FORTINO SIX THE
MOTION IS CONSENT. COURTESY ALL
RIGHT WHO DOES THE I OR CHOI
BOGUE BY A TRAVEL GUIDE RUSSELL
THE RUSSELL I LAYERED. AYE
LAYERED AYE. NEWMAN AYE. HI SIR
OR IT DOES SO THE CONCERN IS OUT
ON THE ON THE UNANIMOUS VOTE-
NOW- IF YOU COULD CALL- IF WE
LOOK TO CALL IN AND CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS I WANT TO DO THAT
BEFORE ANYBODY ELSE HAS TO LEAVE
SUDDENLY. WE START GETTING
NERVOUS ABOUT THE BILLS WE
ALREADY. HEARD. I ITEM ONE SB
EIGHT SIX EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS OR
CHOI BOGUE. I'M SORRY. YOU TO
REPEAT THE BILL NUMBER FOR HER
PLEASE SB EIGHT SIX EIGHT NO
ONE. I DON'T WANT. THAT OKAY
UHHUH NEWMAN SB EIGHT SIX EIGHT
NEWMAN AYE NEWMAN AYE A CHOI
BOGUE. NOT VOTING A TROUBLED
NONVOTING. S. FOR. SENATOR. FOR
YES- SO ON A FOR. ONE FOUR ONE
FOUR AND ONE OF STANCHION THE
BILLS ARE ITEM TWO S. B. ONE
ZERO ZERO TWO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS A
CHOI BOGUE. NUMBER TWO RIGHT
YES. I WOULD TROUBLED BY NEWMAN
NEWMAN I. BY SEPARATE ON THE
UNANIMOUS VOTE THE BILLS OUT.
ADAM THREE SB ELEVEN FIFTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS OR TROUBLE. I THE
TROUBLED AYE NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE-
A UNANIMOUS VOTE THE BILL ITSELF
. SB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO LIMÓN TO
PASS THE FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY A CHOI
BOGUE NO TROUBLED NO. NEWMAN
NEWMAN AYE ON A FOUR TO ONE BOTH
THE BILL IS A. AND THAT INCLUDES
THE. THE CALL ON THOSE BILLS- WE
ARE NO UP TO DATE- TEMPORARILY
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO SENATOR
HERTZBERG ON S. B. THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE SENATOR. WE DO HAVE
MORE COFFEE HERE IT FEELS LIKE
IT DELIVERED I CAN HELP WITH THE
- THANK YOU A- SEVEN MEMBERS AND
THAT HAVE DEEP RESPECT AND
CONSIDERATION OF THIS COMMITTEE.
I TEXTED THE SEVEN HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO PEOPLE THAT WERE
GOING TO SUPPORT. THIS MEASURE
AND- ASK THEM- BUT TO A STAND
DOWN- SO THAT YOU CAN. GET THE
BUSINESS OF THIS COMMITTEE DONE
. IN IN BRIEFLY ARMED SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY NINE WE HAVE
BEEN DEALING WITH A CHALLENGING
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN TRYING TO
FIND ON HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
FOR. DOCTORS AND A WHOLE HOST OF
FOLKS IN THE COUNTY AND THERE
HAS BEEN. NEGOTIATIONS FROM
NINETEEN NINETY TWO THOUSAND ONE
THAT IN TWO THOUSAND TO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GILBERT SAID
THE- PASS LEGISLATION THAT
RESULTED ULTIMATELY TO PROTECT
THOSE DOCTORS IN TERMS OF THEIR
CHOICES OVER HEALTHCARE. THEN
THERE WAS LITIGATION IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE IN A WHICH WAS
SETTLED IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
AND NOW WE'RE BACK AT IT IN
TERMS OF CHICORY WITH THE WITH
THE PRESSURES THAT L. A. COUNTY
MEDICAL PRACTITIONERS
PROFESSIONALS HAVE TO DEAL WITH
GIVEN THE PANDEMIC AND THE
COUNTY HAS BEEN OFFERING SUBPAR
HEALTHCARE BENEFITS. CERTAIN
POSITIONS DEPENDING UPON WHETHER
OR NOT THEY PARTICIPATE IN
EMPLOYMENT ORGANIZATION FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO BRING
CLARITY THE LEGAL BILL WAS IN
TWO THOUSAND TWO WHEN I WAS HERE
AND I REMEMBER THAT AND THAT
TALKED ABOUT. COUNTIES OVER FOUR
MILLION THIS MAKES IT ABUNDANTLY
CLEAR THE MANDATE FOR LOS
ANGELES COUNTY TO ORDER TO
PROTECT THESE FOLKS AND GIVE
THEM THE KIND OF CHOICE THAT
THEY DESERVE AND THEY WON IN THE
LITIGATION THAT THEY HAD IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE SO WITH THAT.
I HAVE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNION OF AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS HOPEFULLY FEES STILL
HERE AS WELL AS WELL AS-
CHRISTOPHER- FROM THE- ALSO FROM
THE AMERICAN VISITS AND THIS. TO
IT A BLESSING. FOR A DOCTOR
BESSIE- IF YOU ARE AVAILABLE YOU
MAY GO AHEAD AND PROCEED WITH
YOUR TESTIMONY THANK YOU. DR
BOTH THE ON THE LINE. HE MIGHT
BE MUTED- OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT. WHAT ONE OF THE FIRST NAME
STEWART TEWART BUSSY STORED
WE'RE- I DO NOT SHOW STORE ON
HOW BUT I FEEL THAT I CAN BE
CHRISTOPHER THERE. CHRISTOPHER
AGE FOR IT ONLINE YOU ARE OPEN
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO THEN YOU.
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL
GET EVENING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
BUT IT'S CHRIS FOR YOU GET- ON
STAFF WITH THE INTERAMERICAN
POSITIONS AND DENNIS ASKED ME
LOCAL TO US SIR. WE OFFER
SUPPORT FOR S. B. THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN. THIS BILL WILL STOP
THE PRACTICE OF DISQUALIFYING
UNIONIZED EMPLOYEES FROM
PRESCRIPTION AND HEALTHCARE
BENEFITS. CLIENTS THAT VIæT
INCREASED BENEFITS THAT ARE ONLY
AVAILABLE TO YOU MANAGERIAL
EMPLOYEES OR NOT MEMBERS OF THE
VULCANIZED. ORGANIZATION
CURRENTLY IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
UNIONIZED DOCTORS AND OTHERS
HIRED ARE ONLY ALLOWED TO
PARTICIPATE IN A BENEFITS
PACKAGE THAT IS 20% LESS THAN
MANAGEMENT AND NON UNIONIZED.
DOCTORS DENNIS. DOES THAT ARE
VACANCY RATES OF ALMOST 25% OR
MEMBERS. UNITS OF COURSE CHANGES
TO THIS PRACTICE AB HELPED
MIDNIGHT CITING A PASSPORT FOR.
PARKINSON'S. IN DECISIONS. HI
THIS OF HAVING MANAGE- NOT
BENEFITS THAT IS NEAR. SET
WORKERS IS SEEN TO STATE FORCE
FOR LABOR AND THE INTENT OF THE
THREE THOUSAND SO. PEOPLE THAT
THE FOR LOCAL. ALL AND WE ARE
YOU WHAT THE OF OUR- LIKE.
PHARMACISTS AND- THIS AT THIRTY
THIRTEEN. A SECOND EQUAL. THANK
YOU. THE MORE PLEASE. AIR AND
CONFUSING- SORRY MY NAME IS TO
OUR JOBS AND RUTH THE UNION OF
AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND DENNIS
AND THE DOCTOR VICE HE'S ASKED
ME TO PLEASE READ HIS FOCUS INTO
THE- ON THE RECORD NEARLY ALL HE
IS THERE IS THERE NOT TOO MUCH
YOU KNOW THERE. YEAH I GOT I
JUST GOT ON I'M SORRY RIGHT
NEVER MIND NEWMAN. HI MY NAME IS
EARL STEWART BUT SEE I'M OF
BOARD CERTIFIED FAMILY DOCTOR.
ON A JOURNEY AND PRESIDENT OF
THE UNION OF AMERICAN PHYSICIANS
AND GAS ASKING LOCAL TWO OH SIX.
I'M FINALLY SPORTING'S THE
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN. WHAT ARE
PSYCHIATRISTS AND DENNIS
ORGANIZED. IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES THE MAGGOTS ELECTRIC
HAVE PREMIUM MEGAPLEX DIDN'T
EXIST. THANK OF WORKERS WORKING
BETWEEN FOURTEEN AND 17% OF AN
EMPLOYEE'S SALARY. AND THE
CHOICES PLAN WHICH I LIKE.
THANKS FOR YOUR CHOICES PLAN- IF
THE MUCH LOWER BENEFIT IT'S
CRITICALLY MANSION. THE WE
ORGANIZE THE EIGHT HUNDRED
DOCTORS OF L. A. COUNTY NINETEEN
NINETY DIFRANCO. IT HAS BEEN A
PLACE THEY ALREADY HAD NOT A
MULTIPLEX. BUT THE DISCOURAGE
THE UNIONIZATION COUNTY CLAIMED
THAT IT HAD A POLICY OF NOT
ALLOWING. EMPLOYEES INTO THE
MEGAPLEX. DIDN'T MAKE ANY SECRET
WHY IT WANTED TO RESERVE THE
BEST BENEFIT FOR NON UNIONIZED
PEOPLE ONE OF THE SPOKESMAN
ACTUALLY STATED. WHAT THE COUNTY
HAS TO GIVE AN INCENTIVE FOR
WORKERS NOT THE UNIONIZED. BUT
OUR DOCTORS GOING TO ANYWAY. AND
DURING THE FIRST CONTRACT THE
COUNTY WOULDN'T AGREE TO OFFER.
THEM BOTH IN A MILIEU WHICH
CIRCLE ENACT A FLEX THEY WERE
UPSET AND DECERTIFY THE UNION
AND THE COUNTY REPORTED THAT THE
CERTIFICATION BY RESTORING THE
PREMIUMS. FOR CLEARLY UNION
DISCRIMINATION. WE FILED A
LAWSUIT YOU OF THESE AND OF
COURSE THE VIDEO- AND GRAY DAVIS
SIGNED INTO LAW A. B. THE FACT
THAT ACCEPTS WHICH MADE IT
DISCRIMINATORY. TO REMOVE. A
DISQUALIFIER MEMBERS. I WE REACH
. TUESDAY SO- A. COUNTY VAN OF A
LITTLE IN THAT LAW TWO. SIX
DURING THE PROJECT. THEY
REFERRED TO OFFER MEGAPLEX OUR
MEMBERS. ALTHOUGH THEIR MANAGERS
AND OTHER PROFESSIONALS HAD IT.
TOOK TO AVOID. ANOTHER DE SER WE
AGREED TO A COMPROMISE L. A.
COUNTY WITH GRANDFATHER THOSE
PHYSICIANS WHO ALREADY HAD NOT
EXPECTED BUT THE FUTURE MEMBERS
. I INTO THE INFERIOR PLAN
AFFECT FORWARD TO TWO FOR TWENTY
TWO ONLY 30% OF OUR DOCTORS NONE
OF OUR PSYCHIATRIST DENNIS THE
PHARMACIST. AB PREMIUM PLAN SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE CLOSE THAT
LOOPHOLE- BY PREVENTING THE
COUNTY FROM REJECTING ANY. UAV
PROPOSAL. TO OUR MEMBERS EQUAL
HEALTH BENEFITS. SO FOR BESIDES
AND RETURN AND RECRUITMENT. THE
DOCTORS HAVE SUFFERED FROM THE
PEPPER REFORM ACT TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN IT'S ONLY FAIR AND
EQUITABLE FOR YOU A FEW DOCTORS.
TO BE OFFERED BENEFIT EQUAL TO
OTHER PROFESSIONALS NEEDS
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THEIR
LOWER EFFORTS DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AND QUALITY IRONIC
THAT THOSE WHO PROVIDE DIRECT
CARE TO PATIENTS ARE NOT OFFER
THE SAME HEALTHCARE BENEFITS FOR
THOSE WHO DO NOT PROVIDE DIRECT
HERE I ASK FOR YOUR AUTO THEN SB
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN THANK. THANK
YOU MISTER RESI. AND WILL NOW
BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. MADAM
CHAIR BY GEORGE OSBORNE FOR YOU
A TD AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK WITH IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN THIRTEEN
HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
. SEEN NONE THANK YOU WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY AT THE AT THE
TELECONFERENCE ARE VERSUS.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
FROM THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN WE WILL BEGIN
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY
. PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE MOMENT
OUR FIRST MY NUMBER. FIVE TO
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
KAREN MEMBERS CHRISTOPHE MAIRE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
WE ARE A CO SPONSOR ADDED SB
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN AND WE URGE
YOUR STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE TWO THREE FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
EVENING SENATORS LISTENED- DOUG
CHIPATA I AM THE- CARE OF THE
ASHLEY CALIFORNIA STEERING
COMMITTEE- ALSO THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE UNION OF
AMERICAN. PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS ACTUALLY LOCAL TO HAVE
SEX WITH THANK OF SEND HERTZBERG
CHRIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE-
I WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU OF MATTER MODERATOR
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL THE
SUPPORTERS WILL NOT FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM THE
OPPOSITION. WE DO HAVE TO LEAD
OPPOSITIONS FOR BILL S. B. TO
THEM. WE DO NOT HAVE ANY LEAD
OPPOSITION I APOLOGIZE MY
MISTAKE- PERFECT. SO HAVING NO
LEAD OPPOSITIONS- MADAME
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND-
ACTUALLY LET'S MOVE ON TO THE AT
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON IT IN
OPPOSITION SORRY HERE IN THE
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. C. NINE
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO- THE
LINES MADAME MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE CHECK THE LINES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN THERE. NO COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN. THANK YOU MODERATOR
WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL OUR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WILL NOT BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO OUR MEMBERS DO ANY OF
OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. I WOULD LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL PLEASE. WE HAVE
SENATOR ONLY WHO LIKE TO THE
BILL I HAVE ONE QUESTION- CENTER
HERTZBERG- IN THIS HAS TO DO
WITH- A COMMENT THAT I HAVE HERE
WITH REGARDS TO THIS IT BEING AN
ISSUE THAT SHOULD BE ADDRESSED
THROUGH THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT PROCESS.
AND WHETHER OR NOT THIS MAY BE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL- ACCORDING TO
AN ARTICLE ELEVEN SECTION ONE B.
OF THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
WHICH PROVIDES THAT THE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS TO PROVIDE
FOR THE NUMBER COMPENSATION
TENURE AND APPOINTMENT OF
EMPLOYEES- INCLUDING THE
BENEFITS INCLUDING THOSE
PROVIDED THROUGH THE MAKE A FLEX
FLEXIBLE BENEFIT PLAN IN THE-
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. YOUR
COMMENTS IF YOU HAVE ANY. HOW TO
ANSWER THAT YES CERTAINLY THEY
THEY MAKE THOSE DETERMINATIONS
AND JUST LIKE WITH RESPECT TO
MEASURE J. LOS ANGELES CERTAIN
THINGS ARE NOT ELIGIBLE BUT THE
ONE THING YOU CAN'T DO FIRST IS
EVERY COUNTY ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES CALIFORNIA OUR
SUBDIVISIONS OF THE STATE SECOND
TO THE EXTENT THAT HAVE A POLICY
WHICH THEY DO HAVE A POLICY FOR
MEGAPLEX THEY CAN'T
DISCRIMINATE. THIRD I COULD BE
HAPPY TO READ TO YOU THE COURT
CASE THAT WAS DECIDED ON THE- BY
TWENTY FIFTH TWO THOUSAND FIVE
IF YOU GUYS WOULD DEVOTE DID
GIVE ME THE TIME IT'S ONLY ABOUT
THIRTY FIVE PAGES. BUT THE
ANALYZE THIS ISSUE IN THIS COURT
CASE IN THE CASE OF UNION. OF
AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS. PLAINEST AN APPELLANT
VERSUS LOS ANGELES COUNTY
EMPLOYEES RELATIONS COMMISSION
AND THAT WAS DECIDED. BECAUSE WE
HAD THE SAME KIND OF ISSUE WHICH
WHICH HAS RESULTED IN. IN THIS
PROBLEM THAT WE HAD AND THEY
MADE THAT DETERMINATION SO
CERTAINLY SOMEONE COULD MAKE
THAT ARGUMENT WE CAN MAKE ANY
ARGUMENT BUT IT BY JUDGMENT
AFTER PRACTICING LAW FOR FORTY
THREE YEARS. AND READING THE
HOMEWORK AND ACTUALLY READ THE
COURT CASE HERE. IN PREPARING
FOR THIS HEARING TODAY I DON'T I
THINK IT'S NOT VERY STRONG
ARGUMENT. THANK YOU FOR. BUT I'M
HAPPY TO READ THE GOOD A LET THE
CASE TO YOU IT'S- TAKE ABOUT
FOUR MAYES TWO THREE HOURS.
THAT'S OKAY YOU CAN SEND THAT
OVER NOW ARE YOU FROM AROUND-
OKAY SO THINK ANY OTHER COMMENTS
NOW I REALLY WANT. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE SENATORS
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU HAVE WHAT
THEY DESERVE KILEY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WE HAVE A- MOTION
THIS THE MOTION IS. DUE PASSED
BUT FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY- YES ALL
THE ROLE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY COURTESY
OR CHOI BOGUE NO A TROUBLED KNOW
WRESTLE. BY THE REST OF I
LAYERED. NEWMAN AYE NEWMAN I
WILL PUT THE BILL ON CALL FOR
UPS AND MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOW WILL MOVE ON TO HAVE
SENATOR BRADFORD PRESENTING
BILLS SB. THIRTEEN THIRTY FOUR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE FOR THIRTEEN
THIRTY FOUR WHICH WILL
EXPLICITLY INCLUDE PUBLIC SECTOR
WORKERS PROVIDE OR SUPPORT
DIRECT PATIENT CARE AND HOSPITAL
CLINIC. AND PUBLIC HEALTH
SETTINGS AND SECTION. FIVE ONE
TWO. GUARANTEEING ENFORCEABLE
MEAL BREAKS AND REST PERIODS
FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK AND I
WITH MY OFFICE ON THIS MEASURE
AND I ACCEPTED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE THIS BILL
CONSISTENT WITH EXISTING WAGE.
ORDERS OCCUPATIONAL FATIGUE IS
KNOWN. WAS A KNOWN ISSUE. IN THE
GENERAL U. S. WORKFORCE AND
THERE IS EVIDENCE. THAT IS
PROPELLANTS IS THE MARKS NURSES
AT A MUCH HIGHER RATE NO SO
BECAUSE MY MOTHER'S A RETIRED
NURSE EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
NURSES TYPICALLY TOOK FEW BREAKS
DURING SHIFTS AND OFTEN. FACE
GREATER WORKLOADS BECAUSE OF.
INSUFFICIENT STAFFING. WORKING
UNDER SUCH CONDITIONS ALEXIS
BECAUSE FATIGUE FEELING VERY
TIRED OR EXHAUSTED BOTH
PHYSICALLY AND EMOTIONALLY WHICH
IN TURN CONTRIBUTES TO POOR
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
OUTCOMES PRIVATE SECTOR NURSES
ARE GUARANTEED MEAL AND REST
PERIODS WHILE NURSES EMPLOYED IN
PUBLIC SECTORS. LACK THESE BASIC
PROTECTIONS EVEN THOUGH THEY
PERFORM THE SAME EXACT DUTIES IN
GENERAL CALIFORNIA LABOR CODE
HAS NOT BEEN FOUND THE COVER
PUBLIC SECTOR EMPLOYEES UNLESS
EXPLICITLY STATED HOUSE WHEN
BOYS ON THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND OTHER PUBLIC.
SECTOR HEALTHCARE FACILITIES ARE
OF THE SAME MAIL BREAK AND REST
PERIODS AND FORCIBLY THAT THE
PRIVATE SECTOR CURRENTLY ENJOYS
AND HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
TODAY'S CURTIS LYING M. MORE
WATER. CAMARA OF THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION OR IS REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A SENATOR BRADFORD WE HAVE-
WE HAVE. CURTIS LANG JUNIOR ON
THE LINE. YES MA'AM GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS- CURTIS LANE
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION PROF SPONSORS OF SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY FOUR WE THANK
SENATOR RAPPER FOR CARRYING THIS
BILL GIVEN ALL THAT ARE NURSES
HAVE ENDURED AND CONTINUE TO
INDOOR DURING THE PANDEMIC SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY FOUR IS MUCH
NEEDED LEGISLATION. THAT SENATOR
BRADFORD INDICATED CURRENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA ONLY PRIVATE SECTOR
NURSES ARE GUARANTEED MEAL AND
REST PERIODS WELL NURSES
EMPLOYED IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR
LACK THESE BASIC PROTECTIONS
EVEN THOUGH THEY PERFORM THE
SAME DUTIES TO REMEDIATE TO
REMEDY THIS DISPARITY SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY FOUR ENTITLED
EMPLOYEE PROVIDES DIRECT PATIENT
CARE OR SUPPORT DIRECT PATIENT
CARE IN A GENERAL CUTE CARE
HOSPITAL CLINIC FOR PUBLIC
SETTINGS. AND WAS DIRECTLY
EMPLOYED BY A PUBLIC EMPLOYER
TWO ONE TWO ONE UNPAID THIRTY
MINUTE MEAL PERIOD ON SHIPS OVER
FIVE HOURS A SECOND UNPAID
THIRTY MINUTE MILPITAS HITS OVER
TEN HOURS AND ALSO- ONE TEN
MINUTE PAID REST PERIOD FOR
EVERY FOUR HOURS WORKED.
HOSPITAL EMPLOYEES THAT YOU SEE
AND OTHER PUBLIC SECTOR
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES DESERVE
THE SAME MEAL AND REST PERIOD
IMPOSSIBILITY THAT THE PRIVATE
SECTOR CURRENTLY ENJOYS AS
DECEMBER MENTION OCCUPATIONAL
FATIGUE IS A KNOWN ISSUE AND IN
THE UNITED STATES AND HAS
INDICATED THERE'S EVIDENCE THAT
IT'S PREVALENT AMONG NURSES IS
MUCH HIGHER- BETTER RESTED
NURSES WILL PROVIDE A HIGHER
QUALITY PATIENT CARE FOR
CALIFORNIANS IN IS FOR THESE
REASONS. I RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB THIRTEEN
THIRTY FOUR THIS EVENING AND
TURNED OVER TO REGISTERED NURSE
MORE WATER CAMARA AND ALSO I'M
AVAILABLE FOR ANY TECHNICAL.
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE THIS
EVENING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
LANG WILL NOW MOVE ON TO MISS
CAMARA FOR ON THE LINE. YES I'M
HERE. YES MA'AM PLEASE PROCEED.
ONE OF FOUR THANK YOU COULD EVEN
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS MY
WIFE TO COME AROUND I AM AN
ACTIVE LIFE NOBODY STEINORTH AND
I'VE BEEN A REGISTERED NURSE IN
THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT AND WE
ENJOY HOSPITALS IF THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SECTOR- I SEND
MESSAGE POPPED UP THE FIVE
YEARS. I AM ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY FOUR TODAY I
WILL TELL YOU FIRST HAND BY THE
VERY NATURE OF NURSING WORK WITH
PHYSICALLY AND EMOTIONALLY
DEMANDING ANNA KOURNIKOVA
KNOCKING PANDEMIC HAS INCREASED. THE REST OF THE TEAM. EVEN
THAT THE THAT MAKES MIGHT AND I
THINK WE TOOK GRAY WHEN I. OFTEN
GREATER WORKLOADS BECAUSE THE
INSUFFICIENT STAFFING. LET ME
CREATE THE YEAR WHAT WHAT WHAT
WHICH UP OUR A LONG BECOMING
BIGGER SOMEBODY. BASED ON MY
EXPERIENCE I CAN ATTEST TO THE
FACT THAT WORKING ON A SPECIAL
OF IT'S EIGHT AFTER BIRTH WE
FOR. WE ARE FEELING AND ADOPT
BOTH PHYSICALLY ANYMORE. WE IN
TURN CAN TO OF OVER OR IF
THERE'S A AND THAT'S HEALTH ARE
. WITHIN PAST TWO WEEKS. MICHAEL
WORKERS HAD HI FOLKS EPISODES
THIS MEANS THAT YOUR BLUSH DRY
TOO LOW. ABLE THE TWO THAT YOU
ARE WAS BUSY SHORT STAFFED WHICH
OFTEN MAKES WHICH OFTEN MEANS NO
BREAK WHIMS NURSE ALL THE TIME
OUR HOSPITAL WHAT WILL BE
PROVIDED THIRTY MINUTES BREAK
AND A FIFTEEN MINUTES BREAK
WITHIN AN EAGLE TWELVE HOUR
SHIFTS. MARKETS ALMOST NEVER GET
OUT OF THE LAST FIFTEEN MINUTES
BREAK YOU GOT PRACTICAL RELY ON
THE FACT THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO
COMPENSATE US. OUTCOMPETED. A
NURSE IF IT NEEDS TO. WHAT MORE
AFTER A NO SO BY SHE WITHOUT A
NEW BECAUSE I GREAT. OFF HAVE
TO. AN EXTRA ARE THE CLIENT ONE
TO APPROVE THAT GREAT IN ORDER
FOR THEM TO GET COME-
COMPENSATED. ACCORDING TO THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE BLOCK. SAFETY
AND HEALTH. SIX WORK AND LONG
HOURS AT THE GROCERY OF WE-
DISTURBANCES IN THIRTY WHAT A
MONTH WILL PROBABLY TO THIS
AGAIN. CHRONIC HEALTH PROBLEMS
SUCH AS CARDIO. DISEASE AND
MOVED IT SERVICES SECTOR BANDAI
AND DEPARTMENT. IN MANY WORK
THANK YOU THAT PHONE A LOT
FISHING AND COVER RETIREMENT TO
RETURN NOT ONLY FIFTY EIGHT AND
INJURING BUT OFFER MORAL INJURY.
MORE MORE ISRAEL ONE MORE NURSES
HAVE BEEN LINKED TO CARRY. OUR
PATIENTS AND HAVING YOU RIGHT
BACK TO CARE FOR THEM. THE
COMMISSION CONTRIBUTE TO HIGHER
RATES OF INTENT TO LEAD THE JOBS
AND JOB. WORK WHICH ARE PROBLEMS
THAT HAVE WORKING DO NOT. CALL
THE NINETEENTH SYMBOLIC. AFTER
FORTY YOU NEED ANOTHER THAT
HEALTHCARE FACILITY DESERVE
THREE MEAL EMBRACE. FOR ABILITY
THAT PRICE SECTOR WHEAT IN JOY.
BETTER RANKED NURSES WILL GO BY
HI. QUALITY FOR FROM. CALIFORNIA
WHAT DO YOU THEN I'M WHAT WE ARE
DOING. AND I TOLD FOR AT THIRTY
THIRTY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR.
A CENTER BORRERO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT
. SENILE THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE ARE
VERSUS MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE FROM THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTEEN THIRTY FOUR WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN
THIRTY FOUR MY FIRST ONE. AND
THEN ZERO. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
NINE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
EVENING CARE AND MEMBERS-
JENNIFER CONNELLY THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
NINE TO SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
AGAIN- JERRY MEMBERS THE FACT
MAYOR WHICH ACTUALLY CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY FOUR THANK YOU.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE- LEFT MY
NUMBER.
IF THEY DROPPED OUT OF THE
QUEUE. WE HAVE NO MORE COMMENTS
IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
FOUR THANK YOU ADAM- MODERATE IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE CHECK THE LINES
ONE MORE TIME TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE HEARD FROM ALL OF OUR
SUPPORT WITNESSES. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF. THE THIRTEEN
THIRTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY FOUR THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR HAVING HEARD
FROM ALL OUR SUPPORTERS WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE
FROM ANY OPPOSITION. WILL MOVE
ON TO WE DON'T HAVE ANY LEAD
OPPOSITION SO WE WILL MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED. SEEN NONE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
OR VERSUS MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE FROM THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
SB THIRTEEN THIRTY FOUR WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. BUT AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SB THIRTEEN
THIRTY FOUR. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO. I HAVE NO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
FOUR. THANK YOU IN THAT MATTER
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
CHECK THE LINES ONE MORE TIME TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE- HEARD
FROM ALL. OPPOSITION TO
WITNESSES. IN A TELECONFERENCE
LINES. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THIRTEEN THIRTY FOUR YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN THERE ARE. WE HAVE NO COMMENT AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU BYE MADAME
MODERATOR. AND THANK YOU TO ALL
OUR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WILL NOT BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR- THE
MEMBERS TO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SENATOR PHIL. OKAY I JUST HAVE
ONE LAST ONE QUESTION. M. AND
THAT IS WITH REGARDS TO- THE
FOLLOWING QUESTION WHICH- STATE-
RIGHT NOW. WHICH EMPLOYEES ARE
INCLUDED IN DIRECT PATIENT CARE-
THIS BILL IS NOT CLEAR ON WHO
THIS DEFINITION WOULD INCLUDE-
IF YOU MIND CLARIFYING THAT
REALLY QUICK FOR THE RECORD
SPEAKS TO A FIRST ARE NURSES OR
NURSES ASSISTANTS THOSE FOLKS
WHO HAVE DIRECT ENGAGEMENT AND
PROVIDING PATIENT CARE TO OUR-
PATIENTS ARE IN A MEDICAL
SETTING SO AS ARE PRIMARILY ARE
NURSES. OKAY AND THEN LAST
QUESTION- THERE HAS BEEN A
QUESTION THAT HAS ARISEN WITH
REGARDS TO WHETHER OR NOT THIS
IS AN ITEM THAT SHOULD BE
ADDRESSED WITHIN THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING UNITS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO. MAKE A COMMENT ON THAT- NO I
THINK WE'RE TRYING TO BRING THIS
IN LINE. AGAIN TO. THE REST OF
THE WORKERS WHO. OUR CONSIDER ME
GIVEN THE SAME LEVEL OF
CONSIDERATION FOR REST BREAKS AS
WE SAID NURSES IN PRIVATE SECTOR
ARE FORTY- THESE BREAKS AND THEY
DO THE EXACT SAME WORKS SO I
DON'T SEE IT AS A COMPLETE CUT
OF COLLECTIVE BARGAINING ISSUE
BUT- I'LL LET MY- WITNESSES MY
EXPERT ITNESSES AT AND IF THEY
HAVE SOMETHING THAT THEIR- SURE
ABSOLUTELY- MADAM CHAIR. I'D
ALSO ADD THAT. BUT THE
BARGAINING IS CONSIDERED IN THIS
BILL IT ACTUALLY EXEMPT. FROM
THESE PROVISIONS EMPLOYEES ARE
COVERED BY COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT IF THAT'S HELPFUL.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT M. AS A WE
HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL
BY SENATOR RAZA. OKAY LET'S SEE
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
DRAW SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
. SB THIRTY THIRTY FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST
AMENDMENT AND FOR TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CORTES C. OR CHOI BO. NO FOR
TROUBLED NO THE RUSSELL. HI THE
REST OF I LAYERED NEWMAN AYE
NEWMAN I MOVEMENT THAT. I WILL
PUT THAT FELL ON THE CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU OF
CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU. I KNOW
THAT THERE. IS A- NEXT WE HAVE
SENATOR LEYVA PRESENTING SB.
THIRTEEN FORTY THREE. READY
PLEASE PROCEED GET ALL RIGHT
GOOD EVENING EVERYONE ALL RIGHT
GOOD AFTERNOON MATT OR EVENING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS SB
THIRTEEN FORTY THREE SIX TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY TEACHER HAS A
RETIREMENT SECURITY AFFORDED TO
THEM BY OUR STATE PENSION
SYSTEM. SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
REQUIRES ALL CHARTER SCHOOLS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM
CAL STIRS AND IN THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT
SYSTEM CALPERS ACCORDING TO CAL
STIRS BETWEEN 2240% OF NEWLY
CREATED CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
OPTING FOR AN ALTERNATIVE
RETIREMENT SYSTEM. BY NOT
ALLOWING TEACHERS TO ACCESS A
DEFINED BENEFIT SYSTEM TEACHERS
ARE LEFT WITH RETIREMENT OPTIONS
THAT ARE HEAVILY DEPENDENT ON
MARKET FLUCTUATIONS CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE FUNDED WITH PUBLIC
DOLLARS AND SHOULD ENSURE THAT
THEIR EMPLOYEES ARE FOR THE SAME
RETIREMENT OPPORTUNITIES AS ALL
OTHER PUBLIC EMPLOYEES. EVERY
TEACHER SHOULD HAVE THE SAME
OPTIONS NO MATTER WHICH PUBLIC
SCHOOL THEY DECIDE TO TEACH AT
TEACHERS ALREADY DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO SOCIAL SECURITY
BENEFITS THEY SHOULD NOT BE
ADDITIONALLY FINANCIALLY
HAMPERED BY NOT HAVING ACCESS TO
CAL STIRS ARE CALPERS. EACH
TEACHER TEACHER SHOULD HAVE A
CHOICE. SB THIRTEEN FORTY THREE
ALSO PUT SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE FOR
RETIREMENT PAYMENTS WHEN A
CHARTER SCHOOL FALLS BEHIND-
SHUTS ITS DOORS COMPLETELY. WHEN
THIS OCCURS THE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND WHICH TO CHARTER
SCHOOLS LOCATED HAS BEEN
REQUIRED TO PAY THE BILL THIS
CAN LEAVE THE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION WITH TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS IN UNEXPECTED. AND
UNWARRANTED RETIREMENT PAYMENT
OBLIGATIONS SB THIRTEEN FORTY
THREE CORRECTS THIS BY REQUIRING
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION TO
WITHHOLD A REASONABLE PORTION.
OF THE CHARTER SCHOOLS FUNDING
DISBURSEMENT AND PAY THE
RETIREMENT RETIREMENT
OBLIGATIONS TO EACH SYSTEM
AUTOMATICALLY. SB FOUR THIRTEEN
FORTY THREE IS ABOUT PROVIDING
ALL PUBLIC EMPLOYEES WITH THE
RETIREMENT SECURITY THEY DESERVE
AND ARE FORWARDED. TEACHERS
PROVIDE GUIDANCE SUPPORT AND AN
EDUCATION TO OUR MOST VULNERABLE
OUR CHILDREN. THE LEAST WE CAN
DO IS GIVE THEM ACCESS TO A
SECURE RETIREMENT SYSTEM. MY
OFFICE HAS BEEN WORKING WITH CAL
STIRS A CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS TO
DO THE FOLLOWING. OFTEN ONLY
HAPPENS WHEN A NEW CHARTER
SCHOOLS CREATED NOT A REAL
AUTHORIZATION. THIS WILL MEAN AN
EXISTING CHARTER THAT HASN'T
BEEN PARTICIPATING ANSWERS OUR
PURSE IS REAUTHORIZED NOTHING
CHANGES FOR THEM THEY WILL BE
LEFT OUT OF THIS BILL. WITH ME
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IS
TRISTEN BROWN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR LEVEL NOW MOVED OUR LEAD
SUPPORT WAIT DISTRICTS AND BROWN
ARE YOU ON THE LINE. HE'S ON
RIGHT HERE IN PERSON SORRY. IT
IS AMAZING TO BE HERE IN PERSON
OUT OF HERE IN MEMBERS AND THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME IT'S GREAT TO
BE BACK- TROSZYN BROWN CFT IN A
UNION OF EDUCATORS IN CLASS I
PROFESSIONALS WE ARE THE SPONSOR
OF THIS BILL- YOU KNOW IN SOME
WAYS I THINK IT'S- PULLING UP A
HOLE IN THE BOAT- STIRS HAS
RELEASED REPORTS. ON HOW YOU
KNOW WE'RE LOOKING AT A-
TIMELINE IN THIRTY YEAR
INCREMENTS ON HOW TO- HAVE FOLKS
PAY AND THEN GET THEIR DEFINED
BENEFITS- WE START TO SEE A
LITTLE BIT OF A SHORTFALL AS
MORE AND MORE SCHOOLS. MY CODE
THE CHARTER ROUTE WITHOUT EATING
AND STIRS AND PURRS AND SO THIS
IS GOING TO PATCH THAT HOLE- AND
HAVE THAT EVERY NEW CHARTER
DON'T KNOW EXISTING WILL BE
BROUGHT IN AS AS WHAT THE
SENATOR SAID IN ORDER AMEND
OTHER ARE PENDING AMENDMENTS.
BUT THAT ALL NEW CHARTERS WILL
THEN JOIN THE PUBLIC PENSION
SYSTEMS AS ALL OTHER- PUBLIC
EDUCATION ENTITIES ARE A WE
BELIEVE THAT A PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER WHO TEACHES AT A PUBLIC
SCHOOL- SHOULD HAVE THE THEIR
RIGHT TO THEIR PUBLIC
RETIREMENT. THEY DO NOT HOUSE OF
SECURITY BENEFITS- IN THE STATE-
AND THEN ON THE CLASSIFIED SIDE-
IT'S THE SAME IF THOSE MEMBERS
ARE CONTRACTED OUT WHICH STILL
IS POSSIBLE FOR CHARTERS TO DO-
THEN THEY TOO WOULD HAVE ACCESS
TO THEIR CALPERS BENEFIT AND
HAVE SOME RETIREMENT SECURITY-
BY THE TIME THE FINISH THEIR
CAREER. WE WANT TO DO NO HARM
EITHER TO INDIVIDUALS OR THE
SYSTEM WHICH IS WHY WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BRING IN EXISTING
CHARTERS AND IF THEY'RE NOT
PARTICIPATING HE GETS TO BE A
BIT OF A LOGISTICAL NIGHTMARE
HAVING FOLKS COME IN. BUT ALSO
YOU KNOW IF FOLKS WERE TO MOVE
FROM WITHIN AND WITHOUT OF THE
SYSTEM- IF YOU'RE A PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHER THAT IS TAUGHT AT
A TRADITIONAL SCHOOL FOR SAY
FIFTEEN YEARS. AND THEN YOU
WANTED TO TAKE A JOB AT A
CHARTER SCHOOL THAT'S NOT
PARTICIPATING YOU MIGHT NOT BE
AWARE THAT AS A PUBLIC TEACHER
IN A PUBLIC SCHOOL YOU'RE NO
LONGER ATTAINING PUBLIC
RETIREMENT CREDIT. AND SO WE
WANT TO AT LEAST START. TO LIVE
AS I SAY STOP THE LEAK AND FROM
HERE ON OUT MAKE SURE THAT ALL
PUBLIC EDUCATORS ARE IN THE
PUBLIC RETIREMENT SYSTEM AND
HAVE MORE OF ASECURE RETIREMENT
WHEN THEIR. TIME IS UP SO WITH
THAT WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. AND
ALL. HERE FOR QUESTIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
BROWN WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OUR
SECOND LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS
MISTER ERIC WE MET. I'M HERE IN
OPPOSITION- IN OPPOSITION. SORRY. OKAY. BAKER OKAY WE WILL NOW
MOVE INTO ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM. TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. FEDERER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. C. NINE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS IS MODERATE
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE FROM THE
INDIVIDUALS WOULD HAVE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN FORTY THREE WILL BEGIN
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. C. IN
FORTY THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY
THREE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. NINE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO AGAIN CARE MEMBERS-
JENNIFER MALLEY LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
NINE TO SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. OOD
EVENING- MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS STUFF BROWN BUT CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE'RE IN
SUPPORT. NINE TO SIXTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING AGAIN CHRISTOS
MAYOR WITH ACTUALLY CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. THIRTEEN
FORTY THREE. THIRD NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN THE QUEUE IN SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY THREE.
THANK YOU MODERATOR- WE WILL
KNOW MOVED OPPOSITION- LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS PLEASE COME
UP AND IDENTIFY YOURSELF THANK
YOU THE- GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- ERIC PRIMACK
THE CHARTER SCHOOLS DEVELOPMENT
CENTER WE'RE HERE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. REPRESENTING
SEVERAL HUNDRED OF OUR MEMBER
SCHOOLS. OUR CONCERN ABOUT THE
BILL FOR SEVERAL REASONS FIRST
OFF IT IMPOSES FACTORING LEE
HIGH COSTS AS ALL OF YOU KNOW-
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT A PUBLIC
PENSION SYSTEMS. AND AS MANY OF
YOU KNOW PARTICULAR MEMBER OR
CHOI BOGUE SERVES ON BUDGET SUB
ONE CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE NOT
FUNDED COMPARABLY TO TRADITIONAL
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND NEW SCHOOLS
IN PARTICULAR HAVE AVERY
DIFFICULT TIME. OF MEETING THEIR
EXPENSES SECOND IT WOULD WREAK
HAVOC WITH NEW CHARTER SCHOOLS
PARTICULARLY EVEN AS THE BILL IS
AMENDED IF I UNDERSTAND
AMENDMENTS CORRECTLY THEY'RE NOT
IN PRINT BUT- AS I UNDERSTAND IT
WOULDN'T POSE THIS REQUIREMENT A
NEW CHARTER SCHOOLS AND IF A-
PRE EXISTING NONPROFIT COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION THAT HAS
EXISTING RETIREMENT SYSTEMS
WANTS TO START A CHARTER SCHOOL.
THIS WOULD MAKE THINGSVERY
COMPLICATED BY EFFECTIVELY
MANDATING TWO DIFFERENT PENSION
SYSTEMS AND SCHEMES WHICH NOT
ALLOWED UNDER FEDERAL TAX LAW
AND PENSION OFF. THIRD IT
MANDATES THAT COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS- TAP WITH UP TO
THREE MONTHS OF CHARTER SCHOOLS
RETIREMENT CONTRIBUTIONS IN
ADVANCE CREATING SIGNIFICANT
CASH FLOW PROBLEMS AND AGAIN NEW
SCHOOLS IN PARTICULAR. ARE
USUALLY VERY LEAN ON CASH
PARTICULARLY GIVEN HOW LATE THE
STATE PROVIDES MONEY TO SCHOOLS.
UNDER THE STATE'S FUNDING
SYSTEM- FINALLY IT GRANTS.
STURGEON PERS UNFETTERED
AUTHORITY TO ESTABLISH- JUST
ABOUT ANY RULE OR REGULATION IF
THEY WANT- AND WE THINK THAT'S
AN INAPPROPRIATE DELEGATION OF
WHAT SHOULD BE LEGISLATIVE
AUTHORITY- THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
TECHNICAL CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE
WITH THE BILL WE UNDERSTAND THAT
FOLKS ARE WORKING ON THOSE BUT-
GIVEN OUR LARGER CONCERNS WE
HOPE THAT YOU WILL VOTE IN
OPPOSITION OR LAY OFF THE BILL.
I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE THANK
YOU OKAY THANK YOU IF THERE ARE
ANY WILL REFER THEM BACK TO YOU-
IS THERE A SECOND LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS I'M SHOWING
PARENTS STUDER IS THAT CORRECT.
ON THE COASTLINE. YES I'M HERE
OKAY SO YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK
YOU GOOD EVENING MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JACK HERER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
CHIMED LOS ANGELES I'M HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION ON CHANDRA SPOKE IN
OPPOSITION TO. FORTY THREE
HUNDRED SCHOOLS ESTABLISH HE
DOESN'T WANNA WHICH SERVES SEVEN
HUNDRED AND THIRTY STUDENTS WITH
A FOCUS ON BEING A NATIONAL
DEMONSTRATE. RECALL INCLUSION OF
ALL LEARNERS AND THE GENERAL
EDUCATION CLASSROOM AND ACTING
AS THE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
SCHOOL THE COLLEGE OF EDUCATION
AT CAL STATE NORTHRIDGE. FORTY
EIGHT TEACHERS AND A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FOUR EMPLOYEES WHEN I WAS
ESTABLISHED FIRST IN PERSON THAT
HAVE WELL ARTICULATED SYSTEM BY
WHICH TO ACCEPT THE COUNTRY THE
FIVE OH ONE THREE THREE.
OPERATING ARE KURDISH SCHOOL.
FOR CHILD ESTABLISH THIS PHONE
TO FIND BETTER BENEFIT FOR
DENTAL BY INSISTING A MATCHING.
EMPLOYER AND EMPLOYEE
CONTRIBUTIONS. FIRED BY LAW ALL
OF OUR EMPLOYEES ARE EMPLOYED OF
THEIR IN THE RETURN PROGRAM THAT
WE OFFER. WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORS STATED CATHLAMET AND THE
BILL AND LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
THE VISION. HOWEVER CONCERNS
STILL REMAIN AS CURRENTLY
DRAFTED S. B. FORTY THREE CAN
JEOPARDIZE THE TECH. MANY OF OUR
EMPLOYEES AND IMPOSED MANDATED
COSTS AND GREATLY DIMINISHED
HIGH QUALITY SERVICES- AT THE
CORE OF CHALLENGE. A SCHOOL TIME
COULD NOT EXIST IF WE COULD NOT
HAVE THAT LOCAL CHOICES ABOUT
OUR INVESTMENT IN STUDENT
SERVICES AND SUPPORT AND A
COMPETITIVE WELL THE TIRE
POPPING TRIMBOLI. THE LITTLE
DATING THIS OPTION WILL IN THE
INTENDED INNOVATION OF NEW
CHARTER SCHOOLS FURTHER
MANDATING SIR- SPRING TO CHARTER
SCHOOLS THE GREATLY COMPLICATE
THE OPERATIONS AND LEGAL STRUCK.
A SUCCESSFUL SCHOOLS LIKE TRUCK
IF WE WERE TO REPLICATE THE
PROGRAM WITH. NEW SCHOOLS WITHIN
OUR ORGANIZATION. THE LAST
THIRTY YEARS CHARTER. HAVE BEEN
. WITH THE OPTION TO PARTICIPATE
IN STIRS AND PURRS AND WHILE THE
VAST MAJORITY FLETCHER. CHOOSE
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE STATE
PLANS SOME OFFER ALTERNATIVE
PLANS FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS.
WE SEE NO COMPELLING REASON TO
TERMINATE OPTIONS LIKE THE
PROGRAM THAT OUR EMPLOYEES
ATHLETES PARTICIPATED FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS. THESE REASONS WE
MUST OPPOSE SB THIRTEEN FORTY
THREE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THE VISION I'M
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- WE'RE
GONNA MOVE NOW BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE REMASTERS ANYONE HERE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION THE BILL
SO PLEASE STEP FORWARD. ALL
RIGHT SEEN AND WE'RE GONNA GO TO
THE MODERATOR S. MODERATOR TO
QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION-
POSITIONS- AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MR CARE
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THIRTEEN FORTY THREE YU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTEEN FORTY THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. REPUBLICAN OPPOSITION
SB THIRTEEN FORTY THREE SORRY
THANK YOU MODERATOR WILL- COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. ON THIS
BILL. SB THIRTEEN FORTY THREE
ANYTHING. THAT WE HAVE TO MOVE
THE BILL ALL RIGHT AFTER THE
OFFICE CLOTHES WE- FIRM CENTER
NEWMAN OFFERING MOVE THE BILL IN
CENTER LEYVA- YOU'RE WELCOME TO
CLOSE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER NEWMAN THANK
YOU MET MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THE
BIGGEST PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN POVERTY ARE WOMEN OVER
SIXTY FIVE BECAUSE THEY DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO A PENSION MORE
SPECIFICALLY A DEFINED BENEFIT
PENSION. MOST OF OUR TEACHERS
THE VAST MAJORITY OF OUR
TEACHERS ARE WOMEN- WHAT I HEAR
FROM THE OPPOSITION IS THAT THEY
CAN'T AFFORD THIS TO ME IT'S
LIKE SAYING WE'RE GOING TO OPEN
A BUSINESS BUT WE CAN'T REALLY
AFFORD TO OPEN THE BUSINESS IF
WE HAVE TO PAY PEOPLE. A MINIMUM
WAGE OR IMPAIR EVERYBODY FIVE
DOLLARS AN HOUR SO THAT WAY WE
CAN KEEP OUR BUSINESS GOING IF
YOU'RE GOING TO OPEN A CHARTER
SCHOOL YOU SHOULD MAKE SURE
YOU'RE TAKING CARE OF THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE WORKING THE HARDEST FOR
YOU AND THOSE ARE T. SHIRTS
TEACHERS. AND A DEFINED BENEFIT
PENSION I GOT TO NEGOTIATE THOSE
FOR TWELVE YEARS AND IT WAS A
REAL PRIVILEGE BECAUSE SOMETIMES
PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE WHEN
THEY'RE YOUNG AND WORKING AND
GETTING A PAYCHECK AS I TELL
YOUNG PEOPLE TIME YOU'RE GOING
TO GET OLD ONE DAY AND YOU'RE
STILL GOING TO WANT TO EAT. AND
A FOUR ONE K. DOES NOT DO THE
SAME THING FOR PEOPLE AND I'M
GUESSING THAT'S WHAT THE
ALTERNATE RETIREMENT SYSTEM IS I
ACTUALLY DON'T KNOW. IS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN SOMETHING WHERE
YOU MONTHLY GET A SPECIFIC
AMOUNT OF MONEY THIS BILL WILL
MAKE SURE THAT OUR TEACHERS IN
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE TAKING CARE
OF SO THAT WHEN THEY RETIRE THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SIR- WE DO HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATE-ROOM SO WE WILL S.
CONSULTANT CALL THE ROLL CALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION COURTESY HI COURTESY I
OR CHOI BOGUE NO A TROUBLED KNOW
WRESTLE. THE REST OF I LAYERED
NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE. ALL RIGHTS TO
THEIR THREE VOTES- IN SUPPORT
ONE IN OPPOSITION AND WILL KEEP
THE BILL ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU CENTER THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS. SINTERED RUSSELL. ARE
VERY OWN WILL BE PRESENTING ON
SB TWELVE SIXTY FIFTH. AND
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SENATOR.THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MANY
MANY MEN AND WOMEN WHO DO
ESSENTIAL WORK FOR OUR ECONOMY
HAVE NOW BECOME MORE VISIBLE
FULL LAST YEAR SB SIXTY TWO MADE
CLEAR THAT A BUSINESS
CONTRACTING TO HAVE GARMENTS
MADE IS LIABLE FOR UNPAID
MINIMUM WAGE AND OVERTIME PAY TO
THE WORKERS. WHO MAKE THOSE
GARMENTS REGARDLESS OF HOW MANY
LAYERS OF CONTRACTING THAT
COMPANY MAY USE END OF SESSION
AMENDMENTS RESULTED. IN A LONG
STANDING PROVISION OF LABOR LAW
IN THE VERDANT LEE STRIPPED FROM
THE LABOR CODE SB TWELVE SIXTY
CORRECT THIS DRAFTING ERROR BY
INSERTING THOSE PROVISIONS BACK
INTO THE LAW THE WAY IT HAS BEEN
FOR TWENTY YEARS. BUT TODAY WE
HAVE ONE EXPERTS WITH ON THE
WITNESS LINE MATTHEW D. COROLLA.
FEDERALES FROM BEDS. TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT. REYES TERM MISTER
DID DO CARLESS YOU MAY PROCEED
IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE THANK YOU. YES GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR HONORABLE MEMBERS BY
MATTHEW THE CARLESS OF STAFF
ATTORNEY AT THAT TOPIC LEGAL
SERVICES IN LOS ANGELES. WE WERE
ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS OF SB
SIXTY TWO WE HAVE REPRESENTATIVE
GOVERNMENT WORKERS FOR MORE THAN
TWENTY YEARS IN THEIR WAGE
CLAIMS IN CALIFORNIA. BUT
SENATOR ALSO NOTED SB TWELVE
SIXTY- CORRECT. SEVERAL DRAFTING
ERRORS THAT OCCURRED AT THE LAST
MINUTE SESSION LAST FALL. HI
MERRY CORRECTION IS TO RESTORE-
WHAT HAS BEEN LINE CALIFORNIA
FOR TWENTY YEARS AND WHICH WAS
AND ALL THE PREVIOUS VERSIONS OF
SB SIXTY TWO AND ITS
PREDECESSOR. A REGARDING-
GARMENT WORKERS RIGHT TO CLAIM
LIQUIDATED DAMAGES WHEN THEY ARE
PAID LESS THAN MINIMUM WAGE OR
OVERTIME THIS RESTORES BACKED-
IN BURTON DRAFTING ERROR THAT
OCCURRED IT ALSO MAKES IF YOU-
CORRECTION THE WITH REFERENCES
TO DIFFERENT SECTIONS- OF THE
LONG PARTICULARLY LABOR CODE.
SECTION TWENTY SIX SEVENTY THREE
POINT ONE AND FOR THESE REASONS. WE ASK FOR YOUR I. PHONE. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU FOR TESTING-
WE'RE GOING TO ASK IF THERE'S
ANY SUPPORT WITH THIS IS IN THE
ROOM IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM SCENE
YES PLEASE COMPORT. SEND OVER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
WAS TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. SEEN NONE A
MODERATOR FEUD PLEASE QUEUE UP
SUPPORT WITNESSES AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
SIXTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWELVE SIXTY YOU MAY PRESS
ONE. AND. ZERO THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
SIXTY AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU- WE DO NOT HAVE A LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS SO I WILL ASK
LOSING WHEN HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION. IF SO PLEASE
COME FORWARD SEEN NONE MODERATOR
PLAN COME BACK TO YOU AND ASK
YOU TO PLEASE. YOU OF ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TWELVE SIXTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH YOU CAN
OPPOSITION SB TWELVE SIXTY YOU
MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO. WE
HAVE NO COMMENT IN A POSITION OF
SB TWELVE SIXTY AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MODERATOR
WILL COME BACK THE COMMITTEE-
ANY COMMENTS QUESTIONS WHEN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. GLAD
MOVE THIS BILL AS WELL ALL RIGHT
SIR NEWMAN WOULD LIKE TO MOVE
THE BILL SENATE ROSE WHICH WOULD
CLOSE. ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU ALRIGHT WE HAVE A
MOTION SENATOR NEWMAN A MUST
CONSULT THE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. COURTESY HI. COURTESY
I OR CHOI BOGUE. A TROUBLED NO
THE REST SO. I WRESTLE I'D
LAYERED. NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE. WE
HAVE THREE AYE VOTES ONE
OPPOSITION THREE TO ONE WITH- AN
ABSENT MEMBERS SO WE'LL PUT THAT
ON CALL- SENATOR. AFTER ALSO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO PROCEED WITH THIS.
THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR- YOU MAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HAS A PLACE- HAS IN
PLACE A POLICY. EQUAL PAY FOR
EQUAL WORK. AND THAT POLICY
REQUIRES VENDOR COMPANIES THAT
HAVE ONE OF AN ESTIMATED FOUR
HUNDRED SERVICE CONTRACTS WITH
YOU SEE. TO PAY THEIR COMPANY'S
EMPLOYEES. WAGES AND BENEFITS
EQUAL. TO WHAT YOU SEE. PAYS ITS
OWN SERVICE WORKERS WHO WORK
DIRECTLY FOR YOU SEE. UC'S
RESPONSIBLE VENDOR COMPANY
VIOLATIONS OF THIS POLICY
HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED FOR S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR. AND THE PAY
INFORMATION REQUIRED UNDER THIS
BILL. QUOTE UNIVERSITY IS NOT
THE EMPLOYER OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND DOES NOT HAVE
THIS INFORMATION AND QUOTE.
THOUSANDS OF IMPACTED SERVICE
WORKERS WE DO NOT DO NOT WORK
FOR YOU SEE NOR ARE THEY COVERED
BY A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT. AND SINCE NO LAW
REQUIRES THE PRIVATE EMPLOYERS
TO TELL THESE WORKERS THAT
UNIVERSITY OR ANY STATE AGENCY
HOW WAGES AND BENEFITS BEING
PAID COMPARED TO WHAT THE UC.
EQUAL PAY FOR EQUAL WORK
REQUIRES THERE IS NO EFFECTIVE
OR LEGAL WAY FOR WORKERS TO
ENFORCE THE UC POLICY OR A PATH
WHERE WORKERS TO RECOVER THEIR
LOST WAGES. IT IS IMPORTANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THE BILL WILL NOT
NEGATIVELY IMPACT ANY STRIDES
YOU SEE IS MAKING TOWARDS ANY
THIRD PARTY VENDOR COMPLIANCE.
THE BILL MILL IT MERELY PROVIDES
AN OPPORTUNITY. FOR WORKERS TO
RESOLVE A SITUATION WHERE YOU
SEE WAS GIVEN MISINFORMATION BY
THE VENDOR WITH THE VENDOR MADE
AN HONEST MISTAKE OR WHERE THERE
WAS A CLEAR VIOLATION OF THE
UC'S. EQUAL PAY FOR EQUAL WORK
POLICY SB THIRTY SIXTY FOUR
CRATES OF FAIR ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM OF REQUIRING THE
VENDOR TO SUPPLY TO YOU SEE AND
ANY JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEE THE BASIC PAYROLL
INFORMATION NECESSARY. TO KNOW
IF A VENDOR IS ABIDING BY YOU
SEE POLICY THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE OF VENDOR TO SUPPLY A
WRITTEN NOTICE TO THEIR
EMPLOYEES ABOUT THE RELEVANT
COMPENSATION RATES AND WOULD
ALLOW A CONTRACTING VENDOR
COMPANY AN OPPORTUNITY TO CURE.
ANY DISCREPANCIES BEFORE FACING
ANY CONSEQUENCE HOWEVER REFUSAL
TO COMPLY WOULD RESULT IN
EMPLOYEES HAVE THE RIGHT TO
PURSUE RECOVERY OF LOST WAGES IN
COURT. AND THE DISQUALIFICATION
OF A VIOLATING COMPANY FROM
DOING BUSINESS WITH YOU SEE FOR
A FIVE YEAR PERIOD I HAVE ONE
PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL TO SPEAK TODAY.
CATHERINE LAI BARKER PRESIDENT
OF ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY TWO
NINETY NINE. OKAY THANK YOU
SENATOR MISLED BURGER- I
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE ON THE LINE
YOU PROCEED IF YOUR- THANK YOU
GOOD EVENING SENATORS CAPTION
LIVE ORDER PRESIDENT OF. THE
THIRTY TWO NINETY NINE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. SERVICE
WORKERS CLEANING TOILETS CUTTING
GRASS PICKING UP TRASH- AND
NEEDING HOSPITAL BEDS AND ARE
HELPING TO MAKE YOU SEE ONE OF
OUR GREATEST EDUCATION AND
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS RUN AND
SUCCEED. I'M HERE TO SPEAK FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE THE PROTECTIONS
IF THEY WERE TO SPEAK OUT OF
FEAR OF RETALIATION THESE ARE
OUR COLLEAGUES SERVICE WORKERS
WE WORK ALONGSIDE IT YOU SEE
BUT- WORK FOR THIRD PARTY
VENDORS AND COMPANIES DOING
BUSINESS WITH YOU SEE. YOU SEE
YOU HAVE A POLICY TITLED EQUAL
PAY FOR EQUAL WORK. IN FOR WORK
BEING PERFORMED AT UC BY OUTSIDE
VENDORS THOSE WORKERS THAT THE
SAME PAY AND BENEFITS FOR
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE HIRED DIRECTLY
BY YOU SHE RECEIVED. AN UC HAS
MADE STRIDES IN IMPLEMENTINGTHAT POLICY WE APPLAUD TAT
PROGRESS BUT UC ACKNOWLEDGES
THAT THEY ARE OFTEN LEFT TO RELY
ON VENDORS TO BE TRUTHFUL ABOUT
ACTUAL WAGES AND BENEFITS BEING%
EIGHT. THE BILL WILL INSURE IF
YOU ARE A THIRD PARTY VENDOR AND
ONCE. THAT WITH YOU SHE- YOU
MUST ADHERE TO THEIR POLICY. OF
EQUAL PAY FOR EQUAL WORK. IT
DOES SO BY MAKING THE
APPROPRIATE INDIVIDUALS AND HE'S
AWARE OF THE NECESSARY
INFORMATION THAT ALLOWS ANYONE
OUT OF THE PLANT HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CURE AND CORRECT.
WHICH THE BILL HELLO. IF THE
VENDOR REFUSES TO CURE AND
CORRECT THEM THEY CAN BE
SANCTIONED BY USUALLY OR BROAD
SUPPORT FOR THE WORKERS WHO WERE
UNDER STATE. WE ASK FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. OKAY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WHICH SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL- SEEN NONE MODERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL ON ANYONE
CUED UP WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF. SB. THIRTY SIXTY
FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. BUT AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN GENERAL'S.
THANK YOU SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR AND SENATORS STUFF BROWN
BOTH CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE IN SUPPORT. ONE TWO SIXTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO AGAIN CHRISTOPHE
BERRA WITH APPS THE CALIFORNIA
CALLING STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU.
ONE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
CHAIR MEMBERS JENNIFER RALLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND THE COURT. AND
ONE MOMENT FOR. I LAST TIME LIKE
TO SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DO YOU REMEMBER
ALEX BROKE. DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDER. WHAT THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR THANK
YOU MODERATOR AND THERE IS NO
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS ON S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY FOURS OR ANYONE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SEEN NONE
BACK TO YOU MODERATOR- IT ASK
YOU TO PLEASE A COUPON FOR ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN
SIXTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN SIXTY
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AT THE
END ZERO. WE HAVE NO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION THE THIRTEEN FIFTY
FOUR. THANK YOU MODERATOR BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE- COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- SEEN NONE- YOU MAY
CLOSE SENATOR ALSO AND THEN- WE
WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU IN A
MOTION ABOUT IT WILL. OKAY
SKINNER NEW MOVES A BILL WILL
CALL THE ROLL CALL NOW. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY PROTESTING HI COURTESY
I- CHOI BOGUE NO THE TROUBLE
KANNO DRESSEL HI THE RUSSELL I
LAYERED. NEWMAN ALL RIGHT NEWMAN
AYE. ALL RIGHT SO WE ARE AT-
THREE ICE- ONE IN OPPOSITION IN
ONE ABSENCE WILL KEEP THIS- ON
CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS
IN A MINUTE ASK OF BY SURE OCHO
BOOK- TO TAKE TO GO ONE MORE
TIME- SO THAT I CAN HAVE MY BILL
SB EIGHT SEVENTY FOUR THAT MEETS
WITH THE CHAIRS APPROVAL.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WITHOUT MOVED TO AS
SENATOR.
EARTH THANK YOU CENTERS IN THE-
THANK YOU CHAIR A POLICE PRESENT
SEVEN BILLION SEVENTY FOUR SPOTS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION COS TA
WITH SUPPORT FROM THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION. OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS A C. ARE YOU CALIFORNIA
SB. EIGHT SEVENTY FIVE EIGHT
SEVEN FOUR WILL PROVIDE
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES OF MERIT K.
TWELVE IN CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS THE SAME
CLARITY THIS PROVIDE CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES IN NON MAYOR DISTRICTS
REGARDING THE RIGHT TO RETURN TO
THEIR PRIOR CLASSIFICATION OF
THEIR PROMOTED AND FAIL TO
COMPLETE PROBATION FOR THE NEW
POSITION. THE ABSENCE OF
PROMOTIONAL PROBATION PROCEDURES
IN THE EDUCATION CODE ALLOWS FOR
THE POTENTIAL TERMINATION OF
PERMANENT EMPLOYEES AMERICA
DISTRICTS WITHOUT CAUSE AS A
RESULT WITHOUT THE CLARITY
PROVIDED IN THE NON MERIT
STATUTES QUALIFIED EMPLOYEES
MERIT DISTRICTS MAY NOT SEEK
PROMOTIONS OUT OF FEAR. OF
LOSING THEIR JOB. S. SEVENTY
FOUR REMEDY THIS BY CLARIFYING
THAT THE PROMOTIONAL
PROBATIONARY PERIOD FOR PLEASE
EMERITUS WILL NOT COSTS AND
THEIR LIVELIHOODS. THIS
ENCOURAGING THEM TO SEEK
PROMOTIONS. THIS IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE SCHOOLS ARE FACING
SEVERE STAFFING SHORTAGES AS WE
KNOW AND QUALIFIED EMPLOYEES
SHOULD BE ENCOURAGED TO PROMOT
AN OPEN ENTRY LEVEL POSITIONS
WITH US TODAY. IS SANDRA BOROUGH
REPRESENTED THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU GOOD EVENING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CENTER GROVE
ON BEHALF OF CSEA WE CONSIDER
THIS A CLEAN UP BILL FOR TWO
REASONS THE FIRST REASON IS THAT
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES ARE ALREADY
CONSIDERED PERMANENT AFTER THEY
COMPLETE AN INITIAL PROBATIONARY
PERIOD SO IF THEY ARE PROMOTED
THEY COULD NOT BE RELEASED
WITHOUT DISCIPLINARY JUST COSTS
SECOND ALTHOUGH THE RIGHTS OF
PERMANENT CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
ARE CLEAR ACROSS ALL EDUCATION
CODE STATUTES THERE IS A LOT OF
INCONSISTENCY INCONSISTENCY
AMONG THE MERIT STATUTES
REGARDING PROMOTION PROBATION
AND EMOTION. SO I'LL SPARE YOU
READING SOME OF THOSE EXAMPLES-
AND UNSETTLE JUST SAY THAT SB
SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR CORRECT THE
PROBLEM BY SIMPLY INSERTING
LANGUAGE FROM THE NON MERIT K.
TWELVE AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SECTIONS INTO THE MERIT SYSTEM
SECTIONS IT SIMPLY STATES THAT
HAVE A CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE IS
PROMOTED AND THEN FAILS
PROMOTION THEY DEMOTED BACK TO
THEIR PREVIOUS POSITION OR
CLASSIFICATION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR REITER WILL NOW
MOVE TO WITNESSES HERE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT SEVENTY
EIGHT. WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. EIGHT SB EIGHT SEVEN
EIGHT ZERO TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
SEEN NONE THANK YOU WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WITNESS
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE ARE
VERSUS- THAT A MODERATE IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE FROM THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT SEVENTY
FOUR WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU
MANAGER AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT SEVENTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT SEVENTY
FOUR. MADE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. ONE TWO SIXTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
STOP HERE WITH ME CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF SB. SEVENTY FOUR. ONE
MOMENT FOR NEXT NINE POINTS. ONE
TWO SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YOUR
LINE. YES MY NAME IS TERRY NOW
ONLINE IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
EIGHT FOUR I AM COMMISSIONER AND
I SIT ON THE SCPA BOARD OF
DIRECTORS. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
SEVENTY FOUR AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU MADAM MODERATOR HAVING HEARD
FROM ALL THE SUPPORTERS WILL NOT
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR
FROM ANY OPPOSITION WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION- ON
RECORD SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN. IN OPPOSITION
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED CENA
WILL NOW AND MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAY INTO TESTIFIED IN
A TELECONFERENCE SERVICES
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
FROM THE INDIVIDUALS WHEN TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB
EIGHT SEVENTY FOUR WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT
SEVENTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN I WISH. OF PETITIONS.
FIFTY EIGHT SEVENTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. LINE
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY APOLOGIES
MADAM CHAIR THAT THE CHANNEL
FROM ALLEY WITH A CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION A MEXICALI
SUPPORT AT LEAST FOR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
LINES IN OPPOSITION OF THE EIGHT
SEVENTY FOUR. WONDERFUL THANK
YOU TO ALL OUR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL NOT
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR
MEMBERS WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FIRE OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. JUST WANT TO COMMEND MS
BURROW UNDER STAMINA AND HER
PATIENTS GET THIS FOR- AND WENT
AFTER THE OFFICE CLOSED TO BE
HAPPENING THE BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- I HAVE REPORTED THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE. TO STICK SORRY
JUST A QUICK COMMENT- THIS BILL
REMINDS ME OF SOMETHING
NEGOTIATED THE CONTRACT TWENTY
YEARS AGO FOR HOTEL WORKERS
WHICH WAS. YOU HAVE BUILT AND
BUILT THE YOUR TALENTS YOUR
SKILLS YOUR COMMITMENT AND YOU
GET OFFERED A PROMOTION HOW
COULD YOU THEN. YOU KNOW LOSE
YOUR JOB JUST BECAUSE YOU TRIED
TO GO ALL OUT FOR AND- THAT
PROMOTION SO WE CLEAN THAT UP
AND THAT WAS A LONG TIME AGO-
IT'S ABOUT TIME TO. GET A FIX
HERE. THANK YOU SENATOR DRAWS
THEM CENTER CORTESE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU THANKS
FOR THE COMMENTS ON THANK YOU-
TO THE COMMITTEE IN A
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE A
MOTION ON SB EIGHT SEVENTY FOUR
BY SENATOR NEWMAN- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE MOTION IS DO YOU
PASS. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
SENATOR COURTESY HI COURTESY I
OR CHOI BOGUE BY A TRAVEL GUIDE
THE WRESTLE. WRESTLE I DARED
NEWMAN. NEWMAN AYE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR DIFFERENT- YES YES FOR
ALL THE FEDERAL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. AND TO CONFIRM A
LISTING LONGER. OKAY SO WE
UNDERSTAND CENTER WHERE IT IS SO
WON'T BE BACK SO WE CAN LIVE THE
CALL AT THIS TIME. OKAY THIS IS
THE FINAL VOTE FOR SB EIGHT
SEVENTY FOUR AND THAT IS FOUR TO
ONE SORRY FOUR ZERO FOUR ZERO
SORRY FOUR TO ZERO AND THE BILL
PASSES RESERVATION CENTER
CORTESE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR HELP
I SURE. A LOCAL MACINNES. NO NO
SHOULD HAVE LIFTING COSTS. YOU
SHOULD HAVE ME. YEAH COMMITTEE.
YES OF THE CALL FOR ME. THE
CHAIR JEFF YEAH I WAS OUT OF THE
ROOM FROM TWO. I BELIEVE I NEED
TO CAST OF. YES WE WERE SURE
THIS YEAR DOING NO I WAS YES THE
ITEM SIX SB THIRTEEN THIRTEEN.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY COURTESY ALL RIGHT
COURTESY OR CHORE OF MYSTERY
FLARED. NOT HERE. OKAY SO THE
BILL IS OUT. TWENTY THREE TO ONE
VOTE A SHELTER FOR. SB THIRTEEN
THIRTY FOUR TO PASS FIRST AMEND
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CORTES C. HI
COURTESY I LAYERED. IN THE BILLS
ARE ONE THREE ONE VOTE AS WELL.
SB THIRTEEN FORTY THREE LAYERED
. THAT'S AT THREE ONE THREE- S.
B. THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE IS OUT ON
THE THREE ONE BOTH. SO WORK
NUMBER. THIRTEEN FORTY THREE
THIRTEEN FORTY THREE I APOLOGIZE
GETTING LATE SB THIRTEEN FORTY
THREE IS OUT ON A THREE TO ONE
VOTE WITH ONE ABSENT THANK YOU.
SB TWELVE SIXTY LAYARD. THREE
ONE THE BILL WAS OUT ON THE
THREE TO ONE WITH ONE ABSENT. SB
THIRTY SIXTY FOUR LAYERED. THE
BILLS OUT ON THE THREE ONE VOTE
S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY FORTY SOUTH
AND THREE ONE BOTH. WITH ONE
ABSENT. IN A RUDE GESTURE WE ARE
PERMANENT WINDOWS HAVE FOR ALL
THIS I WANT TO DO THIS. WE ARE
TURN. RIGHT THAT WAS EASY.